foreign
i'd like to welcome all our public and
that's attending today to the education
committee and members of the education
committee there are a few announcements
which we have before we get into the
first hearing
tomorrow we are going to not be using
this room of course we have session down
in manchester
but before we leave today everything
needs to be taken off the tops these
tables are coming in to give this room a
total scrub down
from
walls everything and so this that will
occur tomorrow so
we have been in the habit of leaving our
stuff here i've done the same thing and
it's been a lot easier but please today
when you head home
take everything with you or put it in
your your file
areas out in the area here
also for you that we do have two desks
out there in the in the office area
we're not using the we our
administrative assistant is not using
that desk lindsay is course down the
hallway a couple doors down on the
right-hand side so if somebody has to do
some work you may go in there and use
the desk that judy was once sitting at
and that's that's available i think
that'll work even better for us seeing
that lindsay so close to us we get that
service and that support
and we can also use the room
for what what we need
so today we have several bills coming up
for hearing the first bill uh is hb 607
prohibiting unlawful discrimination in
public and non-public schools
do it after a representant representing
do it after you present the bill please
so i'd like to well i'll welcome
represent to to uh the committee to
introduce the bill thank you
thank you very much mr chair um my name
is linda tanner representative
for the district 9 in sullivan county
the towns of plainfield cornish
croydon grantham
springfield sunapee newport and unity
today i bring before you a bill
1607 that prohibits unlawful
discrimination in public and non-public
schools
this bill addresses
the admission of students when they're
having a change of school or assignment
under expanded choices offered by the
education scholarship tax credits and
freedom accounts
it involves
an addition to the rsa 193 colon 3
which deals with the change of school
or assignment
section 6 of 1933
spells out the procedures
for the change of school or assignment
for school boards if there is no public
school that offers the child's grade
in the resident district
these are schools that only offer
elementary grades
uh like to grade four or
uh through eighth or ninth grade middle
school
section 193 3
6 and 7
allows the school board to contract and
allow an assignment of a child to
another public school private school or
religious school or a school approved as
a school tuition program using tax money
we now have the freedom accounts the
education tax credit and the scholarship
programs
which also allow public funds to be used
to enroll children in public private
religious tuition programs or home
school
parents sometimes find out that the
reality of these programs is that the
ultimate choice
resides with the school or educational
program not with the parent
we need to look at protecting these
families who are rejected
public funds require public
accountability
our community public school system
is governed by federal and state laws
that prohibit discrimination
public schools accept all students
private religious
and schools for tuition programs do not
have to abide by the state these laws
only public schools and schools
accepting federal funding
parents who want to enroll their student
in a certain school
because of their program
or perhaps the location of the school
can be turned away because their child
is transgender or gay
the child may have some discipline
problems disabilities
emotional or mental issues
imagine a child with a simple
with a disability
maybe they're deaf
or their wheelchair bound or maybe they
have two moms
they've spent six years in a community
public elementary school
and their school and classmates have
accepted them
supported them and nurtured them
their school has specialists they have
ramps or elevators they have special
bathroom facilities to meet their needs
as required for all public schools
time in their school has come to an end
or their parent has decided they want to
move the child out of the school
and the child must move to another
school
during the year there was a presentation
the efa program and now they even have
more choices
maybe that nice private school in the
next town over
or a nearby religious school or a
tuition
program school that looks like an
attractive place for their child
this child wants to stay with his or her
friends
so their parents did decide to enroll
their child
with their friends
but this child is not accepted at the
school
they did not meet
the admission criteria
the school is very sorry but the child
isn't
a good fit
perhaps another school would be better
and they'd be willing to help them find
another school
the rejecting school is under no law or
mandate to accept everybody or anybody
who applies
they are not subject to laws prohibiting
them from discriminating
except in the general areas of race
color and national origin
special needs students students who need
extra help
students who may have parents who are
gay transgender
can and will suffer discrimination
this bill would require those schools
who take public funds to follow the new
hampshire discrimination
in public school law rsa 193 colon 38
and on the handout i gave you
there is a
the description of the law
the bill ex this bill extends those
protections for children who now
will be seeking education outside the
public school system
so that no child will be refused
admission because of discrimination
the responsibility for ensuring these
protections
will be with the department of education
and the state board of education
the state board of education and the
department of education currently can
provide a hearing
and appeals procedure as it does for
issues
under 193 colon 3
and sections 1
through
7.
so
um
what i have here is a bill that will
extend the discrimination protections
the to the protected classes listed in
the new hampshire law
many of the protections that you'll see
that are under the
civil
civil liberties area
in
in statute
are more and federal statute are more
concerned with
race religion
age
and those
are for employment and housing
so this extends it to the school system
whereas the other ones like i said are
for employment and housing
and i'll entertain any questions
thank you very much representative are
there questions for representative
tanner yes representative
thank you
um
the way i read this it means if there's
a small private school for gifted kids
that a child
that the parents of a child who say have
certain mental disabilities or whatever
at any rate
otherwise don't really fit into what
that school is aimed for
can demand that their child goes there
because otherwise they're being
discriminated against based on
mental disability
if
they apply to that school and that
school receives public funding
our our taxpayer dollars
then they should be accepted to that
school with uh
special um
needs special
accommodations i guess is what i would
say
yes go ahead
um so in public schools
do they never
send a kid out to someplace else because
they feel like they the kid has
whatever issues that they can't deal
with they do but they pay for it
and they they oversee it
the schools that we're talking about
would not do that
well
because they wouldn't have the student
then so how could they
i'm is this a catch-22
apparently yes
i think if there's a robotic school
and you know we oftentimes we think of
robotics as being
you know the
the higher end kids that are you know
into stem and that sort of thing and
somebody with a disability wants to
apply to that
that they shouldn't be discriminated
against just for that disability
further further questions
yes representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative um
could you define what your intention is
by use of the words public funds
sure
i think uh
when money is collected by the
government it's collected from the
people of the state
it's collected
through taxation
and a number of other different ways and
it becomes public money and it is our
duty as representatives
we have a duty to spend that money as
efficiently and as effectively and as
transparently
as we can and that's what i consider
public funds
follow up go ahead uh thank you um
would that include federal
funds yes those are public funds as well
representative luna do you have a
question
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much for uh for taking my question
for offering um this introducing this
bill this morning representative tanner
can charter schools currently um
um
let me make sure i use the term right um
lawfully discriminate against the
protected classes that you've listed
here you know i was looking that up
thank you for that question
representative uno um
in 2021 we actually uh put into law that
public schools have to follow the
non-discrimination or the
anti-discrimination laws
outlined in in 193
colon 38
and since charter schools are considered
public schools
um you would think that it would apply
um although they weren't specifically
tagged in that in that statute and if
that's the case that that it doesn't
apply to them
then we should extend it to them
thank you very much further questions
representative i have uh one question
for you
we have a number of schools that are
small schools in the state that do
tuition their students out after fifth
fourth grade fifth grade sixth grade etc
to
other public schools
there is one situation that i know of
that there is a public high school that
will
accept all the kids from these k-4
programs or k-6
however within that same tuition
agreement of those sending schools there
are some schools that refuse to accept
some students
i don't give any names out but that is
the situation occurs so would the public
schools that are
not receiving certain types of students
be
have a problem with this whereas the
sending school also though has a tuition
agreement with a public high school that
will take the kids so there is an
opportunity for tuitioning out
you're following where i'm coming yes i
am and i think it's in your neighborhood
okay well it could could very well be in
my neighborhood i don't want to point
fingers but i would say that um to me
that's not
that's one of the things why this bill
is important
i will say that my local school
accepts quite a few
students for on tuition from other
schools because it's one of the more
higher performing schools in the
in the state
as it does
they do refuse students but they refuse
them because they don't have room
they set a certain
size limit on their classes
and they will
accept tuition students up to a certain
number but as far as who they accept
if they're a public school
and if they're under this law
accepting public funding through
efas tax credit scholarships
the education freedom accounts
then they need to
not discriminate against students
because they have a disability
or because they're transgender or
because they're gay or uh the economic
or social situation of their parents or
that they've had
uh problems before with discipline in
other schools
and i i have one other follow-up
question
uh when we are sending our students out
from a
sending school to a career technical
education center the cte may reject some
students based upon prerequisites
i would imagine that is not going to be
an issue with this yes you've written
this discrimination revolves around
protected classes people that have
suffered discrimination in the past
classes that have suffered
discrimination in the past
or there's a history of discrimination
and therefore the government steps in
and provides non-discrimination laws so
that those people have
access
particularly in the public
public sphere and they can function as
any other citizen in in the united
states rather than being excluded
or treated differently so in follow-up
to that when we're looking at one of the
categories is a mental disability
and a student is rejected going to the
cte center seeing that that student has
not
does not have the prerequisites to get
in that program that's done all over
this state would this
be implied or seen as a rejection due to
mental disability or would it be seen as
a rejection due to
not having the prerequisite courses
that's something with discrimination
charges
and hearings that
you know are those kind of thready lines
that uh people uh need to to examine and
find out exactly what what the
what the situation is and whether it is
prerequisites
thank you
further follow uh questions
representative cordelli
uh thank you
how would you see the state board of
education um enforcing um these
provisions
the same way they enforce
the hearings
for manifest hardship
where a parent wishes to send their
school student to another school
and
the school that's
providing that um they can actually ask
for a hearing and i think that's
that's where
it should be in the it's around public
education and i know ols
wanted to put this under the civil
rights commission but
it really is an educational issue it
needs to be dealt with in education in
my opinion
yes
but
we did uh put uh educational description
excuse me discrimination also under uh
the human rights uh
provisions um in uh
rsa 354.
just wondering why
those
protections are not
sufficient in the human rights
commission has
is set up to do uh investigations and
hold hearings uh why not there their
investigations and and their focus
is employment public accommodations it's
not
specific to education and and it can
deal with education but it's not
specific to education and therefore the
state school board
uh that that
offers hearings and adjudicates a lot of
issues in education
can and could do this um and i know
uh they may not want to
um but i think that's where it belongs
represented woodcock
good morning thank you for thanking my
question uh i missed your intro i got
here a little late and trying things on
shovels here
how did this align itself with governor
sununu's discrimination
committee he had a year or two ago in
terms of anti-discrimination well the
you know we we know that the the finding
of that commission
um
told us about the the discrimination or
how students felt uh discriminated
against in public schools
being transgender or gay in particular
but for other reasons as well i mean
kids get bullied for a lot of different
reasons
this extends a little bit further and
extends to particularly school choice
that expands to school choices i said
before we already put in law that public
schools have to follow
the non-discrimination laws of new
hampshire
which are much more extensive than the
federal laws
thank you thank you chairman
thank you representative moffett thank
you michelle thank you taking my
question i asked this question as a
former teacher at trinity high school
where i went to after being in a public
school where i worked on the ieps with
the special education staff now with
trinity when i went there a long time
ago
they had no special ed staff they had no
special ed students per se like the
public schools did it was as i read this
proposed measure
a school like trinity or private school
charter school i'm thinking of the
little school representative porter
described this used to run
as i read this
if
any of these schools receive public
funds directly or indirectly it sounds
like they have to
accept special needs students and ergo
would have to create
special ed staffs or hire special ed
educators is that said am i reading that
correctly yeah you're reading that
correctly because if they accept public
funds
then
that means that they should be open
and not discriminate and if
they
trinity exists because people pay
people pay their own money to send their
child to trinity
uh they want a religious education a
catholic education and
that's why they send them there and
that's fine i mean it's it's fine if i
want to use a toll highway and pay the
toll for it that's that's great but the
interstate highways are open to
everybody and that's how that's how
america is it's not
uh
setting up classes of you know people
that can't
go to certain schools
and still exist for the on the public
funds public funds are for public good
they they're for the public okay if it
doesn't say those schools can't exist
doesn't say that they can't run it says
that if they accept public funding then
they have to follow the
non-discrimination laws
well what yes
thank you so
do you have any concern that like some
of the smaller schools that are on very
tight tight margins
and have special missions or special
focus
and again i go back to the school that
representative porter described several
times you're concerned that some of
these little schools that are on margins
if suddenly they have to hire special ed
staff they would go out of business
is that
any concern well you know we're in a
capitalist society and if we're going to
put education in the consumer base then
we have to deal with the issues that
capital capitalism and consumerism
uh provides for us
thank you
further further questions from the
committee yes representative porter
can i can i reply to representative
moffat
no we're not going to go this way
representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for bringing this to us
today
so um
i i'm i'm making an assumption and i'm
going to ask you to either
correct me or agree with my perception
that
if you're applying to a school
and one of the prerequisites as
representative vlad uh
indicated it let's say it's a polish
speaking school
and you're applying to the polish
and you also happen to
be gay
if you're applying to the polish
speaking school and you speak polish and
you're gay
that's different than applying to the
polish speaking school
being gay and not speaking polish
so if you were denied admission to the
school because you didn't speak polish
that would not be considered
discrimination is that correct to me
that would be a prerequisite
um and i think uh
the examples you gave are are right on
okay thank you
representative cordelli do you have a
question yes thank you uh just wondering
about your
thoughts on public schools that reject
students
i know of
at least one case where
the child
received best interest
determination by their local school
district
applied to two local public school
systems and was rejected by them
um
child had disability i don't know if
that was a factor or not
and also if you take a look at our open
enrollment uh statute um it provides the
ability to um accept students or not
accept students based on academic
criteria
um how do
how would that fit into um this
legislation um thank you for the
question representative cordelli i i
in fact one of the things that kind of
sparked my mind
was that very testimony that we had here
in this committee
it was under manifest hardship and the
parent came in and was very distressed
that she had fought quite a bit
for her child
on manifest hardship
to get this the public school she was
going to to
relocate her to to another public school
which she did through hearings with the
state school board
she then
the school that the child wanted to go
to the local public or another public
school nearby that the child wanted to
go to child was rejected
and i think if this law were in place
and the child was rejected because
of the disability
then i think they would have another
quite another case as well i don't think
that was fair
rep san luna and just a quick follow-up
on that thank you very much mr chair um
isn't it true that um that when a a
student
is is is placed or
requests a reassignment through manifest
hardship from one
school district to another school
district that if that student has an iep
the whole the district of residence
covers the cost associated with that
individualized educational
plan
yes thanks for that question yes it does
um we we've had that numerous times so
that that's definitely true
further questions rep senator tanner i
have one for you sure would you believe
would you believe that we have
and talked about the same scenario that
representative cordelli and represent
luna have
addressed
with a student that comes from is in
district a and would like to go to
district b
that
we have a statute which allows district
b to refuse that
if there's carrying forth
and they want to go enroll in that
school and they're not
not a resident of that school district
the school district can reject
that individual from coming in due to
the fact
that ongoing costs are going to be
incumbent on that citizenry
and uh so
the end result is
that
many schools are no longer accepting
students from a
ascending district those that are out of
district schools will not accept those
from another district would you believe
that to be the case um and not
discriminatory
i guess i guess my feeling on that
particular scenario where you're saying
they don't accept them because they're
not residents of the area
i think
we have a public school system
that's set up on
providing free open public education to
students within their
district within their
geographic area that's that's their
charge
um that's the charge of
uh free public education
that's like a cornerstone of democracy
and i think that um
we've now made public we've now made
public education fluid
because we've made public education and
public dollars fluid
and once we started doing that then i
think we need a law like this to cover
situations where discrimination plays in
otherwise we're going to get you know i
remember seeing a cartoon one time that
said you know that the new school is you
know a blue school a red school a yellow
school a green school and only green
people can go to green school
and it silos everybody whereas the
public schools are a melting pot they're
they're america they're a foundation of
america
and that's what this is intended to keep
so i i really didn't get a response to
my question is it
is it uh okay for a receiving school to
say no we're not going to take this
student this could eventually be a
catastrophic aid situation in which this
small district you want to go to cannot
come up with the 250 000 annually well
that's just what representative luna was
pointing out that this ascending school
is responsible for the iep
and the iep is what designates whether
it's an out of district placement or not
or whether
you know whatever is going to happen and
they assume
the responsibility for that
iep
and i'm going to follow up just one more
step on that would you believe that the
iep is being addressed in the present
school district however not to the level
that the parent accepts
so they're looking next door to another
district and they want that district to
deliver the service they want
the receiving district in this case
i believe should have the right to
reject that enrollment of that student
do you believe the same um i believe
that special ed has a system set up
a very good system set up and we're
we've been tweaking it right along to
address issues like this and i think
that that is a very specific issue that
isn't necessarily
um
indicative or representative of this
bill that i'm putting forth i think
that's a specialized area i think it's a
special situation
and we have uh all kinds of of ways to
adjudicate that through our special ed
uh division thank you
just
real quickly mr chair i think when um uh
as as testimony continues on on this
bill that might be a very good question
to take up with school boards
association that i think we worked
collaboratively with we have discussed
this issue regarding special ed and that
many many times here
and there are some real significant
financial issues associated with it but
i think we could get into a technical i
think we can do that thank you uh
represent woodcock did you have your
hand up
yeah thank you chairman uh thank you for
taking another question you're getting
varieties over there i was thinking
about the the uh scenario that chairman
ladd presented
uh within my district this is factual
within my district we have multiple
small little towns and each town pays
for the small little school before they
go to high school uh we have one town
that is is more successful uh
academically and has more resources to
put in there
uh
if
our other towns want to transfer the
youngst to that separate school school
district in that region
and they are categorically saying no
because the local people say no we're
paying the proportion of the for our
children would that be discrimination if
they say no across the board
discrimination depends on protected
classes and that's what the law does
so
a school district
that has
my school district has the ability
wants has voted and wanted the ability
to take in students as tuition
they're allowed to set parameters on how
many they can take
under this law they could not refuse
them if they came if it was specific to
a protected class
okay thank you
representative mullen then
representative porter
quick one mr chair thank you uh
representative thank you for taking my
question so
this
i'm looking at the section that has to
do with the duties of the state board of
education and i'm looking at the
additions of
a variety of other
classes that were not in the original
protected classes that were not in the
original definition
am i correct that the definition that is
here already appears in other places in
new hampshire statute as the list of
protected classes yes
kind of a follow-up yes
and that our public schools use this
definition of protected classes in
determining whether or not
somebody is being discriminated against
right as as indicated in my handout 193
colon 38
is the is that and
it's also provided in rsa
354-a colon 27-28
so why wouldn't we ex expect the state
board of education to follow the
definition of discrimination and
protected classes i do no why wouldn't
we expect the state board of edge oh you
do you do expect them i do okay all
right thank you i thought you were
saying something
different thank you representative
porter
thank you mr chair and thank you for
this bill representative tiener so
i'm trying to figure out what might
happen to
a school a public school
if
the
education freedom account program
becomes wildly popular
and
the children who stay
at the public school
are the ones who
the other schools won't accept the kids
that have learning disabilities or the
kids that have
disrupted families or bad behavior or
need to be toileted and have their
diapers changed and those type of things
that those are the children who are left
in the public school um
could that is is that a
scenario that could possibly happen
if things if this bill is not enacted
well um thank you for that question um
when i was in college i worked a couple
of summers at state schools one in
pennsylvania and one in massachusetts
and i think we all
have at least some
historical perspective on what state
schools were
a warehouse for the disabled the
warehouse for the
handicapped warehouse for the poor in
many instances the mentally incompetent
and
and we know
that our our society has totally
rejected that
and um
understands how these people are
our people
and they are
can be productive
uh
to whatever level they can be
in society and i certainly would hate to
see
our public schools become
uh
a ghost of that i guess
on some level
further questions of representative
tanner
not cnn hands thank you very much you're
welcome thank you
uh we would like to have next uh
represent
just
they'll flow around
thank you
thank you chairman and uh good morning
members of the house education committee
for the record my name is matt wilhelm i
proudly represent hillsborough county
district 42
uh covers manchester words one two and
three the north end historic milliard in
downtown
of the queen city
i'm here today to express my support for
house bill 1607 of which i'm a proud
co-sponsor
um
this is this is not a debate today about
uh educational
freedom savings accounts uh that's not
what is up for debate this morning house
bill 1607 makes clear that any and all
public monies spent on education in the
state of new hampshire
shall not be used to discriminate
against granite staters on the basis of
sex gender identity sexual orientation
race color marital status physical or
mental disability religious creed
national origin
or economic status and this is the
policy for all public schools in new
hampshire
if a private or religious school
receives public funding it should be
held to the same standards and be
required to adopt
an identical all-inclusive
non-discrimination policy as public
neighborhood and public charter schools
do
private and religious schools in around
my district have different
non-discrimination policies
they may all
sound inclusive but
the question we should be asking is
what are they leaving out of their
non-discrimination policy
take a religious high school in
manchester as an example as posted on
the school's website it quote
admits students of any race color
national and ethnic origin to all the
rights privileges programs and
activities generally accorded or made
available to students at the school it
does not discriminate on the basis of
race color national and ethnic origin
and administration of its educational
policies admissions policies scholarship
and loan programs
and athletic and other school
programs end quote
it's a good start
but what protects this high school's
students and prospective students and
their staff for that matter
from being discriminated against
and new hampshire residents from having
their tax dollars used
to exclude young people from attending
the school on the basis of sex
gender identity sexual orientation
physical or mental disability religious
creed or economic status
take a private school at my district
there's a different school this one's
non-religious uh as another example on
its website it says there shall be no
discrimination because of race color
religion
national origin sex sexual orientation
gender identity age or handicap status
applied by the school or the school's
board of trustees in violation of
applicable law in the employment of
personnel and the admission of students
in the offering of instruction and
programs or in the election of trustees
again it's a good start
uh it's a good start but what protects
students or
prospective students of this private
school from being discriminated against
on the basis of physical or mental
disability or economic status granite
staters deserve to know that their tax
dollars will not be used to exclude
young people from attending schools that
discriminate against students or their
families for any reason
or denies them benefits in educational
programs activities and employment
practices
under current law and in reading the
posted policies of many private and
religious schools across our state
discrimination discrimination against
our young people appears to be legal
it's not the new hampshire way and we
have an obligation and an opportunity
today to do something about it
if non-public schools wish to receive
public funds then we should fully expect
them to not discriminate against their
students potential students staff
administrators or board members
otherwise school choice
should be limited to public charter
schools which as public schools it's my
understanding that they're held to the
same basic standards of decency
inclusion and non-discrimination as
every other public school in our state i
know i'm not alone in my belief that it
is completely reasonable expectation
that taxpayer dollars should be
prohibited from being used to
discriminate against our children
colleagues i urge you to send house bill
1607 to the house floor with a strong
bipartisan recommendation of ought to
pass to ensure that all new hampshire
schools whether neighborhood schools
public charter schools private schools
and religious schools they're all hailed
to the same standards of decency
inclusion and non-discrimination when it
comes to serving and supporting our
children regardless of sex gender
identity sexual orientation race color
marital status physical or mental
disability religious creed national
origin or economic status
with that i'll take your questions thank
you
representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative
um
you mentioned economic status and it's
mentioned in several places in the
legislation
um so a a private school let's say the
holderness academy or
um
other private uh institution
should be required
to accept
say a student who has
a
two thousand dollar scholarship from the
tax credit scholarship program
that student should be admitted
um regardless of their ability to pay
tuition uh that's correct i think it's
incumbent upon the institution uh the
educational institution to provide
uh additional scholarship funds so that
student can attend if they're accepting
public monies they should not be able to
discriminate on economic status
yes
could you explain how a tax credit
scholarship is a public money
uh
thank you representative for the
question um
i will say this i'm not i'm not an
expert in
education funding
in the state of new hampshire
but i will say that if there are public
public funds that flow into in you know
any educational institution
uh
then that we should have some basic
expectations for transparency
and non-discrimination thanks further
questions for the representative
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
i'd like to invite
emma sevigny
welcome emma
thank you thank you chairman and
honorable members of the committee
my name is emma savini i
am here as the children's behavioral
health policy coordinator for new
futures
new futures is a non-partisan nonprofit
organization that advocates educates and
collaborates to improve the health and
wellness of all new hampshire residents
i'm here in support of house bill 1607
which would expand the duty of the state
board of education to ensure that all
new hampshire students have equal access
to educational resources
in any
institution or program that accepts
public funds
first this bill is important because it
would affect and improve the overall
health and wellness of new hampshire's
youth by addressing inequity in
education
this would expand the duty of the state
board of education to ensure no unlawful
discrimination in any private school
tuition program or educational service
program which receives public funds
um
would reduce the
any discrimination and therefore offer
all students the ability to access
public education or private education
regardless of many of the protected
statuses that you've heard today
education is one of the social
determinants of health and therefore
when students are able to access
better education and educational
resources their overall health and
wellness also improves
second house bill 1607 addresses
educational
inequity by expanding the protected
populations to include gender identity
sexual orientation religious creed and
physical or mental disability it is
estimated that approximately 8 000
students in new hampshire identify
identify as part of the lgbt
lgbtq plus community
and that 450 approximately identify as
transgender additionally 15.3 percent of
new hampshire students in public schools
have received some form of special
education
historically these populations have
struggled to access resources
and therefore have had lower academic
successes and i've cited some resources
that you can follow up on or i'm happy
to provide further resources if you have
any questions on that
expanded the expanding these protections
to these
protected classes would strengthen their
ability to reach the same academic
successes as their counterparts and
again this would contribute to their
overall health and wellness
for these reasons new futures strongly
supports house bill 1607 and would
recommend that this committee
recommend it to the full houses ought to
pass
i'm happy to take any questions thank
you very much other questions for new
futures
not seni seeing nay thank you very much
thank you you're welcome
next card i have here is steven and beth
scarer
i see are both uh related so um and you
have down three and three so it means
each one of you has about three minutes
a piece okay thank you
hi i'm steven scare 111 east hobart
street in nashua
and i'm here as a private citizen asking
you to oppose
and i'm especially concerned about the
wording regarding gender
identity a girl
is a young human female and a female is
a person bearing two x chromosomes in
the cell nuclei and normally having a
uterus and ovaries
a boy is a young human male
no one
can provide a substantially different
definition of a boy or a girl that
doesn't rely on circular reasoning or
gender stereotypes
so one question before this committee
is whether the state should coerce
private schools
including religious schools to pretend
that girls are boys
and boys our girls by withholding funds
until recently it would have been
self-evidently wrong to try to force
people to act and speak against reason
and conscience in order to spare
someone's feelings
and gender identity laws have quickly
made a farce of woman sports
as big strong men run away with women's
trophies
but i especially ask the committee to
consider the carnage caused by passing
laws promoting gender ideology
i had a brilliant but troubled niece
who has persuaded she could transition
into a boy and all her problems would be
solved
with a cross-sex hormone solved nothing
they left her body irreversibly damaged
mr chair
how was this directed to the to the bill
i think he said in terms of in terms of
non-discrimination
well it talks about gender identity in
this bill and he's talking to gender
identity so this is not a bill about
about gender identity this is a bill
about non-discrimination
she fell into addiction and homelessness
she died of an overdose at 21 days
just after talking about suicide
advocates of child transgenderism claim
detransitioners and people that have
trouble adjusting
didn't get the support they needed from
their families
but the almost 26 000 members
of the detransition subreddit page tell
a different story
the transitioners recount how they had
trouble fitting in with other girls
because they didn't fit stereotypes how
they were drawn into transgenderism by
the social media and how they were
rushed through medicalization by
therapists and physicians who didn't
explore whether the gender dysphoria was
a result of other mental health
disorders
detransitioned women
discussed regrets from being sterilized
having their breasts amputated
[Music]
and dealing with
hold on please
go ahead
this is nothing to do with this bill
this is just a rant about
gender discriminator about about gender
identity discrimination and i don't
think this kind of hateful talk is
appropriate in front of this committee
if they want to talk about the bill i
have no problem but a rant about gender
identity discrimination is inappropriate
it's hateful it's wrong and i don't
think it should continue in this room
thank you uh would you please now
address the the bill that we have in
front of us that discrimination
for
sending a student or in another
placement
and and and you've gotten your point
across regarding gender identity
they were too
so so mr chair mr chair
hold on represent luna he's going to be
done in about 10 seconds
would you go ahead and focus your
conclusion on the bill please
you tell them
thank you
uh will we have now some testimony from
beth scarar
and please i i do not want you to repeat
where we have been
address the bill please
thank you
beth scare from nashua um i'm speaking
today in opposition to 1607 which would
bring to all schools that accept from
public funds the same devastating
consequences for women's sports
that have already occurred in new
hampshire's public schools
new hampshire women athletes are losing
to men in sports men who have gone
through male puberty
and who are much stronger and faster
than the women they're excuse me mr
chair
go ahead
uh
this bill does not deal with women's
sports this d bill deals with whether or
not public funds can be used to pay the
tuition for students in private or
religious schools
we're looking at discrimination of a
receiving school denying acceptance
uh based upon a student's
characteristics that we've had here
gender sex identity et cetera
please focus on that i read in the bill
that it prohibited any discrimination i
assumed that meant all the schools
programs all public and all private yep
so this is about a public program
this is about school programs where they
have sports
a sports program at a school or an
excuse me mental chair
rips on luna i'm the best very specific
on on the protector if there is a
receiving school has a sports program
and we've had that discussion before
even when this was not a topic
of the student going to the school that
might be a great hockey player and
another student that has an iep
we were trying to keep the
uh on
accepting both students not just one
while we need a forward and the hockey
team and we're going to deny the iep
because of this that's clear
discrimination we've had that
discussion here many times in past years
i don't see any problem with where we're
going with this discussion that beth is
presenting at this time
go ahead
so in the new england outdoor track and
field championships in
2017 andrea yearwood a biological male
from connecticut
came in second katya lavisher a woman
from manchester central high came in
seventh
in the new england interscholastic track
and field championships in 2019 terry
miller a biological male from
connecticut came in first
grace devonnie a woman from concord high
came in seventh
in her testimony in support of a bill to
protect women's sports eria jerovati the
head coach for girls track at manchester
memorial high and girls cross country
coach at windham high an older sister of
katja lavissura said she wants to be a
voice for those girls who feels if they
will not be heard on this issue of
justice
an excerpt of her testimony i worry
about what girls sports may look like 10
or 20 years down the line when we're
accepting a roster full of biological
male athletes who want to compete
against
female athletes
i worry about how it will affect our
young women in their confidence
as they lose to a field of young men
posing as their peers
we claim to be a country that is for
women for our success and equality yet
coming before you to help support this
this bill a bill that some will oppose
feels as though we have taken giant
strides backwards in history leaving
title ix meaningless
in all the years i've coached female
athletes never would have imagined i'd
be standing before you today pleading
for the rights of my athletes to simply
compete fairly in their own sports
because these two biological males live
in connecticut the situation for women's
sports in that state is even much more
dire
according to alliance defending freedom
two males have taken 15 women state
championship titles
and more than 85 opportunities to
participate in higher level competitions
from female track athletes
women deserve better than to have men
dominate in their school sports please
vote itl and hb 1607 thank you thank you
very much other questions for those
presenting to us
not seeing thank you very much
the next individual is
that's different bill
okay megan tuttle
megan here
good morning chairman lad members of the
house education committee um i'll keep
this short i do have written testimony
that i'll pass in as well
megan tuttle for the record president of
nea new hampshire representing 17 000
educators across the state um and a
eighth grade social studies teacher here
to testify in support of hospital 1607
relative to prohibiting unlawful
discrimination in public and non-public
schools according to the new hampshire
supreme court new hampshire constitution
guarantees all students a right to
inadequate public education
if we're going to use the public funds
designated to help provide that
constitutional right those providers and
institutions accepting those dollars
should not discriminate against a child
for any of the reasons laid out in the
piece of legislation before you today we
must hold every school to the same
standard in this regard whether public
or private house bill 1607 makes it
crystal clear that the state board of
education our board of directors for
education in new hampshire
must ensure that the protected classes
listed in the bill are shielded from
discrimination
we hope and urges committee will ensure
swift passage of house bill 1607 so our
state makes clear that when we're
committing public funds toward our
students future the right to an
education that every student has a
chance to seize that opportunity thank
you very much are there questions for ms
tuttle
yes representative cordelli
thank you maybe
you could help me with the question i
asked previously
um how are tax credit scholarships
public funds
um i'm not either a
expert on the education funding i
understand most of it um but if any our
belief is any school that's getting any
public money and if tax credits come
from any sort of public money they
shouldn't there shouldn't be any
discrimination
uh any further questions of ms tuttle
nancy thank you very much
have a good morning thank you too you're
welcome
uh
representative cannon
here
welcome representative
thank you mr chair and fellow
representatives for listening to me this
morning
for the record my name is representative
jerry cannon i represent stratfor county
district 18 i also sit on the
summersworth school board
i'm a transgender leader in new
hampshire
as well as in the ucc church
i've been asked by many parents
of transgender children to help in
situations where their transgender child
faces discrimination from school boards
or school administration in public and
non-public schools
i'm raising this
although it may not be clear from my
handout
is that we're starting to see
educational freedom accounts being used
to
to fund non-public schools but we're
also
running into situations that go beyond
the original scope of our
of the statutes that we've already put
in place
a situation that i
was made aware of shortly after becoming
a school board member
is that a local religious school
had run into a situation
where a senior
came out as a transgender man
the
non-public school a religious school
tried to
convince that student not to come out
as a transgender
male the parents were fully supportive
of this child
ultimately the school banned that
student from the school
as well as
the property
that the school existed on
there was no
ability for the local school boards of
that community to input into the system
and that's that student was
discriminated against
and
they did find a public school
to take them in with open arms
not in new hampshire
they ended up going to maine
in another other situations i've run
into is that parents have come to me
where local school boards have taken the
new hampshire school board association's
policy on support of
transgender students and environment
and have modified it to the point
where the community has decided that any
student that's coming out as lgbt
should be reported to the students
parents
even if the student is in the process of
just trying to understand their gender
identity
or
sexual orientation
in this hearing the discussion this
morning
i've heard a number of
things about students
transferring to other schools and i've
been involved with the process where a
student was being bullied in one
environment and had to move to another
and it
those discussions come to the school
boards to make a decision because
those local communities need to fund
that student going to another school and
that school the school they're targeting
they're going to also has to accept
that student in response to your
question representative ladd
both school systems need to be in
agreement
that they can transfer
i also ran into a situation where we did
have a student with an iep that wanted
to transfer to a local
another community
and we ended up working on an
arrangement where the paraprofessional
associated with giving the care to that
student
also was was moved
and we split the cost on the
the paraprofessional being in that other
unit sau
the challenge
we're running into and we'll see more of
as as we spend educational freedom
account money
to other schools is to ensure that the
policies related to
anti-discrimination for all students
is it here to
and the question is come up about tax
dollars being spent in here
my my opinion
is that the educational freedom account
would not exist if it weren't for
taxpayer dollars
so these are taxpayer dollars being used
to fund education
through an alternative mechanism
and so i feel that we're spending
the same money we would on a public
school as we would for non-public school
and they should adhere to the same
statutes a public school needs to as far
as non-discrimination
i urge you to vote not to pass on this
bill
thank you very much representative
cannon uh are there
questions of the representative
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you for listening
from the human rights commission
welcome
okay
good morning uh
chairland and to the rest of the
education committee
my name is ani malachi i'm the director
of the human rights commission
i had not planned to speak i was simply
going to listen
to see if there was any clarification
that might be needed relative to
anti-discrimination
statutes and here we are so um there
have been a lot of points that have been
made this morning
um my focus is certainly not going to be
on rsa 193 that is not my lip my area of
expertise
excuse me
however um looking at
this piece of legislation um
house bill 1607
um
in looking at that through the lens of
the human rights commission
with the language that is being sought
to be added to rsa 193
and dealing with the state board of
education to be the
adjudicator or the enforcer of the
additional language
it is my belief that this will create
confusion
there isn't a mechanism specifically
expressly discussed here as to how if
someone's been
if they feel they've been discriminated
against how they would go about
making that claim and then walking
through that process
and
although representative tanner did state
that the human rights commission does
handle
public accommodation employment and
housing we are set up to handle
education as of 2019 the legislature
decided that that was part of our
jurisdictional authority and it was
something that we needed to be
responsible for and therefore we are
so adding education
which means k through 12 education
public schools are included and i
believe if if the scheme of what a
public school is under edu under the
department of education if it includes
charter schools then charter schools are
included what is not expressly included
in our in our statute
is private schools or non-public schools
and if that's something that the
legislature decides that we need to do
then that's up to you all we will abide
by whatever you've added to our statute
to then have authority over and to
enforce
the anti-discrimination laws
as they would read in our statute
to add to that
we are and have been set up to receive a
claim
to pass on a claim
or and if we do receive it then we also
have the authority and the expertise to
do the investigation that's necessary
and then to move that along by offering
mediation by having conversations with
both parties by then moving forward with
a charge
excuse me with a finding of
discrimination if the investigation
warrants that as well as allowing for a
public hearing
if the individual decided they wanted to
take it to court they have that
opportunity and the way that the statute
was written when it when education was
added to the human rights commission it
allowed for what the lawyers in the room
would call a true choice of forum which
means that if i'm a parent and i have an
issue
i feel my child is being discriminated
against and i don't want to go to the
commission i want to take it to court
because i have a a lawyer that's going
to represent me i can go right to court
and you follow that court process or if
they decided they needed to do something
through the attorney general's office
they have the opportunity
to do that
however if they decided they wanted to
come to the commission they can
certainly do that excuse me they could
certainly do that as well
we do not charge any fees we are a state
funded and we do have some partial
funding from the federal government
specifically in the area of employment
and you do not have to have an attorney
to move through our process what some
individuals will do is file a charge and
once it's been accepted sometimes an
attorney will pick them up and represent
them throughout the remainder of our
process
there are also times where someone once
they've received a probable cause
finding then they will find an attorney
and
once you have probable cause there's
still another opportunity to mediate
and that means it's really called
conciliation at that point where if the
parent
simply wants the behavior to stop or
they want the child to be included in
whatever it is then they have that
opportunity um again all of this is free
of charge because we are funded by uh
the state primarily uh basically it's an
8515 split
with that being said religious
organizations
which are not just i think when we hear
the word religious organization we
automatically assume christian but if
it's a hindu organization a muslim
organization a jewish organization an
employer
a club
a
school even a group
educational
opportunity
all of those are exempt which
therein allows people to if you're
working
in a secular position and you have a and
you're requiring a religious exemption
then there are
guidelines and
areas of the statute that specify for
religious exemptions if i'm an employee
and there are also employers that are
religious entities and they have
exemptions that are provided for in our
statute as well
should someone have
any issues under and then they are a
member of a protected class and they
have questions or concerns uh they think
they might be being discriminated
against then they should absolutely
reach out to the commission and we can
field those questions
we do have people that
may feel so i think someone mentioned
ieps and although we do handle education
ieps are not our area of expertise and
if we had a situation and there could
potentially be something where
a child's iep is not being fully met
and the reason for that could be
discriminatory so
if that were the situation and the
parent filed a charge with us and we
took that charge because it seemed clear
that there was some discriminatory
action as to why the child's iep wasn't
being met we would handle the
discriminate the area of discrimination
that we have jurisdiction over and we
would work with the department of
education to deal with the iep uh to
your point chairman ladd yes there are
parents who want
an iep
handled in a particular way
and they may not get their way and so
they feel the child is being
discriminated against based on
in their estimation it would be based on
a disability which that would allow them
to
file a charge with us because we have
jurisdiction over disability but then
once it comes to us we have the
ability to take that charge because we
clearly see something there or to pass
on that charge because it's not that the
iep wasn't being met they wanted
additional items and those items
weren't happening
and so there's a process for that
so my
my concern would be
is that if
this is potentially added
where are parents going and who are they
going to are they coming to us are they
going to court are they going to the
state board of education at what part
are we sharing information because our
process is
is confidential up to
probable cause so if
if a parent files a charge
we're not telling the media that these
charges were filed against this school
district and these are the things that
happen we we don't have that
conversation we have a confidential
process which is to the to the
it's better for for all involved now at
a certain point that information can
become public because if we're having a
public hearing which all of our hearings
are the public will be informed it's you
know x versus y and if they would like
to watch those proceedings then they
certainly can
but i think we are all the human rights
commission is already established to
take these these cases take and pass
upon these cases we have been since 2019
and so i would be a little concerned
about
what the process would look like and
who's tracking these how how is it going
to work as it relates to who would come
to the commission versus who would go to
the state board of education i'm sure
i've missed a lot of points that were
made earlier there was so much
conversation but i'll end my comments
there and i'm absolutely available for
any questions that you might have thank
you very much thank you very much real
helpful information you've presented
i have one question uh and it deals with
process because i i don't really have
the total process put together in my
head but you see
the human rights commission
is that
that a step after
the
the statute says the state board of
education shall ensure that
discrimination doesn't occur
in k through well it doesn't say k-12
but it is k-12 public education
um
if in fact a person comes to you and
says
i have a concern here i want to have you
resolve this issue which i feel we're
dealing with discrimination
would it be likely that your your
commission would say have you dealt with
the state board of education which has
the responsibility to ensure no
discrimination occurs have you gone in
them and had you have you had any
closure or discussion or recommendation
from that board so is that a step prior
to coming to you um thank you so much
for the question that is an excellent
question and i have no idea
um at this point we don't have to do
that someone can come to us unfettered
and file a charge
if this is passed then we would
certainly have to figure it out whether
it's
whether it's the human rights commission
and the state board of education through
the assistance of the attorney general's
office
i would imagine that is what would have
to happen but at this point if a parent
comes to us and would like to file a
charge um depending on what it is if
it's iep related then we may send them
back to the school in question to ask
those particular questions
but customarily we will take the charge
thank you
questions from the committee represent
luna sure thank you very much mr chair
and thanks very much for uh for offering
to um to testify this morning i think
you you've raised some good um good good
questions here um in your opinion
i mean there's obviously a an existing
uh existing language in in statute in
uh roman 33
that um that this bill amends that's
directed to
public schools
and um and a
i'm just going to call it a subset of
protected classes because it certainly
does not include
um some of the language that
representative tanner
did put in to to make it a more
comprehensive group of protected classes
but um
but do you do you see a um
you know any any sort of issues
with the um i guess the lack of
of
i don't know if the word is no uh
the the difference between what's
currently in this statute and what uh
what you're talking about with the human
rights um uh commission and wouldn't we
be better off having having something
that was maybe more in line and
and you know
has has greater
specificity to the protected classes and
and the
the students
educational environments
thank you representative leno for the
question
i would say that i dare not speak to a
statute that is not my own
whether it's a good idea or not a good
idea i would not have the expertise uh
to to try to dance through the weights
and measures of making a statement such
as that
what i can say is that all citizens are
covered by 354a
there are protections in place and 354a
in in many ways mirrors the the federal
civil rights act of 1964.
and uh what people
what children are specifically protected
uh at this point um is the addition to
our statute which is uh
354-827 i believe in 28
those two elements were added when
education was added to our statute so so
there's coverage there
does it help to have it somewhere else
i
i can't speak to that
because in terms of this there there's
an enforcement element
so
the enforcement element is where things
get confusing
does it help to have coverage in
different places
it would honestly it would depend on
who's covering what area does it divide
it up does it make it confusing do they
all work together um those would be the
questions that i would uh have to answer
in order to make and
to give an opinion on something like
that
follow up mr chairman yes so so
in the current statute
uh for example it uh it includes some
race but it doesn't include
gender identity
would it be preferable for the current
statute to be updated to include the
protected classes that are compatible
with what the human rights commission
addresses
that would be a decision between the
legislature who's making these decisions
as well as the department of department
of education
there's already civil rights
there's a civil rights uh not unit but
uh the
civil the office of civil rights and i
know i think i just got that backwards
um that is a part of the federal
department of education so there are
coverage areas that people have access
to as well as the specificity in 354-a
if you also decide that it needs to be
somewhere else then that is what will be
that is that is something squarely on
your shoulders and then the rest of us
will have to go about figuring out how
this works um and and how to if the
pieces are working together or if they
are in conflict and we would have to
figure out what that system is
as chairman lad stated do we need to
send them to
the state board of education first and
they exhaust that and then they come to
us do they not have to go to them did
would it would our statute have to be
amended to make that process another
part because that's not part of our
process currently
so there are a lot of other questions
that need to be asked i'm not weighing
in on whether this is a good piece of
legislation or not
what i'm here to say is
what we do at the commission what our
responsibility is what our raise on debt
is every day and that education was
added in 2019 with the specificity of
the language that is currently being
proposed
and if this piece of legislation passes
there are other elements that have to be
considered and looked at so that
the
parents that are filing or making a
claim will have clarity on where they're
going and what that process is and who
they should see first or not see it all
or what their options are i think this
because it's a bit vague um there's
there's
for me a bit of confusion
relative to those questions that you
asked yeah so so one
one more follow-up on that so so if a um
if a parent and this goes right to your
um your your hypothetical here and tied
in with the process that uh that um that
chair lad uh mentioned if a parent felt
that their student had been
discriminated on based on race
uh could they then not follow i mean
what would be the process for them now
they reach out to us we start with a
questionnaire so that we can gather some
of the basic information it's basically
the who what when where and why a
contact
contact information for the parent and
then our intake person follows up with
them to get clarity on what it is and if
it does meet our prima facie standard
which is really low you know we take a
charge based on what the person is
telling us
you know there's not a there's not a
huge bar that someone has to cross to
get into the door we want to be
accessible once that primo fascia uh
standard is met and then we take that
questionnaire it is then turned into a
charge that some that is verified
meaning under the pains and penalties of
of perjury and that person uh then also
has a um
a
the person with the stamp of losing my
words
thank you notary
this is uh
this is a group sport
and it's notarized and then once that
happens then both parties receive
information on the charge and the charge
will outline what the parent is saying
happened and then the investigation
starts after that and it is assigned to
an investigator and then they will
interview
all of the the parties um they'll invest
excuse me they'll interview the parent
what happened what did you ask for
they'll ask all of these questions and
then they will talk to the school well
so and so said this happened and of
course the school will have the actual
charge so they'll know what's being
alleged and then they are interviewed to
get answers and then from there an
assessment is made as to if there's
enough to move this along if there's
enough that there's probable cause
and there's also
a commissioner that's assigned who will
then make that determination
and after probable cause is found
then there's another uh there's an
opportunity for a conciliation which is
basically a mediation after probable
cause
conciliation happens if it fails then we
move on to a public hearing but also at
that time
if the respondent whether whoever it is
whether it's a school district employer
whomever they have an opportunity to
remove it to court if they would like
and then if they don't and they remain
with us then a scheduled a hearing is
scheduled there are three commissioners
who don't know anything about the
the charge or the case or the
investigation and they are listening to
the information to the testimony that's
provided with
any
additional information and then a
determination is made and from there
then whatever that decision is
and the the parents are asking for
something so
that decision is made based on what the
parents are asking for
there is an opportunity at that point
for
any sort of financial relief that can be
a part of the our entire process now if
we go through the investigation and we
get to a no probable cause then the
information from the investigation
certainly is sent to both parties and
then the both parties will know
what
what information
uh what level it didn't reach so you
have the lower step of primo facial
which is getting in the door the next
step is probable cause and so the
complainant is is proving their case all
along
and if there's not enough information or
i shouldn't say not enough information
if the investigation does not yield that
there was probable cause so maybe there
is a non-discriminatory reason that this
thing happened with their child at that
school and the school would then be
incumbent to um to show that it was a
non-discriminatory reason
and then of course if the complainant
gets a no probable cause finding they
have an opportunity to appeal
and then when we go to a hearing let's
say they get probable cause we go to a
hearing
and they and they don't prevail they
still have another opportunity
to
to appeal
long answer to a short question
long but thorough
mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question this morning so when
i look at the legislation in front in
front of me i see two things
that are new
one is no discrimination
in non-public schools that accept public
funds
and the other
is an updated definition of the list of
protected classes to match what we
already have in statute somewhere else
my question to you is this when you talk
about the enforcement aspect of this law
are you referencing the statement that
says ensure that there shall be no
unlawful discrimination in any public
school
thank you very much for the question
representative mullen
i i'm speaking in terms of enforcement
specifically to what the human rights
commission does
what the enforcement mechanism would
potentially be through the state board
of education i do not know i'm not
familiar with what enforcement
authority they have what jurisdiction
they have and what their process is that
i do not know i'm speaking specifically
for the human rights commission could i
just have
because my next question was going to be
given the fact that they are
charged to ensure that there shall be no
unlawful
discrimination
um are you receiving cases
from the state board of education is
this i know you've said that parents can
come forward
but
have you received any inquiries from the
state board of education with regards to
any of the protected classes and
potential discrimination i would need to
thank you very much for that um
excellent question i would need to
follow back up with you to to confirm
that
off the top of my head which is a scary
place but
i would dare to say we have not but i
would like to confirm that and i'll
circle back with the with the committee
on that thank you very much
representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you this
has been very helpful um part of the
language in the bill we're looking at
addresses
non-discrimination because of physical
or mental disability is that currently
under your purview the current law we
have
is that a protected class um thank you
very much representative porter um yes
it is currently in rsa 354a so all of
the protections in the rsa uh when you
look in our first paragraph
have been extended to areas of
employment
public accommodation housing and then as
of 2019 education k-12 education can i
have a follow-up
so we had a discussion before about um
and i don't know if you can answer this
but we had a discussion before about
a child who might have a mental
disability
being accepted or not accepted into a
non-public school
for the gifted for example
in your opinion is that what what you
deal with as a mental disability would
that be
covered as a mental disability under the
law or would it
be fuzzy
um i'm not thank you for that but i'm
not quite clear on the question can you
rephrase for me okay so so
we had a discussion before about a
private school for the gifted and if a
child had a mental disability
whereby he he or she was not gifted
quote unquote that not accepting the
child into that school
under this language would be
discriminating against his him because
of his mental disability is that your
understanding of what mental disability
discrimination would be
in in the workforce or
for example if someone applied for a job
and they were rejected because they had
a mental disability would that be
discriminate discriminatory okay so
thank you i'm going to try really hard
so
i think where we should really start is
non-public education uh non-public k-12
education is not covered was not added
to our statute so so we only have k-12
uh public education and um and if i'm if
i'm remembering correctly um if the
department of education describes
charter schools as public schools then
they are covered with us as well um
to to answer
let's look at it as an employment
situation
any what so mental disability as well as
physical disabilities those are covered
under the ada
and if it's a place of work for example
that that place of work would be
would be required to follow what the ada
is however the person who may have a
mental or physical disability would need
to also meet certain standards so they
would have to be able to uh perform the
essential functions of any job in order
to to to fall under that right and so
with an accommodation
can they um can they provide can they
operate and and manage those essential
functions so for example i know this is
a little off topic so bear with me but
if the person has a visual impairment
but all that they need in order to do
their work in their cubicle or at the at
the widget bench is a magnifying screen
so that they can see what's on that
screen then there's an accommodation
that's asked for i just need a
magnifying screen to be able to do this
they receive that screen or should
receive that screen and then they're
able to do everything else that the job
entails if that person is not able to do
the essential functions of the job eat
at in the first place right without the
accommodation excuse me even with the
accommodation then that's where we get
into it really isn't discriminatory
right um and hopefully the business
would do what they could to to make
those changes or or to do the
accommodation or to make the adaption
for that individual but then there's an
undue hardship area so it's a little
convoluted there's a lot of things that
have to be looked at
and so
i've not we have not seen something
based on what you're saying in terms of
the the mental ability of this person
with the
going to the gifted school
but we would need to look at all of all
of those things to determine so if the
parent said my child is being
discriminated against because there's a
mental disability then we would have to
take in all of that information well
what what are the guidelines of the
school if do they require a certain gpa
or a certain iq and if this person
doesn't have that then
we then have to have that larger
conversation and and look at that
thank you very much representative
woodcock
thank you i appreciate you taking my
question very short very clear i know
we're running late here um is gender
identity
protected under 354 yes
thank you
and i know we're running late um new
hampshire is a couple of small schools
all girls schools so
if this were to move forward do you
think that the mission of these
all-girls schools would be imperiled
would the human rights commission have a
concern about that
um that thank you very very much
representative moffett that is a that is
an excellent question um
we would have to to look at that and if
this were to pass we would have to have
a conversation with the attorney
general's office you know is there an
exemption that's allowed so now
religious entities um have exemptions
um and so it's like at this point you
know you can't uh force a nunnery to
have a priest be a part of their living
situation but then that's a religious
organization
um and religious housing so
would there be potential exemptions that
a single gender school would have or
a particular religious school whether
it's whatever the religion is hindu
christian
you know whatever um and i think even
atheism is covered under religion uh
religious exemptions actually so
would it would it fit there is that
possible so we would have to have those
conversations um i would dare not guess
on something so important i would
absolutely have the conversation to to
understand if exemptions are allowed and
if so then here we are
if they aren't allowed then we would
have to look at what what that means
thank you
thank you are there further questions
yes represent luna um thank you very
much mr chair in terms of um human
rights uh commission and and
non-discrimination is there a difference
between um
or or and in particular on this bill do
you see a difference between
organizations
that um
that are private and organizations that
i mean private and do not accept public
funds and organizations that uh that do
accept public um tax dollars
um thank you represent representative
juno i'm not sure i understand the
question are you specifically speaking
of schools or
workplaces or
right so so thanks i'm i'm really sort
of directed to what representative
moffett had asked so maybe you do have a
small single gender school
that is operating
without the use of public
tax dollars and maybe a a single gender
school that or maybe a school that is
operating with the use of public tax
dollars and is there any
a different
standard i guess as far as their
requirements to comply with
non-discrimination statutes okay thank
you for that i think i understand you um
so
if my understanding is clear
our purview is public schools period
full stop
and that does
if i'm correct i would include
charter schools as well so we do not
cover private schools
at all so i think your question lends
more towards a public versus private and
since we don't
have jurisdiction over private schools
or non-public schools then i would not
really be able to answer your question
because
if we did then there wouldn't be a
difference right all the schools would
be all the schools but we specifically
cover public school education k through
12.
thank you are there further questions
here from the committee not seeing ants
thank you very much for the very
thorough and
informative presentation thank you
we have one more speaker on this bill
chris urkel
uh
just please press the silver button to
get started thank you
should i wait for the chair to return
go ahead please all right thank you vice
chair um thank you members of the
committee
my name is chris urchill i'm an attorney
with glbtq legal advocates and defenders
better known as glad
we are new england's premier league
advocacy organization for the lgbtq
community
and a key aspect of our mission is to
fight discrimination
in all aspects of public life and
naturally
that includes in education
um
i'd like to start just by laying a
foundation of shared values
among everyone in this room totally
universally shared values
we all win when every single student has
access to a robust and complete
education
and that's because today's students are
tomorrow's
professionals parents volunteers
teachers neighbors voters and our
friends they're our community
for people who experience discrimination
harassment bullying exclusion
at school
which unfortunately includes many lgbtq
young people
it is extremely difficult to obtain
a quality education
this is true
no matter whether a student
attends school if it's one of new
hampshire's excellent public schools or
if it's another school that's chosen by
the student's parents it's always true
that it's hard to be uh to achieve a
full to obtain a full education if
you're being discriminated against
um
as this legislature has previously
declared decades ago when it instituted
the law against discrimination 354-a
discrimination not only threatens the
rights
and proper privileges of new hampshire's
inhabitants but menaces the institutions
and foundation of a free democratic
state and threatens peace order health
safety and general welfare of the state
and its inhabitants
so hb 1607 is really sensible
legislation i think there's a lot of
confusion and with all due respect to
director malachi i believe that
i believe that a lot of her testimony
introduced unnecessary confusion into
into what the legislation does it's
really sensible legislation
prior to the enactment of sb 263 which
is the 2019 law we've been talking about
which expanded nondiscrimination
protections to public schools in new
hampshire prior to that there was uh
there was a statute the same statute
that we're amending here part 33 of
chapter 186 section 11
which
which required the commissioner to
ensure that there was no discrimination
among certain protected classes in
public schools that was true before
there were any human rights commission
protections extended to uh
to to to public school students
so so
it doesn't it didn't then it didn't
affect the scope of the human rights
commission and what it does
and it's true today that this amendment
isn't going to change or affect the
scope of what the human rights
commission does okay 354a is not amended
by this statute the statute does not
create a private right of action for
parents to bring discrimination claims
it does not do that at all all it does
is it expands the scope of what the
board of education already does
uh with you know and it's totally
consistent with the mission statement of
the board of education which is to
ensure that every individual
acquires the skills and knowledge to
succeed in a competitive global economy
and thrive as a 21st century citizen
totally consistent with that objective
the state board of education is tasked
with eliminating discrimination
currently from public schools and this
bill would expand it to private schools
that receive public funds
okay it does not create a human rights
commission um you know catastrophe that
was just uh being being discussed and i
want to add something else to that which
is that if someone walked into my office
tomorrow and told me that they were
being discriminated against in a private
school because they were gay
and i said okay let's uh let's call the
school work with them see if we can
figure out a resolution that's going to
make everyone happy and we're unable to
do that
i could make an assessment based on my
own understanding of the circumstances
and what's going on at the school i
might walk into the human rights
commission the day after that and say
hey i'd like to follow a discrimination
claim based on a public accommodation
discriminating against this student
moreover if it's a boarding school i
might also bring a housing claim
so 354a does already cover
discrimination in many contexts
including public accommodations and
housing which may or may not apply to
private schools in different contexts so
it's actually i mean all due respect to
to director malachi but i believe that
uh it's very likely the human rights
commission would have to process a claim
about a private school student who is
experiencing discrimination at school
and i think that they would have the the
all the tools and resources they would
need to do that to handle that claim and
they might find that there is no
discrimination or they might find that
there is uh no coverage because it's not
a place of public accommodation because
it fits into some exemption or whatever
and then i could go into superior court
and make my case there so that all this
is to say that the law remains unchanged
with respect to the human rights act um
if this bill passes okay
um
so there's no substantive change in law
it's just it doesn't expand legal
protections for vulnerable groups of
of students the bill simply expands the
role of the state board of education to
fulfill its mission
i want to point out something that um
that rep tanner said which is public
funds require public accountability i
agree with that statement i think it's a
great a great line but i want to clarify
that
that the the objective of the state of
new hampshire to end discrimination in
all aspects of public life it does not
stop at people who receive public funds
it includes many private businesses
including um i mean as
director malachi pointed out it includes
exemptions for some organizations in
some contexts but but for the most part
every single organization that employs
people in new hampshire houses people in
new hampshire or serves the public which
includes students
has an obligation to to to to act um
with without discrimination um toward
toward every new hampshire resident
i think that this bill is very simple it
isn't it isn't it isn't complicated it
doesn't make any substantive changes to
the law it just tasks the board of
education with ensuring that there's no
discrimination for any student which is
something that we all benefit from
because every single student should have
access to a full and equal education
that's all i have to say i really urge
you to vote to pass on this legislation
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you thank you very much are there
any questions represented like us
thank you
um
you had said that a lot of lgbtq
children were discriminated in the
public schools could you give me an
estimate of percent because i know there
are a lot of
um lgbtq i know there are lgbtq children
who are in like the efa program or in
the children's scholarship program who
are there because of
discrimination in the public schools
do you can you give me any idea how
prevalent that is in the public schools
yeah um discrimination and harassment
and bullying based on lgbtq status is
extremely common in public schools
including in new hampshire and um the
most recent
survey
you know new hampshire schools survey
that i saw the results for i think it
was over half of
lgbtq students report experiencing
some form of discrimination bullying
harassment at school
as an lgbtq student and i totally
understand your point which is that
students might choose to go to private
school to avoid some of the harms that
come up in public schools and also some
of the laws like h or sorry sb263 which
passed in 2019 which expanded
protections for uh for for lgbtq
students and other students in public
schools gave us mechanisms to help
work against that kind of discrimination
and harassment and i just want to add
that like i've worked with a lot of new
hampshire school principals new
hampshire school guidance counselors
teachers and administrators
and 201
every single one of these people that
i've worked with has a commitment toward
ensuring equal educational opportunities
for every single student there are not
school officials and i and i and i
believe this to be true private school
officials just the same there is not
anyone who is out there trying to harm
or limit the opportunities available to
students that's not the objective of
anybody we need these tools we need
rules and policies and uh and tools to
help address the situations where people
don't know what to do don't have the
don't have the the bandwidth or don't
have the tools they need to stop the
discrimination before it happens this is
just another mechanism to help prevent
discrimination in schools
thank you thank you very much are there
further questions representative waltz
thank you i actually have a technical
drafting question i understand what the
authors of this bill are trying to do
but i'd like to
just
draw your attention do you have a copy
of the bill in front of you i do okay
i'd like to draw your attention to lines
11 and 12.
so it says that there's no lawful
discrimination in any public school
private school
approved tuition program
or educational service that receives
public funds
it looks like educational service that
receives public funds as a separate
category which would then mean this
applies to
private schools that don't necessarily
receive
funds in the way it's drafted am i
reading this correctly is it in context
elsewhere it says i mean i know exactly
what the intent of the bill is but i'm
concerned about the way it's drafted
um
you know i think that's an astute
observation i do think that there's uh
an ambiguity there if not um you know if
not just confusion um and i and i
totally understand what you mean and
that that that could be um
that could be amended if you want or it
could be uh you know kept to the way it
is and i don't and i don't think that it
you know necessarily will be interpreted
one way or the other i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna speculate as to how it would
ultimately be interpreted but i do think
that's an astute observation okay thank
you
representative luno thank you very much
mr chair um you you uh you talked about
um public schools and i just wanted to
ask you about
situations where you might be aware of
discrimination in private schools
and
particularly on the basis of sex gender
identity sexual orientation race
religious
creed
and and if if any of that is going on
either nationally
or in the state of new hampshire
it's true that regardless of where
people go to school when they're
vulnerable and part of a vulnerable
minority and have differences that
separate them from other people they are
bound to experience different forms of
exclusion harassment
harassment at the hands of other
students sometimes at the hands of
teachers and and and um and bullying
this this this happens with frequency
whenever somebody is different from
other people and
um and and yes it happens in private
schools and i am not i'm not of the
opinion that it's worse or better in
private schools it's just the same it's
the same thing everywhere you go
uh and a quick follow-up on that mr
chair so so to representative walls
question um and and actually to to
testimony we've heard um this morning
there may be private schools that are
that are single gender private schools
there may be private schools that
discriminate based on religion there may
be private schools that discriminate
on
other
conditions
and protected classes
but
could there
also be a
i guess a different level of
of non-discrimination
requirement or a non-discrimination
standard for private schools that are
funded with public money as opposed to
private schools that are not funded with
public tax dollars
so thank you rep luna but i would ask
for a little more clarification about
what you're asking i i i followed you
but i would and i think the
clarification goes to how the bill is um
is worded here and whether or not the
state has an obligation to ensure that
that private institutions that are
funded with public tax dollars are free
from discrimination right so so it's not
clear to me
based on what i what i read here whether
or not a private school that say limited
um limited admission to a single sex to
like an all-girls school whether that
would be a violation or not of this of
this law it's possible that it would be
interpreted that way i i will just say
that it would require the board of
education to interpret and enforce it
that way for that to be the outcome
right and um i i i'm actually not aware
and i'm sure members of this committee
are aware of whether or not there are
all girls programs um or schools in
better public schools in new hampshire
um there there might very well be
programs or or opportunities that are
only available to girls within the
public school system and
you know there's non-discrimination
protections that prohibit discrimination
based on sex in new hampshire and public
schools already but those programs would
ostensibly continue to exist i think
it's just a question of whether or not
there's an understanding that certain
programs exist to remediate past
discrimination and whether those would
you know then be a violation of the law
but i i don't think there's a per se
answer to that question does that help
thank you
are there further questions
not seeing any thank you very much
thank you
this concludes the hearing for this bill
and will take about two or three minutes
to prepare and get into the next bill
which we have coming up which is 1671.
stretch your legs a little bit here
you
i think
i think we're just about set to get
started with
the next bill
yeah we're
a little bit behind schedule so maybe we
can catch up
um
the
the next bill is house bill 16-7
relative to the content of an adequate
education
and
i'll uh
call on the
prime sponsor
chairman ladd
for his testimony
my mic's on
i got the pink card in up there
i'm here today to introduce hb 1671
i'm rick ladd representative rick ladd
from haverhill new hampshire
um
as you may recall
previously in the past
session we had hb 242
which was one of the bills which was
vetoed and sustained the veto was
sustained
and we have gone now
onto this step right here and it was
vetoed because there wasn't uh that bill
had not been quite quite crafted the way
we would like to see it done
and
i think that we have now put together a
bill here which is uh much much better
and will will
meet some of the needs that we have
within the state especially the needs
which are existing right now
where after this pandemic
we you know i attended a school board
meeting last night and got out around 11
30.
um and we're we're hearing information
where our students achievement wise is
not where we want it we know that the
statewide achievement in mathematics has
dropped significantly
um 48
proficient to 38 proficient in the
district i was working with it's much
lower than 38 proficient we also know
there's huge blocks of students which
are
are just plain absent over 20 of the
school days
and some of it's directly related to
covid some is that we just don't know
where they are
and and so there's a lot of issues and
call for what are we going to do to try
to
support the achievement in the state and
dealing with our instruction and our
content
and uh we we need to get on it and do
something quickly i know the esr monies
have been used to help remediation etc
but what my concern is that we've come
in the state to believe that
curriculum and instruction are totally
the responsibility local
and then we're also looking at siloing
curriculum from instruction and i don't
think you can do that so when we're
talking about the content of an adequate
education that content those learning
domains cannot be excluded from
instruction in order to be effective in
one you have to have the other you also
have to have other components of uh the
other elements of a a
a
quality education present and there's
some elements that we aren't going to be
discussing today like
the learning environment the the
building itself or the leadership within
the building or the staff in the
building or the preconditions that
students have when they come to school
in funding we have talked about that
another area those all relate to the
content of an adequate education but
what we got right now is the educational
content
what are those core subjects that core
knowledge that core skills which
students require to be successful and
meet the challenges of their careers
when they graduate from high school or
for post-secondary when they go on
beyond
there are certain issues occurring in
schools now that are really restricting
that long list of core subject areas we
have now in the learning domain areas
for an adequate education that restrict
it you know the learning time the school
time for an elementary child can be from
anywhere from five and a half hours to
five hours 45 minutes for a high school
student it could be as much as six hours
per day
but when you boil that down and take out
all the time which is not direct
instruction you come down with possibly
30 minutes per day for lunch yes but
then above that break time above the
recess time uh that's uh considered
transition times etc the actual times
for teaching made down come down to
about four and a half hours
but then you go into that and break that
down and how much of that is time on
task really engaged academic learning
time you can throw a piece of paper in
front of a worksheet and that's not
necessarily going to be a learning
opportunity
so what we have now is we have
restricted time in our schools for
teaching those core contents knowledge
and skills that absolutely every child
deserves and should have the opportunity
to receive
this is why this bill has been
introduced from my perspective
we're looking at the bill itself this
clarifies that
and defines adequacy as a rigorous
academic study in core knowledge and
learning domain areas that are
fundamental for academic success
and those learning domains that are
listed in this bill are english language
arts
arithmetic and mathematics
natural and physical sciences and social
studies history geography government
civics and economics
those were the years ago the core
subjects that we had for when i went to
school
of course we had a few more back then
too penmanship spelling etc
and uh
some of us fared well on that on the
pink cards i see a lot of us could still
use a lot of learning
um
but through applied
through applied in stride the the
the importance of this bill is we also
take another component
and we address
areas where you can apply
this core knowledge and deepen and
deepen the integration and the learning
that goes on through world languages
logic and rhetoric that should be up in
integrated in everything we do
communication skills and thinking skills
we talk about thinking skills here
earlier this year
with various bills which we've had
personal finance literacy
engineering and technologies computer
science and digital literacy arts
education including music
physical education health and wellness
these are areas which are
where you can deepen learning but it
also this bill also
places in language and additional areas
of study may be determined by the local
school board so you go beyond this the
local school district can
identify other areas which they perceive
that might be unique to their particular
school or their location or their
community
there are a number of areas which we're
looking at in this bill that we
are
or i guess there was number areas within
hp 242 as you recall that are not looked
at in this bill the costing of an
adequate education was in 242. this bill
does not have anything to do with the
costing of an adequate education
you also remember that within 242 there
was a component which dealt with the
learn everywhere program that's not
mentioned in this bill at all this bill
strictly deals with the definition of
adequacy the content of adequacy the
delivery of adequacy and the
accountability for that and
responsibilities that the department of
education has in terms of reporting back
to this legislature
looking at the every every
five years the accountability system we
have
and reporting back to the
legislature on that so i'm not going to
go further into this bill right now i'm
here to introduce it the commissioner of
education is here to take you through
some of the particulars and some of the
rationale why the department of
education is anxious to get this in
place and move forward in the state
thank you very much thank you any
questions for representative ladd uh
representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative vlad looks like you did a
lot of work on this can you tell me was
there a committee composed of
teachers and
uh local school boards and
superintendents as well as
others who came up with
the different elements in this bill or
is there was there another way well
the elements you see are if they're
talking about the learning areas those
areas are basically they are in
um statute right now social studies is
not defined the way we've done it here
and put out the broken out the five
areas
but
uh the department has i've worked with
the department very closely
uh throughout the time we did 242 and
following it so it's been an ongoing
process for the last several years i
know the department also you know takes
information from people within the
department uh whether i we've directly
involved people in the field i know i've
had discussions with people in the field
and they they feel right now a little
bit overwhelmed at times that they're
trying to cover all this within a very
shortened day and now they're dealing
with the results of covet and remote
learning and and having to do double
duty for those kids which once were in
kindergarten when this all started now
our third graders and just have missed a
whole lot
this area right here when we
specifically identify that knowledge and
skills required as the foundational
elements that make up and comprise an
adequate education and how they're
applied through these subjects in this
school which is part of it
um i think this will be more effective
and and certainly help our students
so in other words there was there was
not a group of teachers and um
principals and stuff that worked with
you on this this is i did not work for
the task force if that's what you're
looking for thank you
representative walsh
yeah this is real quick simply for those
of us that are newer to educational law
this is there's an awful lot here which
i'm sure you would acknowledge i'm
wondering if we can get a side by side
on these to look at the current law and
the changes in the law and in particular
where
the change it not just in the technical
stuff about you know whether it includes
reading writing arithmetic but but i
think there are some policy changes
embedded in here too and i'm wondering
if we can get a side by side that pulls
out the language we can do that we can
do that
a lot of this is a result of when we
adopted essa essa the new every student
succeeds act
and there were changes which came down
from the federal government we did chip
away at that and we made a whole lot of
changes within this area of statute
within 193e
the way those changes were made we
slipped it in the way it was written
in the past
not really to really support what we
need with essa and so
these changes right here reflect a lot
of that that we had done but things have
been arranged in a different uh uh
sequence so that's easier to understand
and read this bill than it was before
so i will yeah we can get this side by
side that's not not a problem to all
uh thank you representative mullen
thank you representative cordelian thank
you representative vlad for taking my
question my first question is
are you in a position to go piece by
piece through the bill or will there be
people following the commissioner will
do that okay thank you very much
uh representative tanner
thank you i just want to follow up to i
believe it was representative porter's
question
um
were there any any groups like the uh
school boards association or the nea new
hampshire uh that were involved in the
development of this uh adequacy
many of the issues which are in here
were in the previous statutory language
but there was no task force which
brought people together for example like
we did with the code ethics and the code
of conduct
thank you
see no further questions uh thank you uh
chairman lad thank you
next i'll call on uh commissioner frank
edelblut of the department
um who did well in his penmanship on the
pink card as well
good morning everyone and for the record
frank edelblut commissioner of education
uh thank you committee members for
allowing me to speak with you about this
particular bill
in my mind this bill represents an
opportunity for
us
our school systems to refocus and
contribute to the correction of a
decades-long wrong
that has been so persistent relative to
student academic performance this really
is an opportunity for new hampshire to
do something which it frequently does
which is be bold and move forward for
the sake of our students
now i want to give you some perspective
in terms of how i see some of the the
changes that are being proposed here
play out
and really that is a perspective on
students and how students are performing
in the current k-12 education system
both here in new hampshire as well as
across the nation and i share this
information recognizing that new
hampshire holds the spot as one
depending on which survey you're looking
at one of the top performing states
relative to education across the country
now there are several assessments that
are used to provide insight into student
academic trends
and these are trends that we can look at
both in the short run as well as over
the long term
there is the
national assessment of education
progress or nape the nation's report
card some of you may be familiar with
and it is a nationwide assessment in
math and reading to fourth and eighth
graders
and it provides a comparison among the
states in terms of how they're
performing we also have some an
assessment called the program for
international student assessment or pisa
and that is an international assessment
in math reading and science and it
provides comparisons among the oecd
countries and then there is the new
hampshire student assessment system or
new hampshire sas and the s.a.t which
accompanies it in high school and this
is new hampshire a new hampshire based
assessment in math reading and science
for grades three through eight and in
high school
all of these assessment instruments tell
a similar story both here in new
hampshire as well as across the country
about our performing arts student
performance
student performance has shown little
improvement over decades
let that sink in for a moment student
performance has shown little improvement
over decades
the flat performance however masks
underlying and very important trends
what we see in all of these assessment
instruments
is that high performing students my top
quartile students show stable or modest
improvements
while low performing students those in
the lowest quartile are showing
declining performance
essentially what you have happening here
is that and which is why we need to be
bold the system created with the
aspiration of being the great equalizer
has in fact become the great divider and
i believe that this bill wants to move
in the direction of trying to correct
that
some reflecting on some of this
performance observation take criticism
with the assessment instruments
themselves and i don't really want to
engage today in a debate about
assessment instruments but i'm happy to
do that if somebody wants to at some
future time
but you have to understand and this is
part of the reason why i give you all
three of these assessments so these are
three different distinct assessment
tools that are used in different
contexts and different populations and
they're all telling the same story
when you consider the new hampshire
assessment the new hampshire sas
consider that it is an assessment of new
hampshire academic standards these are
the academic standards which our
education system has said this is what
we want our students to know to be able
to be successful citizens
our education system is responsible for
the instruction of students relative to
those standards
the new hampshire sas assessment
questions are questions that are
selected by our educators in terms of
what tests what questions we should give
the kids
and then we set the cut score
through our education system to turn to
determine what level of attainment
should be a passing score
in effect our education
system tells us what students should
know to become successful citizens they
instruct students in those things and
they develop the assessment to see how
well the students understood the
instruction at the end of that process
whether we use nape whether we use pisa
whether we use the new hampshire sas
we generally get less than 50 percent of
our students to proficiency and yet we
end up graduating 90 of our students out
of high school
reflecting on student performance
there's an author of a book school
houses state houses and courthouses eric
hanashek from stanford university he
states the country seems to be stuck in
a rut and achievement levels have
remained largely stagnant since the
1960s despite massive efforts to improve
them this is why we need to be bold and
let me reflect on what some of those
efforts are
in 1964 we had the equality of
educational opportunity act or the
coleman report and that was nine years
after we had brown v board of education
and the question that they were asking
in 1964
is
why after 10 years close to 10 years
with brown v board of education has the
black white equity gap persisted why
does it still exist in 1964 at a federal
level we were asking that question
in 1965 president johnson's war on
poverty included for the first time the
federal government weighing in on
education through the elementary and
secondary education act
which provided significant federal
funding to education with the premise
that more funding would improve
education and that improved education
would eliminate poverty almost 60 years
later that goal has not been realized
in 1983 under president reagan we got a
nation at risk
looking at education
there's a statement that is relatively
uh well known relative to that work that
was done by president reagan that says
if an unfriendly foreign power had
attempted to impose on america the
mediocre education performance that
exists today we might have viewed it as
an act of war
in 1989 see a pattern developing we got
the national education summit by
president george h.w bush which
established education goals to be
achieved by 2000
including all u.s students achieving
competency and challenging subject
matters including among others english
math and science
in 2001
it doesn't go on forever in 2001 we got
the no child left behind act by
president george bush which required
rigorous state economic standards that
must be met by 2014.
in 2015 we got the every student
succeeds act by president obama which
aspires that all students in america be
taught to high academic standards that
will prepare them to succeed in college
and careers
what is clear
is that a herculean effort has been put
forth to try to move education forward
and close the disparity gaps
but the evidence is clear as well these
efforts have not been successful
to those who might argue that somehow
funding or lack thereof is the driver i
can provide hours of evidence of massive
increases in funding well beyond
inflation that have not been effective
again eric haneshan quoting from
stanford the additional resources have
not significantly altered the patterns
of low student achievement observed over
the last several decades
now to the bill let me describe to you
the dilemma that we are facing in
education
we have a fixed instructional day
it's 180 or instructional year we have
180 days in a year or the equivalent
number of hours 9.90 for high school 9
you know in the
elementary school
and the school days generally run from 7
30 a.m to 2 30 p.m and into this fixed
amount of time all of the required areas
of study must be compressed
the day does not extend
and when we add something we take away
from something else
the result which seems to be reflected
in the assessment results
is that we do many things but poorly but
few things with excellence right is
there an opportunity to focus our
efforts and be bold in that area
looking at the list of learning areas in
193 e2a that are listed in your bill
i think we would all agree that
everything
there is valuable and important first
information for students to learn but
there's nothing in there that i'm like
oh i don't want kids to know that we
agree that it's all important
what i would question is whether all
such areas are essential for students to
become effective and productive citizens
what this bill does is allow our
education system to focus its attention
on the important foundational areas that
really are essential to the future
success of our students as citizens in
this state
let's consider some examples of what
this bill excludes through in out of
those core areas world languages
i'm a big proponent of world languages i
personally have competency in several of
them i also know however that most
citizens in new hampshire and likely
most of you in this room
are functioning with only one language
english at this point in time
and so is that essential for our
students if we're trying to figure out
how they can be successful citizens
another area that we have on the list is
computer programming another subject i'm
very fond of and possess a degree of
competency in but what i also know
is that about computer programming is
that if you have not attained basic
algebraic thinking programming will be
very difficult for you
and so what this really does is it
provides an opportunity for integration
with such a growing list of subjects
that we're trying to cram into this
fixed
you know bucket that we have
subjects tend to become isolated in
their own domain and instruction is not
well integrated there are some attempts
these days to try and integrate that but
we need more of that integration perhaps
if we were to focus our attention
we would help that integration move
forward so that
instruction uh you know so that to would
integrate um hey let me see i lost my
page here uh i have math teachers
computer teachers and art teachers
perhaps if we were to focus our
attention we would integrate instruction
and get better algebraic thinking and
better computer programming perhaps if
we were to focus our attention we would
integrate instruction and would get
better geometry and better art
instruction why are those two not
together i mean if you imagine we've all
seen some of those analogies in terms of
time management where you have a bucket
you're trying to fill it with some big
objects some large objects and then some
small objects maybe it's water or sand
or something like that
and what everybody will tell you is you
put the large objects in first and then
you let the other ones fill in around it
and you get more capacity out of that
container that's what we're talking
about here
now let's consider what the bill
includes as essential to helping
students grow to become effective and
productive citizens
the list focuses on core academic areas
that have stood the test of time in
education
the list includes those areas that are
the focus of required assessments
against swiss the system efficacy is
being measured math english and science
the list includes areas of social
studies which along with other areas is
viewed as essential to being a
a successful and productive citizen and
i hear again and again from my social
studies teachers how it's been pushed
out you know we didn't have room so when
we added another thing into the list
that's one of the things that oftentimes
falls off the table
the list includes foundational areas
that students can build from as they
pursue their own areas of interest
equipping them to be lifelong learners
if we don't teach them
literacy if we don't bring their
literacy to a high level if we don't
teach them numeracy and bring their math
capacity to a higher level that they
don't have those skills to apply in all
kinds of domains because those are core
skills that apply across all different
domains
so how does this bill allow the
legislature to continue to weigh in on
areas of study that they see as
important they'll perhaps not require
and i think the bill continues to
recognize the importance of broad and
integrated educational options through
the applied instruction i understand
that the bill like this may be viewed by
some as being limiting in fact it should
be viewed as liberating
and an opportunity to be more engaging
for our students
we need to have collaboration between
math teachers and art teachers we need
collaboration between math teachers and
robotics teachers we need collaboration
between these different domains
applied knowledge grabs the interests of
students and makes it so they cannot
avoid but learn
i hope that you will consider the
importance of this bill
and that we will be bold here in new
hampshire
in its context and considering this bill
in the context of decades of attempts at
failed change not just here in new
hampshire but you heard that list of all
these national efforts every decade
another initiative starts because we
recognize that it hasn't moved forward
since brown v board of education ten
years after that we looked at it we
didn't get that done
you know in its context of helping
schools focus efforts on areas that we
have consistently not been successful at
for too many students you know not here
in new hampshire but a tragic story that
some of you may have seen of a high
school in baltimore
where
71 percent of the students in high
school were reading at an elementary
grade level of kindergarten first grader
second grade
i'm glad that we don't have that here
in its context of helping to drive
innovative and applied instruction that
grabs the attention and curiosity of our
students so that we can move forward so
thank you for letting me share with you
today and i'm happy to answer any
questions you may have
thank you commissioner do we have
questions for the commissioner
representative luno
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much um
commissioner for uh for joining us uh
this morning and this afternoon um
so at the uh at the top of your
testimony you mentioned how um how
overall new hampshire's public education
does uh does very well certainly on uh
on a national basis on a national
ranking so
well hang on hang on
i'm sort of getting to my question
um
and um and you mentioned that
that that that a lot of students are
really i don't think you use the word
left behind but but basically that there
are gaps
and um uh and that uh and that this um
these outcomes are just not not
happening everywhere so i guess the
question to you is that if um if if
those gaps
those um opportunity gaps are as a
result of
of how
an adequate public education is defined
in 193 e2a
and the accountability sections that
you've that you
that you have in here
then
then has new hampshire
been providing an adequate
an opportunity for an adequate education
for all of its kids so i would say that
new hampshire is providing more than an
adequate opportunity for an education
but i think that by focusing it we can
tone in on what is core to having
success
for our education system and so what i
would point out to you is while new
hampshire is one of the higher
performing
you know academic or educational systems
among the new the 50 states if you look
at pisa which is the international
assessment you'll find that we rank in
the 30s behind many of our oecd customer
countries around the world and that has
not improved over time and what we've
seen is a falling on that international
ranking so typically you know if you're
competing in an in a business and you
see yourself falling behind
the important thing to do is figure out
what is my core mission and how do i
refocus on that core mission so that's
really what we're talking about what is
that adequate education we want to hone
in on and make sure that we're focused
on so that we can do a better job on
that
so in a quick follow-up mr chief yes so
um so i think this will be um uh easier
to uh
to look at once uh chairman chair ladd
has uh has completed the the side by
side with with existing law
and um and i um i appreciate very much
your um your your separating the um the
sort of the fundamental um core
knowledge for academic success and then
areas that can really help stimulate and
drive that you know and leverage that
core knowledge but i'm struggling to
really understand
how how
changing this
um is
is somehow going to uh
close those these opportunity gaps that
we see across the state which are very
heavily tied
with um uh in communities that that are
that that tend to skew to lower
socioeconomic conditions and higher
economic challenges and lower resource
capacity than than other districts and
i'm just trying to see how
how
how this plan
uh really does change the slope of uh of
that opportunity for um uh for all of
the uh uh you know kids that are that
are not able to uh to perform at the
same level as so many others yeah so i
appreciate that question and i think
it's a it's a it's a german question
right imagine we're talking about 60
years or more
of this equity disparity that you've
talked about this system that's supposed
to be the great equalizer has in fact
become the great divider
and rather than close some of these
disparity gaps over these 60 years we've
not they're getting wider and not not
narrower and so what i would tell you is
um even you know in our own you know
everyone everyone here in their own
lives uh when you need to get
when you've got lots going on but you
have something you need to get done you
focus on the core and so that's what i'm
trying to do here is i think that this
bill
allows
the legislature to signal to the school
system look let's get back to job number
one which is building a foundation of
education so these students can come out
of our school system
with these important foundational skills
to be successful citizens
and that's really i think what the focus
is so
do i know that this will close that
equity gap i don't know the answer to
that representative if i knew the answer
to that then we wouldn't have 60 years
of uh you know of not closing that gap
with with lots and lots of efforts gone
into that but what i do know is
that a move like this is going to be a
bold move
that's really not so radical in the
sense of what we're saying is like let's
focus our attention let's get down to
what it is that these kids really need
to be able to have
and i think we can all agree that these
are important skills for them to have
and by doing that
are we
signaling to our school system are we
equipping and enabling our school system
to be able to focus and not feel like
they have to do everything at a frantic
pace potentially poorly
represented tanner
thank you
mr chair and thank you for taking the
question and and welcome to the
committee thank you um i wanted to just
go back to the process question that i
asked representative ladd um i'm
wondering why or if he was
i think he was correct and saying that
there was no task force there was no
collaboration
between
you know our fine unh education
department and
the fine instructors and educational
specialists we have
all over new hampshire
to come together to to
develop some of this and and to refine
it as well as like the school boards
association some of the other uh
associations yeah so in fact what i
would describe for you is at the
department we have the opportunity to
work with all of those groups on a
number of different projects we are
working through the comprehensive center
on innovation in schools and how we can
apply it we've got another project with
the rel looking at the data around the
performance
that is comprised with department staff
as well as school staff uh we've got
pride i hope task force right now that's
looking at the entire 306 rules around
education what are the
the minimum standards for education
that's comprised of a number of
superintendents
it's got you know i think principals and
other representatives in there so
through that process
we are getting input from the system
across the board and what this really
represents in my mind is kind of a
culmination of how does this stuff all
come together because you begin to hear
themes consistent across these various
task forces that you know schools are
trying to fit more into a fixed amount
of time and can we actually do that or
is are we better served by focusing our
attention on stuff that we think is
really essential
yes follow-up thank you um and that's
great i i'm glad that that that's
happening but i'm wondering why the
stakeholders
and the expertise within the state not
just at the focused at the state
department of education
were the people that took all this
information
and focused it
into something that's applicable to our
every day
educational
system that we're we support through
public education in new hampshire so so
let me just be clear so in fact that's
what i'm saying is that we got the input
from all these various task forces and
you could see the common themes running
through them and be able to work with it
and probably the department better than
anyone else's position to be able to do
that because you know you have
superintendents and principals some work
on this task force another on this test
for us another on this task force
another on this task force so but what
they don't have the advantage of and i
think really what this bill does this is
a step back perspective type of a bill
right and so we have the ability to look
across all of these task forces where
quite frankly i'm not sure that the
that superintendents and principals
necessarily have the capacity among
their other job that they're doing to be
able to have the broader perspective but
because all of these various efforts
roll up to the department of education
it provides us with i think better
perspective
thank you representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you
commissioner welcome
um your
talk this morning brought me back to my
graduate student days in educational
leadership
and um something that i learned during
that process was that
reaching consensus on something is
major change of this
is this it's not always as simple as it
might sound
and
i'm assuming that you would hope you
would have buy-in from
a large percentage of the
legislature as well as a large
percentage of the population of the
state on what you're trying to do here
when i look at the sponsors of this bill
i see
they all belong to one party
so how would you
work to convince people that might not
be listed on here that what you're
trying to do is really
to the benefit of everyone else
so thanks for that question because i
you know
the sponsorship of that is uh you know
another matter altogether but what i
would tell you is if we look at i hope
that it was a little bit
revealing to you and maybe even a little
bit shocking when you look at the
history of some of these national
efforts right 1964. 1964 1965 1980 1989
2000 2015 like we just keep doing it
right like it's time for us to be bold
and do something and so
my hope is that as i'm sharing my
testimony you too will agree
that this is a bold step but it's not a
radical step like we're not you know
there we still have all these core
things in there we're still teaching we
want to focus um so what we're really
trying to do is just
cause some focus that will happen and
then you know ultimately whether this
passes or not is up to you as a
legislature
follow-up
i do understand that um because i know
that a lot of the things that you're
talking about have been being talked
about for a long time and indeed have
been being tried
and i'm thinking about specifically very
narrow but having to do the amount of
time and day and how everything is
crammed in a number of years ago
our school district
was looking at
changing the starting times
for the elementary school and high
school because young children learn
better in the morning early morning and
high school kids learn better later on
in the day
and it made a lot of sense there was
research behind it but we couldn't
convince the community that that was
what they wanted what they wanted to do
so i'm i'm just concerned i know there's
been a lot of legislation that's been
moved through this this legislature this
year that does not have an awful lot of
uh community support behind it and um
i'm just concerned that this is another
one of these efforts that
i'm going to have to be defending when i
go out in my community so i i think when
you go out to your community if you're
defending to parents that we're going to
get your kids to proficiency and english
in math
in social studies and in science
you know then i think they're going to
be very excited about that and you're
not taking anything away because you can
still use these applied learning areas
and in fact what we'll do is to make
them more engaging for the students you
know this better than i do right so make
it more engaging for those students to
be learning so we're really it's not a
this is not a zero-sum game where uh you
know you have to you're eliminating
something what you're doing is you're
pushing together and focusing the effort
thank you representative hopson
thank you chairman cordelli and thank
you commissioner for being here and for
taking my question
um i wanted to just point out that as a
new member of education this year these
are the types of conversations that i
love to have these are the this is the
reason that i wanted to be on education
to focus on educational content
um and rep porter i wish you were a
co-sponsor on this bill
i think that
quite often we forget that education
could be the equalizer
many students come to school
hoping to either change their situation
or
improve their situation
from where they came and i was one of
those students
so i i appreciate this i appreciate the
aspect of lifelong learning and i have a
question and then a would you believe my
question is could you explain what the
acronym oecd means because i've never
heard that before uh organization
organization of economic
country development i don't remember but
it's basically that's okay good question
uh
yeah
we see i mean but basically it is like
the economically developed countries
across the world so i'll do my research
and i have a lot of people
google oecd for me
follow up would you believe um in
concord mass there is a museum the
concord museum that has and it's been a
while since i've been there so i'm going
from memory a
it's a some sort of a document from
either
ralph waldo emerson or bronson alcott
that talks about how adequate
inadequately education is funded from
1888 so it's a long time
thank you
uh representative
mullen
thank you representative cordelli uh
thank you commissioner for taking my
questions i have just uh
some technical questions here so um
on page one of the bill in roman two
where it lists out world languages logic
personal finance you know what i'm
referencing it says that these areas
shall be integrated into a student's
learning
am i reading correctly but that will be
determined to what degree by the local
school district
that's what i would understand in other
words we're basically signaling to them
that we think these are important areas
and you can continue to offer them as a
separate thing if that's what you want
to do but otherwise we think that you
should look for opportunities to
integrate and because you're focusing we
think that that sets up the system that
encourages that type of integration so
that would follow up that would move uh
these
content areas away from
x number of minutes per week and
uh
at least k through 12.
um
one more okay one more the next section
instruction in core domains and learning
shall be complemented with integrated
instruction for the development of
aptitudes
i mean right away i'm wondering what is
actually being said here uh including
effective communication analytic
research benevolence public and private
charity
industry and economy honesty and
punctuality sincere sincerity and
self-control my question is
who picked the attributes how were these
decided upon how are they going to be
instructed and how are they ever going
to be measured
well so certainly you recognize the list
of most of those from article 83 of the
new hampshire constitution right so in
article 83 we basically say these are
things that we want our students
inculcated with
the vernacular may be dated
and i don't think that there's per se
magic to this but what we're recognizing
is that beyond those core subjects these
types of attributes and character traits
are important to the success of the
students
representative ford did you have a
question
thank you mr chair
uh for taking my question thank you sir
for answering or attempting to answer
this what i'm going to pose
i wonder if we conducted an experiment
here
and asked everyone who had studied a
foreign language in college to raise
their hand
and then ask shall we continue this
meeting in that language
how many hands would still be set up
would we ask that question
so i'm happy to answer that question
because i can tell you i did not study
language in college
because
because you learn how to learn and you
can learn things the follow-up question
is
if we teach a language in a college as
we do in many cases
and then we never require them to use
that language in any other course
how long are they likely to continue to
command that language
not very long i suspect do it and i do
want to i'll comment a little bit on the
language because i do love foreign
languages and so i do i understand what
you're saying in terms of
you know
years of study go in and many people
don't have any uh utility for that um
that doesn't
in i don't disagree with the premise but
i wouldn't say that not being able to
use it
obviates
all of the benefit of studying it
because when you learn another language
you're firing off different neurons in
your brain which are going to be
beneficial you have those other pathways
when you're learning another language
you're understanding another grammar um
and as the famous historian uh you know
uh lukakus said you know saying
something in a different language isn't
just saying the same thing with
different you know sounds it's actually
saying something slightly different um
you know so there's nuance to it as well
yeah i hope that helps follow one more
would that also apply to mathematics
though in the same way i mean we take
courses in mathematics and then we're
never in another course asked to apply
that mathematics toward that
subject yeah so sometimes you're asked
to apply it and sometimes you're not but
what i would tell you is when you learn
how to solve a quadratic equation you
learn how to
um think logically you know how to build
multi-variable uh you know thought
processes and that helps you whether
you're dealing with mathematics computer
programming a complex you know
literature piece of literature that has
a very uh you know complex storyline or
plot
and i wonder why so many of our teachers
take neither of those courses
thank you representative cornell thank
you
thank you thank you for taking my
question i'm coming from manchester
which is very very underfunded and
one of the under-resourced schools
it would be hard
how will this work for them and will
there be any targeted aid to help
manchester
offer some of these things
so these things are already required so
really what we're doing is we're
allowing the district to focus their
resources so it's not nothing is being
asked in addition this is already part
of an adequate education what you're
really doing is you're saying this is a
focus this is the point that's that will
help to
to allow that to be focused and if i
might share a story about manchester um
so manchester has a computer science
class
right now it is the most failed class in
the school district
not because it's so difficult but
because it's so boring
um that kids just check out um so we're
working with manchester right now to
develop through learn everywhere a
program with esports to learn computer
programming through esports so then you
know which is a much more engaging thing
so that's the you see it's just one more
extension of applying knowledge in a
domain so that you can engage the
students as best you can so we are happy
to work with manchester uh to try and
help them understand how to do this
focus but i think that this is a
reprieve for many of our school leaders
who can say okay i get this this is
where i can now focus and get done the
job at task because remember
every year you know nape releases
results fees are released releases
results every couple of years right they
don't do that every year or nape is
every other year and we have the new
hampshire sas and we all look at these
results by which we're measuring the
efficacy of our system and we see like
oh they didn't get the job done you know
because they got 50 of the kids to
proficiency don't we want to see that
improve and again i think that's what
not only do we want to see that improve
but
you know starting back you know with
brown v board of education we wanted
that improved and we're still working on
that
doesn't seem right representative porter
this is just a quick question thank you
again uh
commissioner so if i'm understanding
right and i
might not be understanding correctly
looking at the list of things that are
on page 2 under roman 2 those a through
g
if a school district was trying to save
money
if this bill passes
would they be able to eliminate their
world languages program
and get rid of those teachers
would they be able to get rid of their
um arts education program etc because
it's no longer part of the requirement
from the state yeah so they would still
be required to offer that type of
instruction it may be that and even they
can do this today they can offer that
through vlax or some other means
the objective would be to see more of
the integration take place so you would
see
schools instead of isolating art like i
mean it drives me not sometimes why is
art and math not
integrated right like this is you know
like uh you know if you're learning
about vanishing points you're learning
some geometry there and uh you know so
so what we need to see happen is we need
to enable the schools to stay focused
and then pull these other disciplines in
in terms of how to engage the students
follow up so as opposed to isolating is
that clear what i'm saying no it's not
um okay
if
if i'm got english language arts and i
how am i going to pull french
into english language arts arithmetic
and mathematics natural physical science
or social studies
so how am i going to get them so that
they can be proficient in speaking
french
if i don't have
french classes that are focusing on
grammar and vocabulary but instead
they're being integrated into the
literature program so so they're able to
offer a french class but i would say
that you would integrate that with
humanities and it might be with world
history where you would introduce those
students to learning and they're
studying the french revolution and the
french teachers in there explaining some
of the stuff and describing some of that
language and the kid goes wow i would
love to learn french it would be awesome
right or it could be that you do uh in a
u.s history and you're studying
louisiana and louisiana purchase and the
french influence down there and how that
happened and so you're you're engaging
the students as opposed to i want to
learn french but if you haven't engaged
them first then we end up with what
representative ford said you have
students who are required to take a
language they go through two years or
three years of the language and they
don't master it
because it's a requirement not an
engagement
so this is where again it's a bold move
i get it right we're trying to be bold
here
but we're in in this boldness it's not
like we're
you know uh jettisoning everything we're
basically saying like let's focus
uh representative baum
thank you mr chairman and thank you
commissioner
to follow up
all right
and
right now in law the adequate education
says as music has art has has languages
has part of an adequate education but
yet they're not mandatory in the schools
isn't that right
i know they're having they're teaching
all these subjects
yeah but i mean the point is the schools
offer them but they're not really the
law says they're part of an adequate
education
but they're
they're elective courses in a lot of
high schools they're not mandatory so
but but they still have to offer the
high schools out of the minimum
standards um but again what you're
finding is then so students are are
checking off boxes as opposed to
focusing on
uh you know making sure that they get
the foundational stuff down because what
we do is we cram another item into the
uh already busy you know and limited day
so i guess what i'm saying here this
will not really change anything
just it just puts the focus on
i think it helps us to focus our effort
and again if i look at six decades of
not being able to figure out how to get
this thing forward
i don't think
you know that this is uh i think that
that type of focus and the way that
we've architected it here
allows us to do that focus
the you know at best the focus allows us
to close some of those disparity gaps at
worst we haven't taken anything away
thank you
i was wondering
since this is a bold move
how much of this or is any of this going
to be applicable to charter schools
as part of our public school system
yeah so i would assume that so the
churches are public schools and so they
also go through i believe um you know
the same adequate education law so
representative
so
they're not required as far as i
understand
to follow the education laws unless it's
specifically stated in those education
laws and i don't see it specifically
stated here so what i'm wondering is how
much of this
is actually going to be used in charter
schools and how much
will be up to them to pick and choose
what they want to use and what they
don't want to use right so the content
is the same so you don't see it in this
law but you would see it over in 194b
which tells the charter schools that
they have to teach the new hampshire
academic standards so that stuff pulls
over that way so i don't think that
there's any disparity there
see no further
representative waltz
thank you
um commissioner
the whole idea of integrated education
was a hot topic in the 1990s
and there were schools that designed
their whole programs around doing
integrated into education there are some
major shortfalls of trying to take an
approach of integrated education where
kids have huge gaps and what they didn't
learn when you're focused on the
integrated education as opposed to the
more traditional education where you're
trying to to silo some of these things
and i'm wondering if in putting forth
which is really just another version of
integrated education is what you're
proposing here if you have looked at
those programs the reasons people moved
away from them the aspects that failed
and the aspects that worked
so happy to answer that question um so
this is not the same as the previous
integrated education because in the
previous educated
integrated education
there was not the focal point right it
was like you have all these subjects do
them all but just mix them up and do
them together uh well that is how most
of that was done and what i would tell
you is while your statement that the
integrated education
revealed gaps in that education those
gaps existed before integrated education
and they exist after integrated
education and so i what i would tell you
is
the gaps are persistent and they're
still there
can i follow up
quickly please
so i'll give you a really good example
my kids beau moved to the integrated
system which is where my kids went to
school they took
math down integrated math one that was
supposed to be basically algebra and
then they went to a private school for
the balance of the high school and
actually one also did the integrated two
there they got to the private school and
discovered huge gaps in their math
knowledge they really hadn't learned
algebra one they really hadn't learned
geometry they had some basics but they
hadn't really learned it
and they found this in other subject
matters as well that there were huge
gaps
so even with that program in one of the
best school districts in the state
there were huge gaps and i'm it really
was what what beau was doing is no
different than what you're proposing
here and i am confused
like as to why this is better i mean we
have you listed it you listed at the
beginning all the attempts over the last
50 years to reinvent education that
haven't changed it because what you put
in here the problem isn't this it's a
socio-economic problem this doesn't
address the underlying socioeconomic
problems so i'm still confused as to how
creating a system that now once again
creates holes addresses the educational
issues that are really founded on
socioeconomic issues
so i would actually i'm not familiar
with the bow program i can tell you that
they continue to offer integrated
education beau continues to be one of
the top performing schools in the state
of new hampshire i'm sorry that your
children didn't benefit from that
instruction
and ended up with gaps in that
what i would tell you is that if what we
can't avoid is we have to make sure that
we're focused on english language arts
arithmetic and mathematics natural and
physical science and social studies if
we give our students those things we've
equipped them to be lifelong learners
and effective citizens
uh representative luno
thank you mr chair thanks again uh uh
commissioner for taking my question so
um so following on what representative
walls is talking about and the
the phrase that you just used that gaps
are persistent and they're still there
and they're certainly there
um
i mean i'll pick a couple of
you know a couple of school districts
hannover and newport
um how is this going to close the gap in
student opportunities
between hanover and newport because it's
going to allow my instructional staff in
newport to focus on these core
foundational
subject areas right and hone in on them
put the big blocks into the box first
and so when you because you identify you
say hanover and newport have different
performance they have different
performances across these domains that
we're testing here right and so by
focusing the instruction on there and
not trying to fit more things into the
day in newport maybe they can make up
the gaps for the economically
disadvantaged kids that are not
otherwise being able to close that gap
so follow-up
so
i mean just going with your analogy
which i think is is maybe not you know
square on the mark here but uh doesn't
hanover have a bigger box or a bigger
bucket than newport to begin with
sure in what sense uh they have a whole
all of them have in terms of access to
financial resources so but that's not
the box the box of the children that
we're trying to you know fill up with
the core knowledge that they want so
your analogy is not consistent you just
said the boxes the hours and the day and
the the availability resources so
newport fill up the box with the big
rocks first before you put the sand in
hanover just happens to have a bigger
box they can put the big rocks and the
sand and a lot more sand yeah so so
what's what's closing the opportunity
gap here
so what's closing the opportunity gap is
that we have an opportunity in newport
to be able to focus our instructional
time
and to those students who to
representative walters comment the
economically disadvantaged kids who are
falling behind can now we can spend more
time with them
in these subjects that they are
deficient in that they are falling
behind in to try and move them up and i
would tell you that the thing that we're
trying to fill up is so the box is i
have a fixed day but what i'm trying to
fill up are my students with information
and if your students in hanover can
master algebra in an hour and a half and
so he can move on and he's doing the
french but my other student over in
representative walters district needs
two hours to do that why would i not say
to the school you have the flexibility
focus on these things and make sure that
everyone gets these correct as opposed
to cutting everybody off in an hour and
a half and moving on and leaving those
kids behind because they're the that's
where you've just created that gap
thank you commissioner uh is this quick
mr representative woodcock well i have
been waiting
thank you i will make it as quick as the
commissioner answered that yes christian
thank you for taking my question um
i i appreciate the the commentary uh
from the get-go honestly in the dialogue
can you i'm looking at the the line that
talks about the adequate education
and it's going to be defined as
rigorous academic study
can you explain that to me rigorous
academic study sure i mean that is
language that's consistent with the
statute today and it is basically
rigorous academic study means that we're
challenging our students right so
students we don't want to
um you know continue if they're in high
school they shouldn't be reading at a
second grade level we should always be
challenging them to be able to read uh
beyond that so
rigorous is referring to the the
challenge that we bring so that would
bring students to new places
so so it's not it's not a measurable
piece i mean there's no
way to assess that rigorous academic
study from one district to another
um there's not a quantitative measurable
definition of rigorous probably not the
measure is the accountability system
which is the assessments that
representative luna is referring to
so the uh it's all part of the same
question replica
so the assessment pieces that you were
talking the national assessment
standards the two or three ones you
identified that is going to be the
determinant of the rigorous academic
study so what i will tell you is that is
the standard today and that is the
standard that we are all measuring
ourselves against um we get federal
funding because we participate in those
standards in those assessments that's
going to be the measure
that is our measure that we have today
if this board wants to come up with this
board that's fine but let me just be
clear so this board has passed a law
that says that we will administer this
assessment if this board wants to give
me another academic you know measure
then i'm happy to try and you know
implement that
let me just go back to the i know i know
rather than cordelia loving the third
question they
go back to the third part we said
you're talking about bold
and requiring districts to step up
to provide i was based on that rigorous
study more
professional development more evaluation
more critical thinking teachers
performing better so students perform
better more engagement that whole piece
are you bold enough to say or is this
legislation bold enough to say that the
high school diploma
will be
uh
on the on the level of proficiency
so if you're telling us that 90 of the
people are getting high school diplomas
with 50 proficiency i think that was a
statement to use
is this is this bold enough to say that
there's no high school diploma
you cannot get to that
proficient area you should not be
uh eligible for high school deformers is
that is that bull are we gonna do that
are you gonna do that so that is a
policy for example that massachusetts
implemented a number of years ago with
their mcats um it is not a policy that
our legislature has passed but if that
is something that this legislature wants
to entertain how we can have that
conversation i think that this is uh you
know bold but not it's not it's not as
disruptive as that type of a of a
measure this is really bold in the sense
that we're saying we're signaling quite
clearly this is what is really important
that we can't not have this you know get
done
last one last guarantee the but the end
bucket the end bucket then
based on that of the
mcas was disruptive it is now
effective
based on that bucket
under these percentiles
fifty percent full is going to be
adequate in new hampshire
let's try to understand the question if
ninety percent of our youngsters i
haven't hit the 50 level so 50
is going to be
that's us we're going to be a bull
standard
so well i mean so this is a step in in
the direction of bold but what you're
saying is we want 100 of our kids to get
to proficiency how bold are you willing
to make the high school diploma we're
saying half the kids are already failing
but we're going to give him a diploma
that's all thank you thank you
thank you um thank you very much
commissioners see no further questions
we'll end the hearing on hb 1671
and um
we're due to start up again at one
o'clock
um
with the
next bill
we have we have nobody else speaking
representative cordelli
okay
did you say 115 representative
cordelie's already heard
thank you
you
thank you mr chairman and thank you
members of the education committee for
the record my name is representative
erica leon representing derry
when i put this bill together um with my
co-sponsors we looked at a couple of the
details that i had wish bin had been
straightened out a little bit more last
year around but it was it was a big
undertaking and i appreciate everything
that was passed
one of the areas that i thought was
important is
that these this isn't funding that's
going directly to any of these
institutions this is going to the
parents in order to provide an education
for their students so they're taking
this money going to approved providers
but they may be choosing from multiple
different providers or they may be
meeting 95 percent of the education
that they're required to provide
underneath this
at say a private school but there may be
some part of the education that they
provide that isn't part of the
curriculum
that doesn't mean that that school isn't
meeting anything it just
clarified the parent still needs to make
sure that they are receiving that
education whether or not they're
directly purchasing it from somebody so
i thought that having the language that
i put on page one line six through ten
would help make that clear so that
future legislatures and everybody else
would be a little bit more clear in the
intent that this the parent is directing
where they get the education and where
they spend the mountain the money from
this
i'm also concerned about privacy i know
that's something that is very important
to us here in new hampshire we have
article 2b and i hear we hear that
constantly over in hhs and i believe you
hear it here as well
the portfolio review
is something that is
a work product of the student so that
should be something that remains part of
the student's portfolio and doesn't get
handed directly to the state
so that
was added in lines 24-27
of page one
and i appreciate that there have been
there have been quite a few opinions
that
the art the withdrawal language saying
that upon notice the scholarship
organization an efa student may choose
to stop receiving efa funding and enroll
full-time in a public school
doesn't mean that they're not able to go
to any of the other options that that's
intended to make sure that they still
have a place at the resident district
just like every other child in this
state
i prefer the language making it clear it
can be any other way to satisfy educate
satisfy compulsory education but i
understand that that is the intent of
the words that are in there this is just
just trying to be a little more clear
for posterity
and in order to make sure that we
are keeping that same intent
that a student won't be denied re-entry
into the public school in their resident
district
there's the language added on lines 12
and 13.
so those were the specific parts that i
had when i was drafting it but my
intention as well was to be able to look
at what was happening with jalcar look
at how this is evolving and see what
other problems
what other clarification i wouldn't say
problem so what other clarifications
would be helpful
so i
i would be very open to addressing any
of the problems that are coming through
or any of the questions that are there
anything that should be resolved in
legislation now but i also
appreciate that we not i may not have a
more full understanding of exactly which
tweaks we would like to see until later
on after the session after we've we
finished meeting this year in may and it
may be something that
either we can we can find the right
language now or we could interim study
it if we need to
look at a group in the future i i leave
that in your hands to be able to use
this as the best vehicle to improve this
program
because it is a huge asset for families
it's a huge benefit for families who
can't otherwise afford to
purchase educational materials a la
carte or participate in private schools
or in any of these other services
and i know dozens and dozens and dozens
of families for whom this has been
such a relief for them because money
that was going
to buy educational materials last year
out of their pocketbooks they're able to
better cope with the increase in gas
prices
the increasing prices at the grocery
store and they actually don't have much
more room and flexibility than they did
last year but with these rising prices
they would have really been in a world
of hurt because i know
a lot of people that that really it
could be a choice between
getting getting free resources or what
they're eating and i'm so glad that with
this program people don't have to make
that choice
because we are providing this
for
some of our lower income
lower income people it's not always
lower income you know i don't like to
draw that line because a lot of that
depends on how you use your resources i
know some people on a really
tight income
that do an amazing job and they don't go
wanting because of how they shape their
choices
so i want to appreciate that
i just i don't want it to be drawing
lines between
different groups of people but i really
appreciate that we have this i would
like to make it stronger and i also
understand that this is
a newer program and if now's not the
time to make these changes i would
appreciate that as well so with that
i'll take any questions thank you very
much representative i have one question
for you on the first page
uh line 25
when you're talking about the parent
shall provide only the evaluation
document are you talking about the
evaluation report
the document is there certain criteria
that should be in it or would it be
i guess the word report would really
tell me a lot more than just the word
document is that the evaluation
what is that you know
what was it a test an assessment of some
kind or was it you know a review of the
portfolio
that is intended to be for the portfolio
review because it's taught in the part
talking about maintaining the portfolio
and have the it says the parent shall
have a certified teacher a teacher
currently teaching in non-public school
selected to evaluate the progress upon
the portfolio review and discussion so
that would be a document about the
evaluation a report would be fine
language to me
i think that that's one of the things
that specifically what they call that
portfolio review evaluation is probably
going to come through rules
and so
if you have better language we can
figure out how how to tie that in and
perhaps set the language for this
portfolio evaluation thank you
yes representative waltz
thank you
um
i must be misreading this and i'm
looking for help here
because i'm looking at the first changes
on lines 7 through 9 through 10.
and to me what it does is it looks like
it just relieves parents
or anybody or a school or anybody from
complying with the educational
requirements that we just considered in
the last bill under section 193 of the
law and it says they're not provided to
change the course to fulfill these
requirements
but if they're not required to change
the course to fulfill the requirements
and they're not fulfilling them
it's like it's exempting them from the
basic requirements of education am i
misreading this
um thank you for the question and i
believe you are
this is dividing out what the education
providers
provide so if you're contracting with
just one a private school
and you're the parent you may have a
separate education provider who you are
who which we are using to fulfill some
of this
let's say that
you don't like the language program at
the private school so instead you are
going into a german club and immersing
and paying for some membership fees
if you aren't getting language at the
private school and instead the parent is
choosing to fulfill that somewhere else
having the obligation on that private
school to teach language
when they are getting a superior program
through one another resource
wouldn't be a fair burden on that
original education provider it is the
parent that signs a contract and not the
education providers and it is the
parents duty as part of this contract to
make sure that their student that their
child receives the education as defined
in 194 f3
3d1
yes
so i understand that intention
but i'm not convinced that's what this
says i think under the rules of
statutory construction
what this says is education providers
don't have to basically
change any program to meet the basic
requirements set out in
lines three through six
and
you know one of the things i've learned
in my many years here is being be aware
of unintended consequence and i think
the way this is drafted that is an
unintended consequence is that you're
basically saying education providers
don't have to do what they need to do to
meet the requirements set out in the
paragraph above it and that's my concern
as to the way i read it and i understand
that was not your intent but i do
believe that is what the statutory
construction says
thank you for that lines 9 and 10 state
that the responsibility
remains with the parent to meet these
requirements
that puts the requirement on the parent
further questions representative porter
and then representative woodcock thank
you mr chair and thank you
representative um i want to go back to
the um portfolio section section c
i'm looking at um and i know this is in
current law line 22
it says the parent shall have a
certified teacher or a teacher currently
teaching in a non-public school who was
selected by the parent evaluate the
students educational progress
upon review of a portfolio
and discussion with the parent or
student
i'm a sir i i'm no longer a certified
teacher because i'm retired now but
i was certified in early childhood
education grades k through three
and i would feel very comfortable
evaluating a portfolio of a child in
that age group
however i would not be comfortable
evaluating a portfolio for high school
chemistry because i don't have an
expertise in that but it appears to me
from this law
that the parent could come to me and say
will you evaluate my high school
chemistry uh kids portfolio
um and that it would be perfectly all
right for me to do that so i'm wondering
if you might perhaps put some language
in
that specifies that
the teacher who is evaluating the
portfolio have some
um certification or knowledge of the
area that's being
evaluated
i appreciate your concern there i think
that also comes down to the teacher
because i know that you would not feel
comfortable doing that and you would
decline there needs to be an agreement
between both of them and
that evaluation and review
if you look at that so sorry
i get off into tangents i'm going to
refocus right back here
you wouldn't have a teacher who
choosing to do that
i believe that teachers are ethical
professionals and that they would only
evaluate a student within their scope of
knowledge and i
i don't think that we have to legislate
for every small wrinkle of how somebody
may be dishonorable and instead realize
that our teachers are a huge resource
and a huge asset and they take what they
do seriously
but still under the car under the way
it's written that could happen
it could happen under this so you might
want to protect
protect the students and the parents
from that happening thank you
uh represent woodcock
thank you chairman good afternoon
welcome to our late starting community
um
and
i was going to follow up on
representative west on the end on
line seven
if if the
private organization that the parents
are taking their child to
doesn't have to follow the requirements
as exhibit up above what they should do
for core requirements
and it still remains under be the
responsibility of the parent why do you
even have that in there
what's the value of if they don't follow
it they don't need to provide it they
don't need to modify the curriculum why
would you have it there because as you
said the underlying responsibility to
remains of the parents
thank you for the question the
responsibility is on the parent it's on
the parent to provide that education
that meets those standards it does not
require that efa funds are spent on each
of those portions because it's not
dictating where you're using these you
may simply go and be going for intensive
work in one area when you're one of
these a la carte students it's less of
an issue for those who are getting all
of their education from one
provider but even then
they may not
there still can be instruction at home
even if you're full-time enrolled in a
school
i understand that i just don't i
understand that um but i don't
understand why line seven is there at
all why you need it
um thank you the money doesn't go
directly to the schools the contract is
not with the education provider it is
with the parent
the parent
who chooses how to do that is the one
responsible for allocation of funds
so in this case the first two words
education provider you're saying that's
the parent
no okay so why why does it why do we
need that line in there at all that's my
point question i'm missing it
i think that the number of questions we
have around it is it explains some of
why we need it
if there's a move to make sure that
anybody taking these funds checks every
single box on this even if they're not a
full-time or even if the parent is
choosing to provide some of this
education this provides needed clarity
to show that the education provider
provides a poor apportion or all
of the education that's required and
that the parent maintains the
responsibility
for the student meeting those
requirements
okay thank you
i got one follow-up on on line seven
there where we were just talking about
what would happen if we scratched
lines seven and eight
and then had versus b
responsibility to fulfill stu study
requirements for students participating
in the efa program remain with the
parent
i think that sounds wonderful
wonderful excuse mr chairman it does
sound beautifully from your voice that's
exactly what i'm asking i asked it three
times
but you've made it so much better
sharing life oh thank you i
i'm sorry i might still have a couple
scars
so
you wouldn't object to that type of
language i just i i
i
the point is that the response i i guess
the responsibility remains with the
parent not any not any particular
education provider perhaps putting that
together because you're right that is
missing that i'm deferring to my former
chairman
so responsibility remains with a parent
not any one education provider to meet
these requirements for all students
and what i said responsibility to
fulfill study requirements for students
participating in the efa program
remains with the parent
and
it's a thought uh reps and like us then
represent tanner
thank you
hang on i can't see you from here
i'll let you keep writing
so
my understanding and correct me if i'm
wrong
the education providers
part
is there
so that the education provider doesn't
feel compelled if they're taking efa
money to have to change things because i
know p it was a discussion that's been
had is that while this provider you know
they can't be a provider because they're
not providing all of this and so it's
sort of a protection on the other end is
that the providers then know
no i don't have to do all of this i can
provide the part that i provide
and i'm not
ineligible
to get this
money i mean you know to for the kid to
participate or for the provider to
participate i'm not ineligible because i
don't do all of this because i have
heard people try to say oh that provider
shouldn't be allowed because they don't
fulfill all of these things and so it's
a way of protecting the providers to say
no you're not expected to do everything
you do the part you do well
it's the parent who has to make sure and
fill in any parts that are missed right
or that it's provided some other way is
that correct
that yes that is correct and that's why
i guess there was that hesitation that
um that it would be good so the
responsibility to fulfill the
requirements
remains with the parent and not any one
education provider might be a way to
reflect that and respect that as well
just some way to make that clear without
cutting it in such a way that it's going
to be
confusing
because the point is to make sure that
one education provider
isn't expected to do
everything if that's not their mission
okay representative tanner than
representative ford thank you mr chair
and thank you for it's good to see you
back here i'm wondering on page 2 lines
12 and 13
um it seems redundant be
and not necessary because if the child
is living
uh
in a certain address then then they
have the right to go to public school
once the faa is done
i don't see
you know i just think it's
a duplication of what's already in the
law
and
i don't understand why it's there i
guess
thank you for the question um i i do
believe that it is their right to go
back to those schools as well i had
heard different discussions
and i wanted to put that in as a safety
net
if it's very clear then that's
if everybody understands that these
students don't give up their right to go
back to the public school and be treated
just as any other student
then that is that's the point
further questions
represent ford yes
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i wonder whether the
clarification you're looking for is then
worried
to something to extend through whatever
combination of providers is necessary
within that statement you had there the
the made to whatever sub-providers or
whatever distinction you want to make so
that they can be a combination of
individual schools
all qualified individually for their
part of it
thank you that's a good question but
parents aren't defined as an education
provider in this because then they could
be funded for providing the education
for their own student so the parent may
be providing that education and that
would come into our portfolio review and
that's one of the areas where a
portfolio review is more important when
you're doing an a la carte because if
you're meeting one part of the statutes
here another part there that all should
come together in that portfolio to make
sure that you are meeting the
requirements of the efa program
and you may have paid for sixty percent
of it or eighty percent of it
or whichever par or a hundred percent of
it but the parent is not an education
provider under the terms of the statute
because they're not paid and the parent
should be able to fulfill those
educational requirements as part of that
thank you
further questions
not yeah yeah
thank you very much thank you
and that's it for this hearing
we have uh
about five or six minutes here
the hearing's over
it it's i understand what she's trying
to do it but it's written like a knife
you
okay folks we need to get on it's
a little past uh
1 45 here and we have a bill coming up
at 145 relative to the education service
providers
under the education freedom accounts
program that's 11 20.
and representative mullen is waiting
here i am
thank you welcome to the committee thank
you mr chair and thank you colleagues on
house education for hearing me today for
the record my name is sue mullen and i
represent hillsborough county district 7
the town of bedford
house bill 1120 focuses on two central
things
quality of instruction and student
safety
with the precipitous arrival of the
education freedom accounts not much was
able to be done regarding the extensive
list of concerns that had been expressed
with house bill 20 before new
hampshire's voucher program was signed
into law
the scope of my bill only scratches the
surface but it does address the
qualifications and background
of people who are being paid with state
funds to teach our children in
non-traditional settings
first house bill 1120 requires that
enter any entity applying for funds as
an education service provider be in
service for a year before being accepted
as a participant
during that year student performance
data and financial viability data would
be able to be collected by the provider
and shared with the scholarship
organization or the department of
education as part of a vetting
application process
we can't be too careful when the client
is our children
next any education service provider
offering instruction as a school or
program should be approved through the
non-public school approval process
outlined in ed 400 administrative rules
there is a reason why every state board
of education approved non-public school
has been required to go through this
process
it is essential to the educational
well-being of our students that they
receive quality instruction with
recognized standards and dedicated
oversight
and it is essential that students who
are participating in the state funded
efa program are guaranteed that safety
net as well
the third provision of the bill
literally deals with local and state
health and safety standards
in 2018 the governor's school safety
preparedness task force recommended 59
steps to be taken to address student
wellness
those recommendations ranged from things
like assuring the kids aren't drinking
leaded water
that fire safety measures are in place
that staff are trained in first aid
suicide and bully prevention bullying
prevention
and that things like reunification plans
are in place in the event of an
emergency
the doe has a number of tools on their
website to guide teachers in the do's
and don'ts of setting up classroom
environments
fire code
requirements allergy management
practices
the impact of clutter upon a student's
ability to concentrate
the importance of proper ventilation to
optimize learning and assuring that
emergency plans are well established and
understood by even our very young
students are all highlighted
local and statewide ordinances are meant
to protect us all at home and at school
and those protections should be
extended to efa students as well
the final aspect of the bill that i will
draw your attention to is on line 16 and
it requires that all education service
providers submit a criminal background
check that is compliant with rsa 189 13
a
to the department of education
the law
currently prevent that law currently
prevents employment in a public school
for anyone guilty of a section 5
violation and i would propose that it
should be applicable to education
service providers too
when dzhokhar was delivering the
deliberating the rules for the efa
program they noted that there was no
provision in the new statute that
required a criminal background check for
education service providers and no
stipulation that potentially barring
employment was tied to those results
this bill represents an attempt to
correct those pitfalls of hastiness and
further assure student safety
thank you very much for allowing me to
introduce this bill
and i am happy to take questions
questions of the presenter represent
like us
yes i'm not sure how many of these apply
to all service providers for one
and so like if somebody was doing an
online course would they have to have
health and safety
stuff for their facility and codes and
all of that
is there a reason they have to be at
least one year
um
in order to participate
and a number of these other things i
think that's why
our previous bill had that section in
there about not having to comply with
all this oh it was not lost on me
representative lacus as we were
listening to that testimony
because some of these just do not apply
a service provider might be something
that teaches one
small thing a service provider might be
something who specializes in say
dyslexia and is going to meet with a
student once every some number of weeks
to work on a specific
thing with that teacher and they may be
fully certified in dyslexia by a
different organization and not follow
any of the rest of these things except
for maybe the
the criminal history
check but
it seems awfully broad and full of rules
for things that don't necessarily apply
i
am aware that there is no
one-size-fits-all
actually i thought of you because when i
originally submitted the bill
it was not submitted as one bill it came
back from ols's one bill because the
provisions that i was referencing all
had to do with uh educational service
providers
so it became uh
a buffet as opposed to an entree so uh i
i hear what you're saying to
to answer
your question a little more broadly what
i did when i was looking at the language
in house bill 20 on education service
providers
was to
try to uh
categorize
if you will
what was happening around the country
with
other programs some similar maybe not
quite in scope but similar in practice
so i looked at
the financial financial stability aspect
and discovered that
georgia
oklahoma
utah
mississippi washington d.c
all require that their service providers
be in business for a year in order to
establish finance financial stability
records
at before they can be accepted as a
service provider so i thought oh okay
all right well that would in fact give
you time to
for for whomever the scholarship
organization really to be able to sort
of check things out
thank you
i got a question for you yes sir on this
same line here i guess on five and six
where you're talking about
be around for one year prior
uh to ensure financial sustainability
well the edsel was around for a couple
years but then it was not sustainable
so
does
being in business one year
demonstrate that you have financial
sustainability or does it
identify some other aspect besides
finance i
would love to be able to answer that
question as an economist for you
representative vlad um all i can say is
i'll repeat what i said to uh
representative lakis and that is the
one-year standard
seemed to be the most commonly put into
place practice for other states that
have
voucher programs savings accounts
however whatever semantic language we
want to use i mean basically what what
you're we're doing there was there was a
situation in north carolina i guess one
in milwaukee
where um
fraud was an issue i mean we've had
fraud issues in new hampshire
and so the intent is just for somebody
to be up and running long enough to be
able to establish themselves as a
legitimate business before
they're out
taking people's money
okay representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative
this is a little bit of a would you
believe
question i'm looking at um
section f line i think that's 15 local
and state
health and safety standards
when
and then this is for representative
moffat as well
when i ran my little school
because it was not a because it was a
case
a pre-k
i was not part of the department of
education i had to get licensed through
dhhs as a child care provider
and the list of rules and regulations
and safety
inspections that needed to be done on my
property to make sure i was safe for
children
really opened my eyes having just come
from a public school where i taught
kindergarten and knowing what was there
compared to what i had to provide so i
think it's wise of you to put this in
because
it's something that's overlooked i think
to a logic i mean every once in a while
the fire department would come into the
public school and say you can't hang
things from the ceiling
and that kind of stuff but it was not to
the depth
of
detail that i had to follow when i ran
the preschool kindergarten under dhhs
and that was all to keep the kids safe
so i think thank you very much
representative porter thank you um and
also representative porter uh to to what
you're saying um
arkansas is probably the first state
that put this provision into their
program
and uh their their
provision was based on a situation in
indiana where there were unsafe
there were kids in situations that were
unsafe in terms of uh not having any
kind of inspection
and again in washington dc there was a
situation there where kids were
in a place that didn't have running
water and didn't have heat during the
winter and that kind of thing
were there further questions
representative moffatt
thank you mr thank you take my question
uh
it's very reasonable well thought out to
me but i do want to ask you a couple
questions about um
line
seven
uh so
let me give you two examples that you
can respond to
so if if a parent or family is looking
for some
beyond
the basics but some specialized
instructions say in the field of music
or
in the trades for example as an
apprentice
um so there are we probably all know
examples of
music people who teach uh they have a
gift and skill music and they teach and
they take on people or somebody in the
trades who has apprentices and you name
it you know electric uh as an
electrician whatever
so
if the providing instruction to students
on
approved non-public uh
so my question is would this preclude
like a specialized program that would
have preclude like
an apprentice situation or a music
teacher who are not certified from being
part of the mix
i i don't believe so representative
moffat i will tell you that that is the
spot where that was supposed to be a
standalone and and that provision is
supposed to read
any educational service provider that
purports to be a school or a program has
to go through the ed 400
approval process
it does not read that way when it came
back to me late in the drafting process
from ols
we agreed that we would wait until it
came before the committee and then if
there was an opportunity to
amend it we would do do so uh i do
believe that any service provider that
is with a child
particularly alone
should go through the background check
because i just think that that makes
sense and i think that it allows parents
to confidently allow people to work with
their kids without having to worry about
you know whether or not they missed
something when they were screening
education service providers
and i do believe that any education
service provider that has a prescribed
program or is describing itself as a
school
should do
what every
school a private schooler or non-public
school in new hampshire has done and
that is
go to the ed 400 rules and utilize the
section that applies to them i mean if
you look at those rules
i just happen to have them in front of
me
if you look at the rules what you'll
find is that
different sections
of
the ed 400
rules
deal with different aspects of
non-public education
including the budget
including the budget you know when we
were talking about um being open for a
year if you go through the ed 400 rules
it's all over the place that before they
will
approve
saint anywhere
or uh
you know the little school of skipping
stones or whatever the you know whatever
the private organization is called they
have to provide a budget and demonstrate
financial feasibility before they'll be
approved by the state board of ed
you
thank you thank you for taking my
question this is
probably for more from my edification
but
do all
uh education service providers under the
scholarship organizat do they have to be
registered with a scholarship
organization or registered with the
department of education or are they just
uh
there's no um
accounting of
who
actually is an education provider i i
wish i could answer that question
thoroughly for you i will give you what
information i know and then i will count
on anybody who's behind me to supplement
it representative tanner
some of the education service providers
are already on the state board of
education approved lists
some have been vetted through the
scholarship organization
but i don't believe that if you're a
parent and you have to and you're hiring
an individual to work with your student
i don't believe that that person has to
be vetted
necessarily does that answer your
question
or registered with anybody i don't
believe so
if i were allowed to i would turn to my
right and i would ask that question
uh representative hopps
uh thank you and i i just was looking
for clarification is there anyone here
who can answer that question for us
because i was i was under the impression
that they had to be follow up i'm sorry
i i don't have a an answer or response
without having to read about it
um
matt do you have your hand up
would you like me would you like
representative tanner
ask it or me representative flat no
representative go ahead and ask your
question again please
sure and um
ms fenton's here attorney fenton's here
from doe as well
i just wondered if education
providers as as listed under this
bill um 194
if they have to be registered or
um
well not necessarily vetted because
that's what we're talking about now but
registered either with the scholarship
organization
or
with
uh the doe or do they
just
a parent can say so and so well not even
say who the educational provider is they
have to be registered
okay by excuses
um just as a follow-up to that yeah are
they registered um
how how how are they registered i mean
like
uh representative moffat's uh example of
you know the
flute teacher who
takes gives lessons in their home or
something
[Music]
how are they registered
thank you
i have two questions for you
representative mullen yes sir um
the
online 15
it says comply with state and local
health and safety standards codes
uh if the provider is an online service
do they have to do that no no they would
not have to uh we're not looking at
bandwidth at least not yet the other one
is approved non-public school education
program pursuant to the department of
education
is there a fee associated with that
you know i don't know the answer to that
you mean as far as whether or not to get
approval to get approval uh i i
i don't believe it appears anywhere in
the in the ed 400 rules that there's a
fee
okay just it was just a question yeah no
i i i i'm unaware of it if there is
or if there would be yeah
further questions
not seeing any thank you very much
you're quite welcome
or an interim study
you
okay we're ready to go ahead with the
last hearing of the day it's hb 1683
repealing the education freedom account
program
before we have the uh prime spots which
is rep san luna present
i'd like to mention to everybody we have
about approximately 20 cards here
i would and they're probably more coming
in
would you please state of course your
name and if you're representing an
organization are you just representing
yourself but also
when you're giving your presentation
please don't do a lot of duplication
what we've heard over and over and over
again by the time it gets the sixth
seventh person
you've the point has been made
so please you know keep your testimony
short if you have a story that you want
to tell that's fine but you know keep
that also within time frame if we gave
everybody three minutes here we'd be
here for what another hour
so uh please um
be concise and uh i think we'll make it
through so with that i'd like to
uh recognize representative luno
prime sponsor of 1683.
thank you very much mr chair members of
the um the committee for the record my
name is david luno um i'm in my uh my
fourth term
i represent the uh the
people of hopkinton and concord
and serve on this uh
this esteemed house education committee
we've heard a
lot this uh this session about how words
matter
and i agree words matter
and the truth matters
and being honest and transparent with
our constituents matters
matters a lot to me and i bet it matters
to you too
according to the national conference of
state legislatures school vouchers are
state-funded scholarships that pay for
students to attend private schools
rather than public schools
these private schools must meet minimum
standards established by legislatures
and legislatures set parameters for
student eligibility such as for families
to meet a specific income threshold
there's certainly a lot more detail in
rsa 194f about new hampshire's school
voucher program
but it has these basic characteristics
well except for the private schools
having to meet minimum standards
new hampshire's voucher program doesn't
have that
did you know that in 1975 new hampshire
had a school voucher pilot program in
rsa
194a in fact it's titled quote education
voucher programs and it's similar to
what the state enacted last summer
as part of the budget
with a few noticeable differences
school districts would not see a loss of
state aid
in fact the voucher was in addition to
this aid and not a substitution for it
another difference is that the payment
would flow from the school district to
the education service provider
and another big difference is the 1975
law included a provision to repeal it
after eight years
and guess what
it was repealed
so best i can tell the so-called
education freedom account program does
pretty much the same as the voucher
program
it directs taxpayer money to pay for
other people's private school tuition
and homeschool costs
but the new efa program doesn't set
standards for participating private
schools
it has a third party program
administrator with a current and former
state representative on their board that
keeps 10 percent of taxpayer money
and it doesn't have a repeal provision
in the end the efa program is a voucher
program that lacks education standards
accountability fraud protection
financial responsibility income
eligibility requirements at least after
the first year
is potentially subject to federal income
tax
is considered a parental placement under
the idea
and doesn't include repeal language
and i don't think passing public money
through a third party that takes a 10
cut makes it any better especially in
the eyes of taxpayers
so words do matter
what is clear is that new hampshire has
a voucher program and a bad voucher
program at that
to try to call it something else is
simply to recognize that granite staters
have rejected and continue to reject
voucher programs
the way the voucher program was hastily
jammed into the budget with no debate
with strong public opposition
has resulted in a program that is
financially irresponsible and leaves
students and taxpayers susceptible to
fraud and abuse
at best it's about using taxpayer money
to pay for someone else's private school
tuition and home school costs
at worst it's a blank check to pay for
just about anything
we've proposed a number of bills some
with bipartisan support
to set up some guard rails to protect
students and taxpayers
unless these bills move forward the only
responsible move
is to repeal the program
house bill 1516
prohibits the use of local property
taxes to fund school vouchers
it protects local taxpayers whose costs
would range from a few thousand dollars
per student to more than twenty thousand
dollars depending upon where you live
it will be on the house floor on
wednesday for debate and vote
house bill 1684 holds the program to
budgeted amounts
for this year at the request of the
department of education the state budget
included 129 000 for vouchers and it's
already blown the budget by more than
eight million dollars
before taking a voucher the vast
majority of these students were already
in private schools and home schools by
their choice and at no cost to taxpayers
according to the legislative budget
assistant office total taxpayer exposure
could exceed 70 million dollars just to
pay this private school tuition and home
school costs
there's an amendment to house bill 16
1684 and we discussed it last week to
accommodate students already in the
program
this bill and amendment also come to the
house floor tomorrow
attempts to table these bills will be a
clear signal to voters that
representatives want to hide from a
record of financial irresponsibility
hospital 1120 heard today
sets minimum standards for service
providers and requires criminal
background checks
house bills 1355 and 1672
require the contractor to report
suspected cases of fraud to the attorney
general for investigation
both these bills protects taxpayers and
students from abuse
hospital 1376 makes it clear that under
federal law a student within with an iep
waives their right to a free and
appropriate public education
the bill doesn't change anybody's rights
it just makes it clear to parents what
they're signing up for
house bill 1669 eliminates the third
party contractor and puts the department
of education in charge to administer the
program
this would increase the value to
students by 10 percent
current law requires students come from
household households under 300 of the
federal poverty line
but but only uh to qualify for that in
the first year
every year thereafter no income
qualification would be necessary
senate bill 237
requires annual income verification to
participate in the program
and that's not a big lift since families
already have to provide their tax
returns to the program administrator
every year
so if we're not going to approve these
bills
that protect taxpayers and students
and provide some degree of fiscal
responsibility accountability and
transparency then we have no choice but
to repeal the voucher program
and that's what this bill house bill
1683 does i'm happy to take questions
thank you very much are there any
questions of representative
representative cordelli
thank you thank you representative luna
all as well
um
are you familiar
with the fact that there are differences
between voucher programs and education
savings accounts programs and that this
is an education savings account program
so i'm i'm i'm certainly uh familiar
with um with voucher programs and
education savings account programs and
the education freedom account program as
it's defined in in our statutes
um the fact of the matter is
representative cordelli is that um is
that our constituents don't want to
argue the difference on it they want to
argue they want to learn about what the
program is and not be told that it's
something that it isn't most granite
staters are familiar with voucher
programs
that have been enacted in other states
and you're right this one is quite a bit
different but i think in the eyes of a
lot of taxpayers those differences don't
make the program
more exciting more enticing more
valuable but in fact take it the other
way so calling it a voucher doesn't um
doesn't change that fact follow-up
question
thank you um
you mentioned the uh
um in the legislation to go to the
scholarship organization or uh to
whatever organization has the contracts
um for administration of 10
are you aware that uh
per the
reports that are sent to the department
of education from the districts that
school administration costs are also ten
percent yeah i'm aware i'm aware of that
thank you very much for the question
representative um and so in the case
where a um or a voucher is being used to
to pay private school tuition that
private school tuition covers the
administrative costs of the private
school so now we're essentially doubling
the the administrative costs associated
with the adequacy dollars that are
limited and come from the state and
we've just made our adequacy dollars
that much less efficient
further questions representative moffatt
thank you miss you thank you taking my
question
uh you mentioned a couple times that
the efa program
um
uses taxpayer money to pay for someone
else's education you said that at least
a couple of times but my question refers
to
like don't almost all new hampshire
families pay property taxes directly
indirectly through
rent or from their own properties and so
if that's the case wouldn't these
families have already
put money into swept statewide education
property tax so thank you very much for
the question
what i said was to pay for somebody
else's private schooling
tuition and home education costs so i
didn't just say pay for somebody else's
education because all of our tax dollars
do pay for public education we have a
constitutional requirement in new
hampshire to provide a constitutionally
adequate education to all new
hampshire's children and the state of
new hampshire has decided to do that
through school districts if the state
the state can certainly do other other
things too but our obligation to pay for
other people's education is through
public s through our school districts
for the constitutional requirement that
we have
further questions
i'm just following up with what you just
said didn't you say
if the state decides to have other
means of
providing that education we can and
didn't we when we passed efas so now why
are those students not supposed to be
provided for an education if that was a
way we decided to adequately
give an opportunity for f for education
so thank you very much for the for the
question representative lucas the um the
state can provide alternatives if it
want and it can pay for them or not if
it wants but it doesn't have that choice
when it comes to school districts
because the state provides its
i'm sorry because the state
um
uh performs its constitutional
obligation for a constitutionally
adequate education through the school
districts that are set up across the
state
further questions
yes represent litchfield
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
did you know by folks using the efa
accounts that they are not taking any
money away from public schools because
if the child does not attend the public
school the state adequacy money does not
go to the public school anyway
no thank you very much for the question
i'm really familiar with with how school
funding works
in um in new hampshire and uh that is
absolutely true for approximately the 17
of students who are enrolled in in the
voucher program but for the vast
majority of of um
of of students in the program they they
did not end they did not exit their
public school directly to uh to uh to
enter the uh the efas so this is
entirely new money on the part of the
state and the
the 8 million or 8.1 million
over budget
is is money that that the state was not
spending on its public schools for these
students
further questions
representative nelson thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
seems like earlier today there was
concern about students getting a very
good education and some were not if a
parent felt that this was the way to go
with these accounts
for their child to get a better
education why would we deny them that
right
so um so first of all they
parents have always had the right to um
to to take their child out of public
school and put them into alternative
educational environments
our statutes reflect that when looking
at the um i forget the particular
statute but that that you know students
are supposed to be in school from i
think age six to age eighteen
uh
and um and and and uh you can you can
meet that qualification by going to your
public school or going to a private
school or being homeschooled and i think
there's a few other alternatives uh in
there in there as well
so so that right has has already uh been
in existence i think where the question
is do taxpayers have the responsibility
to pay for those that public school
tuition and for these homeschooling
costs when taxpayers are already
providing
a constitutionally adequate education
through school districts across the
state so that's a question for taxpayers
it's a policy question for the state the
state has an obligation to fund its um
to fund its school districts uh it does
not have an obligation to fund these
these private accounts
further questions represent lakas
yeah i keep hearing that argument
parents already have a right to take
their kids out of the public schools
but what about the parents who don't
have the means to take their kids out of
the public schools if the public school
is not providing an adequate education
for a student
should a stu should the state since
they're not providing an adequate
education should they not
provide those means
and much smaller means
for the parent to still be able to
provide an education for their students
should only the rich be able to get a
good education you're always talking
about helping those poorer students
that's
you you want to completely revamp the
way school is funded to get take care of
those poorest students well here's a way
to take care of the poorer students
why are you so against this
so so i've laid out a number of very
specific reasons to
um behind
the rationale to repeal this program um
uh you know uh particularly financial
the financial irresponsibility of the
current program the lack of safeguards
for to protect students i've i've laid
all of all of these things out
um
the
not taking away anybody's right to
anything everybody has a right to attend
their um their public school
through their through their local school
districts
and and that's how new hampshire
provides a constitutionally adequate
education we heard from the commissioner
this morning in his opinion that new
hampshire is providing beyond more than
a constitutionally adequate education so
um
so but but i think your question is um
is is is very important because if in
fact new hampshire is failing to provide
a constitutionally adequate education
then then it does set up new hampshire
it sets up the question of what's new
hampshire going to do about it
further questions representative
cordelli thank you in terms of what is
new hampshire going to do about it
what is new hampshire going to do about
it if
um a child in a public school is not
having their educational needs met
shouldn't there be alternatives for the
parent in those cases and
especially if those parents are not
wealthy and cannot afford on their own
to send their child to a to a private
school
so um
that's uh that that's a
an important question i mean every every
public school
every school district i should say has a
locally elected school board
parents can can meet with their school
board members
as i met with school board members when
i was on a uh on a on a school board and
try to
um
learn about what the uh what the parents
concerns are and uh and take those
concerns to the administration for um uh
for resolution
and uh and i think that's the way that's
that's addressed given that new
hampshire provides its constitutionally
adequate
education through school districts
further questions
representative tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um do you feel that taxpayers have a
right to
the
accountability some accountability
for the academic
the academic achievement or academic
services that are offered in in the efa
program the the voucher program and also
accountability for how the money's spent
so thank you very very much for the
question representative tanner um given
the fact that that um
that the money that's in the efa program
or the voucher program uh began with
with taxpayer money then then i do think
taxpayers have a vested interest in
knowing how their money is being spent
how it's being used and what the results
are from that use they do have that
information when it comes to school
districts and all that information is
available
through
through information that's collected by
the department and uh and student
performance data that's um that's
available so
so it is available through
for public for public schools it uh it
certainly should be available for
anything else that's funded by taxpayer
dollars
representative luna you and i have had
this discussion many times so i ask you
this question again
um
you just responded that the taxpayers in
the community should have accountability
for
the results are for an efa program do
taxpayers also have the right for
accountability where we're having an
average math score in the state a
proficiency of 38 percent
oh absolutely i think
i think accountability is taxpayer
accountability is is absolutely uh a
critical item um for for for anything
that's that's
uh
funded through taxpayer dollars now
where you there's there's certainly a
lot of different measures as far as
student performance um is concerned
and um
and and you know the uh
whether it's proficiency on on tests or
sat scores or other factors too like
graduation and attendance rates those
are all important uh considerations too
student outcomes um how successful are
students in their post-secondary
work whether that's
you know
going into the workforce an
apprenticeship
post-secondary higher education or the
military how successful are our students
um uh
after they uh after they leave their the
k-12 world absolutely thank you
uh further questions represent uh
woodcock then representative cordelli
thank you chairman
thank you for
taking my question well these hope thank
you for taking my question um
i've heard here today in prior dialogues
that the
efas the vouchers the esa's whatever
term you want to use for that money
is helping the poor kids and why
shouldn't they have the same opportunity
as the wealthy families
so my question is would you characterize
the other 170 000 students that are in
public school coming from wealthy
families
coming from what wealthy families oh
sorry um
no i i would not characterize the um the
the 160 000 ish students that that
currently attend public schools as uh as
as you know
coming from coming from wealthy families
i think some probably do i think it's
probably all over all over the map
and
what what i'm what i'm really you know
what i feel good about in new hampshire
is that in general our public schools
are are very good but as we heard this
morning it's just not happening
everywhere and the public schools that
have the
the greatest challenges
where the average students are
performing
in the in the lower uh quartile tend to
be public schools that are serving a
a less affluent
population
and and this is where i think the state
can
can do a lot more to try to improve
those those outcomes by directing its
limited resources to where they're
needed most thank you thank you chairman
you're welcome uh representative
cordelli thank you
on accountability uh in most industries
with automobile dealerships grocery
stores clothing stores
you're really talking about customer
accountability if
the store is not meeting the customer's
needs they're going to go to another
store
isn't it really similar with education
in that um
there's there should be
the highest form of accountability is
customer accountability also maybe known
as parent accountability and in a
program like this if
the education option that the parent is
choosing with their efa funds
is not satisfied
with the education the child is getting
they can take their money and go to a
different education option
parent accountability wouldn't you say
that is the best form of accountability
so i think parents have had that option
for a long time to take their money and
use it for a private school or use it
for home school
or or you know any of the things that
that fall into the list of alternatives
that uh that we have laid out in our in
our statute statute uh i think parents
have always had that ability i think
what uh what what what they have right
now which i think is beyond what uh what
what most taxpayers expect is for is for
us as taxpayers to have to pay not only
for public school districts for
constitutionally adequate education but
also some additional overlay
to uh to provide other forms of
of education i think that's that's
asking more than what taxpayers are
aren't necessarily signed up for
thank you further questions from the
committee
represent like us
so would you say then that taxpayers are
only planning on educating the people in
their town who go to the public school
and they have no desire whatsoever to
educate any child who can't get an
education there and go someplace else i
mean
i pay taxes i've paid taxes for
38 years in my town i have not had my
kids go to that school for 38 years and
i think most taxpayers would say that
and isn't the idea to tax to
get an education or provide an education
for the students in the town which would
include not just those who can go to the
public school but those for whom the
public school doesn't work so one of the
reasons new hampshire has such a good
has such good public schools and school
districts is because school districts
budge school district budgets go to the
voter
at every year at annual school district
meetings in most places i know
manchester and the cities are a little
bit different and i get that
but
but but
most school districts most voters have a
real high expectation in terms of
student performance and want to make
sure they're providing the best public
education that they can that they can
afford we see that all over the state we
see it in affluent communities
with with very high property valuations
and they might be lucky enough to have
you know an ocean or lake
in their community and then we see it in
communities that don't have high
property valuations and struggle work
really hard to raise the money to try to
do as best they can for their students
so absolutely
voters across the state almost uniformly
want to want to want to have strong
public schools
and
and being on a school board i certainly
you know think of of public education
as anything but
one size fits all
it's a it's a it's a type of education
that has to be everything for everybody
because you've got so much diverse and
unique needs
and diverse student characteristics
um uh that uh that that it's a it's an
unbelievably
uh
important and and challenging
um
obligation on the part of public schools
to be able to be able to do that but i
think we're very fortunate here in new
hampshire to have the support of
taxpayers of voters
uh to uh to do absolutely the best we
can and i think we've got an opportunity
over the next few years
to uh to make sure that
that
that that we can we can you know
you know tilt the bar
so that uh so that
students all across the state no matter
where they live no matter what their zip
code is
can uh can have a strong opportunity for
a good outcome
thank you for answering my questions
thank you very much are there further
questions representing tanner
thank you um
do you think that taxpayers also are
willing to pay money for
public education because of the consumer
protections and the safety nets
that our community public schools offer
students in our area
thank you for the question i think
that's that's
that that's
i i would say that that's just a given
that's expected and uh and that there's
certainly an accountability aspect to
that but it's absolutely a consumer
protection aspect that i know when when
a public school hires teachers that
these teachers are have been licensed
through the uh through the state board
of education i know that when the school
district hires a contractor um that that
they've undergone criminal background
checks that that i know that when i send
my child to a public school in the
morning it's um it's on a school bus
that that meets specific requirements
for uh for public safety and when they
walk into the school building they're
not walking into a place that's going to
have the roof collapse on their heads
but it's something that's been inspected
by the local building inspector on an
annual basis and then also every year by
the joint loss
committee
in new hampshire to to make sure those
buildings are safe so absolutely i think
that's expected
okay i'm going to call it quits on this
one right here
uh it's been 30 minutes with
representative taking questions and
uh we have all these to go through here
no and i thank i thank you mr chair and
i thank the members of the committee for
all the very thoughtful uh questions
that's this is an important issue
obviously we went beyond i think um um
uh
the the efa program but uh but this is
this is the stuff we're here to talk
about so thank you very much thank you
very much
um we'll call forward representative tim
horrigan
this morning earlier we were looking at
the content of an adequate education and
looking at those learning domains and i
think after looking the cards one of the
areas i'm going to put back in is
cursive writing
and and manuscript uh penmanship
for some of you
and uh
it's a real battle up here trying to
figure out
welcome representative welcome can you
hear me so i'm represent timothy
horrigan from stratford county district
six that's the towns of durham and
madbury it's
two-thirds of the oyster river
cooperative school district and i'm a
proud former student of that cooperative
school district i think they're
back in retrospect i went to several
different types of school a non-secular
private school they religiously
connected
private school
and the conventional public school and
also one year for a
state school in uh in britain when my
dad was a
visiting professor in england but anyway
i think the uh
the education i got in the conventional
public school we like to dump on them
but it was probably of all those
institutions that was probably where i
learned the most in the oyster river
cooperative school district so that's uh
and um
so i remember my dad
my late father who is a professor of
accounting at unh and he certainly would
object to calling
those voucher programs educational
savings accounts because they're
absolutely
not savings accounts at all um
i remember the voucher bill
that regina luna talked about i vaguely
remember that from when he was a uh
he was a rep so this issue that's been
bounced around for a long time and i see
there's
a number of children are taking the day
off from school to at least the
afternoon off to watch proceedings um
i was 17 when my dad was first in
legislature our next door neighbor we
were very close to was my father's
predecessor and my father took us down
to see representative
leon crouch in action a few times so it
was a valuable learning experience i'm
glad to hear maybe some of those
children will someday be members of this
body so
that said um
that said i think you don't have to look
i think just pronounce your fiasco you
don't really have to look much farther
than the children's scholarship funds
new hampshire's website to see why it's
a fiasco and i i'm not
don't want to impugn their integrity
they're an honorable group of people
they do a pretty good job of registering
the rsa 77g program but
they're a small and obscure politically
well-connected organization they were
awarded a no-bid contract being charged
with a very ill-conceived and poorly
designed entitlement program which uh
and of course uh
you probably all remember how uh state
commissioner frank edelblut predicted
not long ago about 28 children would
take advantage of the efa program this
school year
the cfs h's website states and i
absolutely believe them that eight
1856 children are currently enrolled in
the program so
the commissioners
estimate was off by a factor of 60. so
this program is programmed six thousand
percent over budget so that's pretty
alarming right there the uh
the doe has very limited uh oversight
over this aside from some rather
rudimentary rules over csf nh
cfa nh um
i mean there's good people running the
organization but uh they just get a
fixed percentage of taxpayer money to
spend so they really have no incentive
to you know reign in the costs of this
program and they also have
really no incentive to ride her too hard
on either families or educational
providers
i mean there are some rules the
educational providers there are some
things you can't
in fact it's um i guess anytime you make
rules like that whereas a government
non-government organization sometimes
what's in and what's out is kind of
funny like we have
school uniforms can be bought with efa
funds but not
sports teams uniforms and you can't buy
any type of shoes even though i think
every school that has a school uniform
has some rules about what shoes you can
wear with it so there's a lot of
um
i mean that's probably true if any
program is arbitrary but there isn't a
whole lot of outside uh oversight over
this organization so we're pretty much
at their mercy and
but a bigger problem is um separation of
church and state is mandated by both the
new hampshire united states constitution
our constitution and their statute law
to go with it
very specifically bans taxpayer funding
of religious schools and that's a i know
we've debated that issue in the house
because i was
testifying against a hearing uh trying
to eliminate that but
um part
and part 83 parts article 83 part second
of the state constitution states in part
very clearly
no money raised by taxation shall ever
be granted or applied for the use of the
schools
or institutions of any religious sector
denominations that's a pretty that's
pretty unambiguous language it's been
there since the 19th century
and with csf on the other hand and
they're very specifically quite openly
devoted to make no bones about it
they're
devoted to promoting religious education
you need to look no forward than other
glossy reports always have pictures of
parochial school students on and we need
to look for it in the home page where
they're very large very lovely portrait
very adorable very beautiful uh
sisters they
appear to be aged about
so they seem to be aged about eight
years old nine years old plus or minus a
couple of years um
they're students at a manchester
parochial school they're wearing school
uniforms those could quite i say very
likely in my written testimony but they
could conceivably been purchased
with efa dollars
and of course as you all know uh regular
public school students their families
have to buy all their own clothes so
like the state doesn't buy them any
outfits
and then these pictures also come with
video the girls parents their older
sisters and a local multi-millionaire
all expand upon the awesomeness of
private schools and the horribleness of
public schools
so i'm not a lawyer or a constitutional
scholar and you know and i don't blame
cfs senate for doing what it is i think
they're acting in good faith they're
taking advantage of the opportunities we
gave them but
cfna csf and his activities have never
been seriously challenged the state of
federal court but it's unclear to me how
they can do what they do without
violating article 83 part second of the
state constitution because they're very
clearly collecting taxpayer money and
distributing it like pretty directly to
parochial schools i know it's not just
religious schools but that's like a
major focus of their mission so
anyway there's a lot of other things i
can say about the uh what's wrong with
the efa program but i just i think it's
wasteful it's unconstitutional it's
poorly conceived
so the first step in
putting an end to this
wasteful program is by passing hp 1683.
so i urge you to find it ought to pass
and
um
one thing you might mention i was just
looking uh at the eligibility guidelines
by the way the 300 percent of
federal poverty you're not rich but
you're you can be doing pretty well and
still meet especially if you have many
children like i think even
my family back in the 1960s that this
program existed back then i'm pretty
sure
just trying to remember what i remember
my dad telling me to multiply by
donation i'm pretty sure at least when
my father came here as a
uh
young
young associate professor
first he's a young assistant professor
at uh what was in the whitmore school i
think
i think my two sisters and i would have
been eligible for this program and we um
you know we were
our family was much more fortunate than
most we were blessed with a lot of good
fortune and we did pretty well without
uh
any efa or voucher whatever you call it
so it's a fairly
generous program the family the video
had
five children they had a
family of seven they could have uh made
up to i think
something like a hundred and twenty
three thousand dollars so they could
have made you know that didn't come to
tie above what most working families
make so um
so it's it's not just rich so you know
it's a you can be actually doing pretty
well for yourself and still be eligible
for this program so
if you have to take any questions
thank you are there any questions of the
representative
okay yes represent litchfield
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um first i just want to say wouldn't you
agree that due to this program's
popularity initially that parents really
are hungry for this and there is a need
and i also like to ask
do you feel that possibly parents are
being forced to leave public schools at
this point in time maybe they're feeling
as though they're not being heard by
their school boards due to possibly
forced masking
fear of cobalt vaccine mandates
and being labeled nationally as domestic
terrorists well um
i'm not i don't just i'm not sure who's
being labeled domestic terrorists
although we do have we do have
terrorists here in the united states um
that
the
of course there's also no protections
program you know efa funds can go to
organizations that forbid mess and the
the
cause of it i think it's mostly uh
it seems to be mostly taken advantage of
by families who already would have found
another way to go to a private school
instead of their public school that's
that's what the data i've seen suggest
and i i don't buy that
public schools are unresponsive the uh
so when i was attending the oyster river
uh
schools um of course my mom and dad were
both big you know
very persistent and it could be a big
pain in the well i don't want to say
that here but the big pain and you know
what um but i
i don't recall that the uh i don't
recall my school and that was a long
time ago being unresponsive to parents
needs and i don't
think they're unresponsive now as for
the masking um you know that's a
controversial thing but
it's a
you know it's a safety precaution that's
just being imposed because we have a
pandemic which presumably will
settle down eventually i don't think
it's done so yet and uh
and as
for school boards you know they don't
really provide the education it's the uh
teachers and so a good school board
should probably go unnoticed they should
should be just doing their job without
doing anything that attracts attention
so it's not really
in fact probably if you have a specific
complaint about your child that's
probably not necessarily the first
person you want to talk to is your
school board members you probably want
to
talk to your teacher and your administ
and the principal your school and so
forth and i certainly uh don't feel i
know that the
superintendent and the principals in the
oyster river schools are very responsive
to the families like sir thank you very
much representative are there further
questions
maxine thank you very much all right
thank you uh kate baker the mayors
hi everybody i'm kate baker demers i'm
the executive director of children's
scholarship fund and we have quite a few
families in the education freedom
account program
that are homeschooling now medically
fragile child children and so i'd like
to read a testimony from a parent who
couldn't be here today
she says i'm disheartened to see the
efforts of some of our new hampshire
leaders to eliminate the beneficial
education freedom account program i'm a
licensed teacher in the state of new
hampshire and after having children of
my own decided it was in their best
interest to have an alternative
education path
just as adults have a variety of skill
sets that lend themselves to various
careers so children have different
learning styles
parents know their children best and
therefore should be able to educate them
in the environment that's most conducive
to their individual learning styles
the dollars allocated for a child's
education should therefore be able to
follow each individual student so they
have the best opportunities to learn in
the most effective manner
each of our children have been able to
more fully reach their potential by
having the resources made available to
them that were intended for them in the
first place but never accessible until
the education freedom account was
established
it's common sense to allow education tax
dollars to follow a student that they
were meant for rather than being
educated allocated only to a building
removing the efa program will not only
negatively impact the participating
families but also the children that
would join the program in the future
children thrive with consistency and
bouncing them around by removing the
funds that are meant for their schooling
creates gaps in their learning that's
both disruptive and detrimental to their
overall education
it's a parent's right and responsibility
to choose an education that best meets
their child's needs education funding in
new hampshire should align with that
fact education freedom accounts should
be the standard not just this year or
next but as long as we are the live free
or die state
a vote to end the education freedom
account is a vote against the children
of this state they are our future and
deserve a learning environment in which
they thrive
her name is karen dyer she's from alton
new hampshire
so you may have thought that while you
were looking at this bill
you were just looking at words on a page
or that you were just crossing off a
line here some of the bills you've been
looking at maybe adding a tweak or you
thought you're adding maybe a guard rail
or eliminating a choice of what
standardized test a parent might take or
adding a little bit of paperwork or
maybe you're just enabling the
scholarship organization or perhaps you
were just thinking that one of these
bills just excluded some education
providers
and what i'd just like to share with you
today is that when you do this
when you change lines in a law
change words add paragraphs cross off
paragraphs in the education freedom
account law you are in fact making it
inaccessible bureaucratic eliminating
education options or frankly adding a
paragraph that eliminates the program
when you cross out these lines or words
in the education freedom account law you
are in fact crossing out real children
real children in need possibly even the
tutor that helps them with dyslexia
i haven't been asked yet
by anyone if there are any changes that
we need at children's scholarship fund
to run the program well
the answer i would give you today is
none
we will absolutely let you know when we
do need something
we are especially against working with
the urgency of emts to get the program
up and running in the fall
and then by winter throwing out every
participating child into the cold
thank you very much kate any questions
yes representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you ms
baker for taking my question hard to see
you yeah i know
it's okay if i lean right and you lean
left
[Laughter]
background checks yeah sure uh you just
said that you don't feel that you need
to change anything mix it up improve
anything so
the providers have applicable laws that
they have to abide by
in terms of background checks and there
is some work in the rules process right
now about that
and we'll implement whatever the
existing laws or rules are i just don't
think any changes need to be made at
this time
could i follow up with yesterday
um i hear you yeah and i've looked at
those rules background checks seems to
be my thing yeah i know and totally get
it
so um
would would you would it be fair to say
that it's a good idea if somebody is
going to be instructing a child
particularly alone
that they have a criminal background
check before they work with that child i
mean my understanding is the people are
doing that already
which
which people for example all the private
schools in new hampshire are conducting
background checks right music teachers
at music schools i mean in my experience
when i volunteered in a school i get a
background check and so it is my
understanding that most people are doing
that anyway although again i'm not up to
speed on what you're what you're
referring to okay so yeah
asking them we're asking them to comply
with the existing laws that pertain to
them so my
my um yeah my response to that would be
that if they're already doing it great
because it's not going to be an issue
for them or anybody else if they're
already doing it but i'm concerned and
i'm interested my question to you
because that's going to make me ask one
is
what what is your [__] mic and see
you at the same time that's okay what is
your response to uh what's your response
to
individual service providers that don't
belong to any
private school or i'm
the i'm concerned about the vetting yes
so you're talking about like a two like
a music teacher like you're a piano
teacher and you teach piano i mean as a
parent if i'm signing my child up in a
place like that i'm asking them to do
that and i'm also checking the sex
offender registry and we are doing that
type of due diligence on our own when
we're on boarding providers we're
checking the existing databases that are
available to be sure that someone
doesn't show up on those registries and
so
that's my answer to your question yeah
yeah thank you very much uh further
questions
i like the good questions so i'm happy
you've got me here for a minute
everybody all questions are good
questions okay uh thank you
not that your question wasn't that's a
good question too i mean i mean deep
questions is what i like no you don't
have time for this well chairman ladd
representative
you have a question
yes can you give us an idea of the
percent of kids
who are taking advantage of the efa
program
who are special needs
and in particular
well i guess it's two questions the
other is those who
were at some point in the public school
before
um leaving sure yeah you guys have spent
a lot of time on that in here and so
the data from the department of ed that
we all crunched together
is the number of 280 that you've been
using is correct if you're looking at
the switchers from november when the
program started right the kids that
moved this year usually when you ask me
about switchers in our program you're
talking about kids from the prior year
okay when we count them in the tax
credit program we're usually looking at
the prior year so you've got your 280
from this year and then you've got 220
from the prior year
and then i think of it in terms of all
the families that drove this into
existence right so there was that period
of time when the schools were closed
when families needed these resources and
they drove this program into existence
and so to me those switchers the
switchers in the pandemic and right
before that
shutdowns happened or the families that
drove this program and so if you if you
want to look at the data from any kid
that ever stepped foot into a public
school in the entire existence there's a
lot of them but if you want to talk
about how many kids moved right now
representative luna's been telling you
right to 280 from just this fall we
didn't start the program until november
and so you wouldn't expect very many
kids to switch right now in the middle
of a school year
did that help oh and you asked me about
special needs kids
so our average of special needs kids in
our program over the course of it ranges
between like 10 and 20 percent
in this little education freedom account
group
it's five percent but remember that
we're not qualifying kids for special
education we're qualifying them for the
differentiated aid piece and they have
to provide a special documentation for
that so there might be a family in the
program who has a child with special
needs who's using the program to meet
those child special needs but they
haven't given us the documentation to
get the differentiated aid right so
we're qualifying the kids for
differentiated aid not special ed
services so what we have is five percent
of the kids are qualified for that
differentiated aid based on the
documentation they gave us that doesn't
necessarily mean that they
you know there aren't more children that
have special needs in the program
a lot of the providers you'll i don't
know if you've looked at the list but a
lot of the providers are people who are
doing special ed services
and i'm seeing a lot of that thank you i
love these questions anyone else why you
have me on the hot seat great i'm sorry
thank you mr chair uh generally speaking
are the um
students uh happy with the program who
are in it
i mean yes we've been a little bit slow
in approving expenses because for each
transaction that goes through the
digital wallet my team asked themselves
a series of like seven qualifying
questions and we're also googling all of
the items that are in there to make sure
that they are at an educational expense
in addition matching them with the
appropriate grade level and the core
knowledge subject which you talked about
earlier so i wish we could be a little
bit faster for the families i get a lot
of messages saying it's taking you too
long to approve my orders takes about
two weeks to get through the queue of
orders that's sitting there i wish we
were a little bit faster
it's also a little bit slow when we give
the department of education our list it
takes a full 30 days after that for them
to run their cross checks on the sassage
the unique people identifiers which you
guys have talked about in here and then
to say to us yes this child is qualified
in the program i wish that was a little
bit faster also but i appreciate the
steps that we're taking that are
the as you've been talking about in here
accountability and transparency right
the fact that the doe is cross-checking
the sacids is a really important piece
and they'll say okay we've got an
anomaly here or a district will write to
me we've got an anomaly here where the
kid is enrolled in our district and in
your program and then we've got to find
out you know does the child not belong
or did they mean to transfer and and so
that's a little bit of a slow process
but i think all of those pieces are
doing exactly what it was designed to do
he's gonna he's gonna send him off he's
gonna kill us are you done with the
questioning representative
representative thank you i know we want
to keep moving but representative saudi
inspired me uh
in terms of this is new yeah and in
terms of self-assessment quality control
evaluations uh could you speak to
what is in place or what will be in
place in terms of
people
evaluating the experience from from
different perspectives and also would
these evaluations be public yeah so we
do survey our existing families and have
every year and we were publishing on the
website when people were interested in
that and so we're glad to continue to do
that but we want to survey the families
because we want to know from their
perspective one
how are we doing right how can we
improve what what do they want to see
that's not a part there's been some
things that people have hoped would be
allowable that are not allowable and so
i think we can collect that feedback you
know some of the questions i like to
know is why are you here right why did
you choose this program was there
something that in your experience that
made you come to us right for example
how else would i know that so many
children come to us because they
experience bullying or discrimination or
so many kids come to us because they
were below grade level and want a
smaller class size right that's how we
find out all that information and so we
survey the families every year we do it
towards the end of the year right so we
get some good feedback from the
experience they had and then we could
publish it i mean like our annual report
on the website
okay thank you that's my question
if the anonymous evaluation is good or
bad sure people can look at it sure yeah
i'll give people your number too if they
want to complain about me i'm just
teasing i'm just cheating
thank you
i'll give them glenn's number actually
uh when a a child or a family uh apply
for an essay
is there a component or element within
that application that answers the
question that you you just indicated you
wish you could get saying why i'm coming
after an efa
there isn't a question asking why
they're there there's a question asking
what they want to do with the money yeah
you know and we ask them why they're
there after they're in
to that bill you talked about at one
point right if you asked them the
question and required it when they
entered they might not be as as truthful
as when they're there right after if
you've decided you might apply for
something and then not decide not to
take it for example so i had did have a
family who applied for the education
freedom account got it i talked to the
dad on the phone and said
oh you know you have a 15 year old
sophomore like is she struggling i said
is she struggling you know are you sure
you want to transfer and he decided to
stay at the school where she was instead
of choose the education freedom account
we don't need to survey him at that
point when he's like should i do
something i'm exploring you survey him
after he says okay he didn't he they
stayed in their public school they
decided to stay there
once they move to the program then it
makes sense to say to them why are you
here
right so that's where we survey them so
why are you here when you're there
once you've made the leap
thank you kate eddie yes represent
hobson
thank you mr chair and uh thank you for
your testimony today i was wondering um
i'm very interested in the in
a report that shows you know what what
data you're collecting and i was
wondering if by any chance you could
elaborate on what types of expenses you
might see the most of sure so right now
we're seeing the most of private school
tuition
and then tutoring after that and then
computers and books predominantly but
that's also data that we can bring at
the end of the year to look at i know
i'm expected to bring that to the
oversight committee and so that might be
a good time for everyone to just come to
the oversight committee and discuss
you know the those pieces what i like
about this program is that we can track
down to the pencil what everyone did
with this money and then look at it and
see is it doing what we wanted it to do
right is it meeting the goals
from when you put this program into
place and is there anything that we
would change or do differently and so
it's it's been a lot of tutoring a lot
of special ed services a lot of tuition
a lot of books
a lot of laptops people did not have
access to laptops or technology or ipads
like you might think they do right
because it's easy for us to get one you
think everybody has one people do not
have access to and you want to do online
classes so many home schoolers want to
do online classes and never had access
to the appropriate technology to be able
to do that they did put in the rules
just so you know the cap of one every
three years and so i think that was a
reasonable way to meet the need but also
make it so that it's not over the top
thank you um
okay fine love it
thanks kate lorraine lindenberg
she'll be back
deborah house
she's not here
either oh okay
okay this is still on yep
good afternoon i'm deborah house from
the american federation of teachers
represent 3 500 members across the state
where you still can okay i need to lean
forward thank you for letting me know
uh
deborah house from the american
federation of teachers i represent 3 500
members across the state where teachers
para educators school support staff
public employees
and i'm here today to speak in support
of this bill
i will try not to repeat too much of
what has been said already
the representative has gone over the
legislative history of this bill uh very
thoroughly so i will
dive right in
the money that is being spent on this is
going to help a very small number of
students
the only firm number we've been able to
get is from the department of ed's
report from november when the program
started when there were 1635 students
enrolled in the voucher program
of those 280 are ones who have just
recently left public schools
so most of the money that uh taxpayer
money that's being spent on this
is subsidies for families who are
already finding other ways to meet their
students
educational needs
and
i listen very carefully when the
senate bill that was very similar to
this was heard the other week because
i wanted to think
very carefully about what to say
um
and i heard the
and passion please to continue this
program because i am very mindful of how
students are enrolled in programs and
how they want to continue it's all about
the educational
fit and
educational fit is important it's also
very important for the hundred and sixty
thousand plus students who are in uh
public schools
all of our students deserve
small class sizes individual attention
from a teacher support from caring para
educators they deserve engaging
curriculums they deserve
lots of chances to engage in science and
technology enrichment activities
languages arts all these things that
make school
engaging and inviting a place where they
want to be a community where they want
to belong
and that's what i want to bring up here
this program was passed so quickly
without the chance to have a full
examination of the financial impact the
estimates for what it was going to cost
for way off and that eight million
dollars that it it is costing the
taxpayers
could have been spent on
200 nurses for public schools
it could have been spent on 160
classroom teachers
430 para educators who can sit with
students in small group and give them
extra help and go over the lesson their
classroom teacher have taught
and help them practice their skills it
could mean the difference between
many hundreds of students getting
individualized attention
so i'm here to speak up for those
students who are are in public schools
who could be getting a lot more
of that individualized attention that
feeling of belonging in an educational
community that fits them
if we weren't
spending money on a program
that wasn't planned for in the budget
that was rushed through that as we've
heard the rules are still being written
for this program
i want to bring a few more points to
your attention
more than 80 percent of new hampshire
families
choose to send their students to public
schools
that is where they want their students
and they are happy with their public
schools
we did
a big survey in december 2021 and it was
equally divided between republican
democrat and undeclared it was done by
heart research
and
overwhelmingly
voters in new hampshire want to see
stronger investment in public schools to
benefit all students
74 c say we need greater investment
in our public schools 72 percent want
better public schools for all instead of
vouchers for a few
and
um nearly six out of 10 are concerned
that their tax dollars are going to
increase
because of voucher programs
so
the message to us was clear we want to
see our public schools strengthened we
don't want to see
tax money
going
for
families that make what are private
education choices
for a different
solution which they're they're entirely
entitled to make
but our public money needs to stay in
strengthening our public schools for all
of our students
so they can all have that wonderful fit
not just the towns that happen to be
blessed with good property tax basis
and that's really all i want to say and
i will see myself time to the many
others who want to speak unless there
are questions thank you very much are
there any questions
yes representatives
since you brought up money
um
does it
i'm not sure how to ask this
i had it
i'm sorry um
the question is
since you brought up money
does it make more sense
if you're worried about proper care and
spending of public money and whatever to
spend twenty thousand to educate a
student or four thousand to educate a
student
the thing is that we don't parcel out
the money individually when we're
talking about the police department or
the fire department or the road
department we don't divide their budgets
by the number of taxpayers in town and
give each person an individual account
to
go build their part of the road that
they use
that's a common
good that we all use the schools work
the same way and it's an economy of
scale if you have one student leave you
don't reduce your costs
by that much
sorry i forgot to lean into the mic
okay because schools do run on an
economy of scale and you do reduce your
cost some when one student sleeps but
not necessarily enough
by the amount of money that you have
just removed from from the from the pool
so and
thank you thank you welcome
are there any more questions
thank you very much uh are there any
parents out here that have a long drive
and have children with you that you
would like to i see a hand go up i don't
know your names but would you please
come on up and let's get the kids
home get them outside
older kids count too
hey
i'm from alaska and um
cold gets down at -20 that's when you
start getting cold
hello
hi would you say your name please my
name is deborah dao i'm a micro school
in new hampshire um
under prenda which has been developed
years ago in the west coast but new
hampshire department of education has
adopted and supported
our program to educate as an alternative
schooling program for children that
choose a smaller environment
and a unique environment that suits
their needs
so my children will be sharing their
experience with their homeschooling
and their astronomical growth autonomy
and individuality that the micro school
has allowed for them personally
this is in response of the efa funding
and how we support it and how it will be
effective to us at the micro school and
as a
homeschool family
our micro school
my name is debbie i'm a former
educator in a private and a public
school i'm a music
teacher
and i also homeschool my children and
run the micro school like i said and um
i want to tell you that the academic
resources that we are receiving
supports all of my children in one way
or another the funds support material
that my children and students eagerly
apply to their academic growth and
without it i would otherwise be able to
afford
efa
allows students
to utilize the resources to spark their
interest with hands-on experiences
and to join others that have likewise
minds that they want to learn that way
the educational freedom account supports
a place like our micro school a place
where we are confident in our children's
safety during their learning a place
that sparks the interest of the child
a resource that is provided to assist in
providing materials to our youngsters
that have chosen to learn in the smaller
environment like i said
it is a place where students are not
measured in comparison to others but are
measured on how they show their personal
competencies
the efa helps support a place that they
do not need to be molded to fit in a box
a place where the test scores show only
the personal growth and not comparison
to others
our place is a place where hands-on
experiences allow for individuality
uniqueness and pride
please support the efa so programs like
mine can celebrate children in their
abilities feed their desire to learn and
support our future
efa has supported our youngest citizens
please be mindful when considering the
individuality uniqueness and of each
student's academic journey
i don't know if i answered
gave enough information to tell you who
i was but my kids have prepared
something for them to share with you
guys with their experience
thank you
are there any questions from um
were your children out of school when
you started this program or did you take
them off school
um so my children attended public school
right before this program started before
the program started i was homeschooling
thank you
thank you very much
they'll probably do better than i did
did a fine job thank you
all girls
oh wow
yeah yeah and the red light that's on
okay
we are representing um the prenda school
and we're going to show why we think
that the efa should continue supporting
us now for your names somebody's emma
this is emma emma and amelia
and
see who else we have here isla
or danica
danica's right here okay
welcome
my name is amelia dow i am 13 years old
and i am your future veterinarian
my name is
bring the mic up right close to where
you're speaking and then everybody be
able to hear
my name is amelia dao i am 13 and i am
your future veterinarian
my name is emma tinkam and i am 12 and
i'm your future neurosurgeon
my name is dana cadell i am 11 and i'm
your future dance teacher and local
baker
my name is isla catalano i am 10 years
old and i am your future teacher
we participate in a prenda pod in
meredith new hampshire aprendipod is a
one of a kind learning program that
focuses on the students academic needs
through community autonomy mindset and
purpose
we believe that a student's education
homeschooled or not should be equally
important to the priorities of funding
through the department of education
meaning that
funds towards our education should be
permitted to the students and equally
justifiable some of us can understand
why the public school staff members
might feel at a disadvantage but
students deserve to learn on their terms
we shouldn't be forced to meet
unreasonable expectations which is why
prenda lets us learn on our level
some of us learn better
put the mic right down that bends so you
can go right into it
some of us learning
some of us learning it better
better in a less chaotic environment
with less people and less pressure which
can lead to unnecessary stress
studies show
what the stress level of an average
student is 75 percent of
the us students express boredom anger
sadness fear or stress well in a
traditional school on a 10 point scale
where normal value for adults are 3.8
american students rated their stress
level at an average score of 5.8
our pranapod benefits not only us but
our fellow classmates and many others in
the state participating in a homeschool
curriculum charter schools and privately
owned systems
prenda helps students that may be behind
in their academics and encourages them
to set goals and meet them through their
own levels of learning it is not
fast-paced it is set to a reasonable
expectation without
comparisons to other students
a quick according to a classmate with
their permission they have excelled two
grades in a short time this year filling
in the gap where they want struggles
this is because of the ability
ambition and opportunity to excel on
their terms without being rushed
pressured or compared
our daily activities include a variety
of options that expose us to learning
opportunities that would not otherwise
be offered in the public school for
example i want to be a veterinarian
therefore i am able to have hands-on
experience with the farm anal animals at
my school
i am able to order with the efa funds
labs enhanced on activity kits that will
further my knowledge and understanding
of animals
this typically would not be an option if
i was in a traditional school this is
feeding my desire to learn at my pace
with the program of my choice
my example oh sorry
my experience with prenda has offered me
an opportunity to engage in activities i
would not typically be able to choose as
an option in traditional school
if efa stripped from our ability to
access the funds the federal funds may
run out and jeopardize the future of our
program it would be upsetting to many
others including myself
although prenda and homeschooling may
seem quite different from public school
in which it is we still learn just like
everybody else if we feel overwhelmed we
can take a break and come back to our
studies when our mind is ready to learn
in the morning we spend time creating
things like art music and doing
activities that spark our inner artists
and ignites our creativity
we also pay attention to important core
programming like lexia language arts
cern math and reading and writing
through a digital platform we spend a
majority of our time outdoors hiking
working with the animals climbing trees
and gardening we play we embrace the
natural beauty around us
we will learn
we learn and we work with each other as
a community through unplugged
opportunities that encourage alternative
learning environments
efa offers us a multitude of
opportunities that provide us a creative
new way to learn that promotes
individuality
community and encourages autonomy and
the ability to take control of our
academic journey with efa we know we can
have support in educational materials
and resources that will further our
learning interest with efa we will be
able to conti continue programming like
prenda for young aspiring citizens
citizens in a unique fruitful program
please support us by continuing the
educational freedom accounts so we can
learn our way with your support to
inspire us through our academic
challenges and successes we could not do
it without efa
thank you thank you
thank you both all of you thank you very
much
the whole world saw you this is being
streamed so folks outside also see
what's going on
good job
are there any other families yes
my name is amanda littlefield and this
is my son matthew littlefield over here
we have my brother richard littlefield
who is a state rep for laconia here to
support us today
i wanted to talk about matthew my son he
is a efa participant
we do homeschooling
we
technically um switched from
public school which i know you're going
to ask
but in reality he was waiting for four
months
while the school tried to find an
appropriate setting for him
matthew has ptsd and asperger's he
cannot handle himself
in a typical school setting
matthew was at school
and the behavioral specialist
and him were walking down the hallway
matthew took off into a run
at which point the behavioral specialist
grabbed him
uh with ptsd we all know we fight flight
or freeze right matthew chose to fight
at that point matthew was expelled
and his iep was pretty much useless at
that point
um they took him and had him go to mount
prospect academy on the at the the
school district paid for it
uh to which he was also kicked out of
um
he's not a typical settings uh child so
i know that this doesn't apply to all
but for matthew um
he he just couldn't do it
he would have anxiety attacks flashbacks
and things like that in the in the
school setting
um you see him here today he's calm he's
not really happy to be here
but he's handling it right
he's been quiet for the most part
um this you wouldn't get in the normal
school district in the normal school
setting because he can't handle it
it's too chaotic there's too much going
on and the second a child acts up around
him he hops on that bandwagon like gets
his job right
so
for matthew being able to be taught at
home means a lot to us
um it means that i'm not dealing with
police on a daily basis so that's great
it means he no longer has a probation
officer
and that that is quite significant for
an eleven-year-old to have
two probation officers in his lifetime
right
matthew had gone to a residential
treatment facility in allenstown called
pinehammon boy center
to which he got kicked out of
um
the efa
and the grant
is the only way that i'm able to
educate my child
the only way that anyone is able to
educate my child the school district
failed him
we talk about a
i don't know the exact words but it was
a
constitutionally approved education it
doesn't work for him
it doesn't work for me
we want to talk about a program that has
gone six thousand percent over budget
you're right
and it's because there is such a need
in the community there is such a need
for these children who cannot be taught
in a public school setting to be able to
go out there and have their education
without that all of these children i
mean what are we going to do with them
where are we going to put them
for children who cannot learn in a
public school setting with a bunch of
other children
what do we do with them how do we
educate them if not for the efa
so i want to say i'm thankful that this
program is here and i hope that after
today it's still there
and you know we really appreciate it
thank you very much
are there any questions
thank you very much for coming today
okay any other
families here
come on forward
you're welcome to use the wipes if you
want to or in between or
they're they're available to you
please say your name so we can make sure
we get your card out
my name is taylor garrison and this is
my sister alexis and this is delaney
and we can bring the mic down a little
bit
that's it talk right into it
and us three people um we all go to
laconia christian academy
in public school i was bullied from
third to sixth grade my parents have
legal guardian of
me and my two sisters because of trauma
in our lives
at the beginning of the school year we
went to public school and after about
two weeks we ended up
leaving
there
we went to the coney christian academy
this school is way better
than i've ever experienced for the time
my sisters and i have been here we have
never been bullied the teachers and
students would never let that happen
after about two days
i was friends with almost everyone in my
class
in public school there were 30 minute
class classes of you sitting doing
nothing and
then expected to do homework
at laconia christian we have one hour
classes and we are being taught
everything we need to know
when i was online during covid
i was very behind in every class and we
weren't being taught anything
i ended up going to summer school for
two weeks last summer and i learned more
there than i've learned online at
laconia question i've learned more
there than i've ever learned right now i
have all a's and b's in every class and
i could barely get to an a in any class
in public school
my youngest sister delaney could barely
even say her abcs and now she's really
good at saying them
if it weren't for the education freedom
accounts
my sisters and i would never have the
education opportunity we have now
please don't know on this bill
thank you very much how old is delaney
seven
wow
congratulations thank you very much any
questions for folks
thank you very much
should i speak now sure go ahead
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to be here today um my name is randall
kelly
these young ladies happen to be i've
been blessed with that pardon me it's
tough for me not to be choked up after
that right there i'm
i'm so proud of these young ladies i
can't even tell you
um
if you could see where we were six
months ago
to where we are
today um as taylor mentioned
delaney could not even
say her abcs
didn't even know them clueless couldn't
even barely count to ten
that young lady can sing them now
she's using words that would make some
adults
blush
and not because they are
you got my point
folks i can't express i i've actually
i've quit working and i'm playing
full-time dad with these three young
ladies so you can understand the
financial burden that that has brought
to our picture
god has blessed us and blessed us with
the opportunity to make good for these
young ladies
i just hope that you keep that in place
because i see a great future for every
one of them
and i hate to see that taken away
because without this
i don't know that we can make that
happen
thank you for your time
thank you
any questions
you're off the hook
any other families out here that have to
hit the road or
get home
my name is michael from deering
new hampshire is my
one of five kids judah he uh came out
here with me today he's very excited to
be here right jude
he really wants to go home
um you know i was really glad that the
the statistic that said six thousand
percent over budget and just repeat that
you know just to see the amount of
interest um you know i think it might be
a testament just to make us think that
what kind of product is the public
school giving us
you know i think too the kids that come
from a home school or private school
environment into the into this program
shouldn't be penalized for trying to
escape a subpar product in the public
schools
new hampshire in 2020 had a six point
went to home the families at home school
was six six point three percent uh in
new hampshire and you know i find it
interesting in massachusetts where i
personally do a lot of my work
the the percentage of my students of
homeschooled kids is 12.1 percent
uh it actually went up 800 fold 800
increase
so if it's happening in massachusetts uh
you know you can imagine it's uh
happening here in new hampshire and all
over new england um and and parents are
looking for an alternative to the public
school
um and i think the the difference of
educating a child for four thousand
dollars as opposed to twenty thousand
dollars is a big deal and it actually
can be done for for much less than that
um as well in a in a private school
environment i have a 16 year old son
that's a bona fide professional
carpenter uh and i can really direct his
education at a very efficient rate um
and he's going to be a very successful
young man
um
you know i think a lot a lot of the
public schools are losing trust with
many of our families and we see this
with you know parents showing up now to
school committees uh all over the nation
right and i know this for my work in
massachusetts where a lot of parents are
upset with crt and congratulations to
new hampshire for passing a bill that
opposes crt but also the csc the
comprehensive sex education you know a
lot of parents think that's not age
appropriate they think it's not
medically accurate they think it's not
evidence-based
and it's really making a lot of parents
lose trust in the schools the social
emotional learning these these surveys
that go to these kids without parental
consent
and really target kids based on you know
not being a part of the group think and
this is really the main point i want to
make is that the public schools have
taken such a large step away from so
many families that have different belief
systems different morals that we
shouldn't be penalizing these families
for for the fact that the public school
has left them uh regarding their
convictions
the cato institute just said that new
hampshire out of all 50 states in the
union is the free estate
out of 50 and that's even above florida
where a lot of people seem to be
migrating these days so i think a lot of
people in new england you know you guys
know as well as i do a lot of people
that grow up in new england they pretty
much stay in new england right so all
new hampshire has to do is just keep
great programs like this if you want
freedom loving people to come to your
state um you know this is a wonderful
marketing
you know ploy for new hampshire
and then also i just want to bring up a
personal story i was talking to a father
african-american father the other day
actually yesterday spoke to me about for
30 minutes and
he's from a different state he's in he's
in massachusetts in worcester but i
think i think it's a very um
relevant story so he's telling me how
he's got four kids in the public school
and he's opted them out of sex ed in the
public school because he doesn't agree
with it right and then he said also the
school gave computers to his kids and he
said look i i really don't want my kids
to have computers like because i don't
want them to bring home the technology
and i want to have the freedom but you
know and he fought the school on it and
the school would not you know let him uh
have his way like they said no your
kid's going to have a computer and so
the computer came into the home and the
kid you know was looking on the computer
and and things were happening as you can
imagine with the technology that the
parent was in an agreement with
and you know and and i told him i felt
so bad for him i said well you know can
you look into a school alternative or
whatever you say well look i my wife and
i work two jobs i i can't homeschool my
kids you know i can't afford it you know
and what a great opportunity to have
this kind of program for a parent like
that who has fought the school system
for the sake of his kids but is now
literally he told me that he's losing
his relationship with his 15 year old
because of this whole computer issue
right and so just to listen to parents
because this shouldn't make the public
school just be no you're taking money
away from us this should make the public
school say what are we doing wrong what
should we be doing so that we can
attract these kids back to the public
school right
um and so the last one i'll make is just
on the um the point that was made about
funds not being given to religious
institutions and i would just remind you
all that you know we have this case at
the supreme court now in maine the
carson versus macon uh that is going to
go over this exact point right and i
think that uh from what i can tell it's
going to be a pretty positive decision
from the supreme court saying that you
can't discriminate against these
religious institutions just because
they're religious
um so i really encourage you to keep
these programs i think they're wonderful
for new hampshire and i think it's going
to really attract people to new
hampshire that are not just freedom
loving but you know a lot i know
personally a lot of hard-working
families that are saying you know what
i'm leaving massachusetts and i'm going
to new hampshire because that's a more
free state thank you
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
some of us come home to new hampshire
yeah well thank you very much for coming
today
any other parents out here
that have their kids here or need to get
home to their kids
home alone
there you go come on up
thank you i'm matthew smith um out of
where uh
these are my three boys well two boys
and my nephew
um i have custody of
i'll keep it brief this has been uh i
my kids go to attend uh concord
christian academy um
we i've struggled to keep him in school
for
20 years it's been six seven
eight
two are honor students um
lucas my great nephew
he uh
he started a year ago
his grades have gone up drastically from
where he was his reading comprehension
his arithmetic
um i attributed a lot of to the teachers
at cca
um there's a lot of dialogue there
we don't have any real experience with
public schools as far as they've been in
private sense but i pretty much moved
mountains to keep them there
um
i know we do pay plenty of taxes
and it goes towards public schools um
i'm trying to think what else
he said i'm a little nervous about this
i used to disarm bombs and i don't like
public speaking
[Laughter]
do you have anything to add voice
like thank you um for those who
it has really helped us quite a bit um
it really actually has kept us in our
house this year as everybody knows
things have gone up quite a bit
i don't know what we do without it um
and it's given us some
some lateral movement um
takes a little bit of stress off of me i
know that for sure
so
i'll take questions i'm probably better
at that
disarming uh
bombs i retired from
military yes
good
uh any questions
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you for having us yeah
let's have a good day
can i just add thank you for taking your
nephew i'm over in the corner um it's i
i know how
hard it is these days to even raise two
children on your own and you've taken
the third one in when obviously things
are tight for you so good for you for
taking in a child that obviously needed
love from somebody other than where he
started and it was very nice to do this
so i just want to say thank you because
i know it's hard and there are far too
many children out there who need what
you're giving to your nephew
it was my dying sister's last request
i actually just got my mom in december
she's on a couch right now but we're
trying trying to make it so
it's all about family
it's this is not a dress rehearsal yeah
thank you thank you
hello can everyone hear me okay yes all
right
um so i'm here to ask please do not give
us your name oh i'm sorry yes um my name
is jenny jennis and i'm asking if you
please not repeal the efi it has been
absolutely life-changing for my family
um i'm so pleased to be able to speak to
you all in favor of the education
freedom accounts
they have been such an extraordinary
benefit to my family in my original
remarks i wasn't going to address this
but um
i do want to say that we live in a
lovely part of new hampshire we
absolutely adore it the school district
is failing there the scores are not
going to
probably lower quartile the lowest
quartile and we we love it there we love
that we're a part of the revitalization
of this part of new hampshire we're very
involved in the community but it is only
because we homeschool that we're able to
be a part of it in that way
so i
living where i am i would have to move
to have that constitutional right
without homeschooling and and the efa
um as a little background about my
family my husband and i have been
married 12 years we have five kids ages
one through ten
we're both public schooled he is now a
lawyer and um
i am a therapist trained at the
doctorate level with a master's in
clinical psychology i'm also a former
public high school teacher
despite our aptitude for schooling both
my husband and i found that we struggled
throughout our schooling
in different ways and we learned over
time as we both have professional
degrees how to learn in a way where we
could excel
so when we were married we had children
we decided we wanted them to homeschool
as well so i am one of those who always
intended to homeschool but
many of you may realize that the choice
to homeschool means that you have
significant financial sacrifices you
make generally you have to uh someone
has to stay home and i was offered my
dream job
and we would have been doing
very well between the two of us but
instead we said you know we're going to
do this i stayed home and we sent my
husband off to law school so he was
working full-time doing law school while
i was at home homeschooling these kids
so while we have the professional
degrees and all we are all we have we
have really worked for that and we are
now on a budget
always on a budget something to think
about is that it takes a lot of time to
be able to homeschool you're already
sacrificing the one income and then it
takes a lot of time to find used
resources the the good the well-priced
classes the you know the the
my kids used the same notebooks since
they were in kindergarten and the oldest
one is 10. i literally bought new
notebooks for the first time this year
we just had bought a book pack and we
used it you know because to us it was
this important to give them the
differentiated instruction especially
having been a public school teacher all
the more so i had found how restricted i
was in trying to give the children that
i really adored what they needed so i i
you know i made those sacrifices so the
children can do that
now i i mean when this efa happened i
was
i was like oh my goodness you know for a
fraction of the cost of one public
school student these kids are thriving i
wasn't able even though we do very well
because we have five kids because the
ways we did this because we have student
loans and things i wasn't able to afford
a computer and a printer so no i
couldn't do online classes i couldn't
figure out how to get the the free
typing club class to go on the one
little kindle we had like that didn't
work you know and so now we have all
these resources it didn't cost a lot it
didn't cost a lot to the taxpayer and
this will benefit the new hampshire
taxpayer this will
these kids will benefit new hampshire
and this program will benefit new
hampshire because it is allowing so many
kids to thrive
so
yeah we got a printer we got a computer
our first one in ten years um
you know we got what did we get we got
hooked on phonics app it cost 12.99 a
month but
i couldn't do it i couldn't i didn't
have a computer i couldn't do it what
else we do my kids have done um they
have a gym class now so mom's not out
there trying to kick the soccer ball to
them like i know what i'm doing i like
out there on the street like yeah kick
it with the side of your foot i don't
know what i'm doing you know so they're
out there they're out there with someone
who can really teach them some things
you know because we all need some help
we all need a little help i'm quite good
at this and in many ways math and
science and friend even french i teach
some french i can do that but i can't
teach them gym class i need to pay
someone so you know this is this has
been absolutely everything and for this
small amount
it's everything we need to be able to
give these children who will benefit
other children who will benefit new
hampshire's economy who will benefit new
hampshire's communities and our family
is also able to live where we live and
benefit our community which we're very
invested in and very involved in because
of the efa supporting us and i want to
make one more point which is that when
you start homeschooling it's not very
expensive a kindergartner does not need
much you do a little reading you do a
little writing you do a little math
you're good to go
but a 10 year old who's who's it who's
fairly advanced in in several several
subjects
and an eight-year-old who's starting to
explore things they need more so even if
you have a home i've been in
homeschooling the whole time
it was starting to become almost
undoable
because as you go and you have more
needs your financial needs get greater
so the efa provided me something
where i had no solution i wasn't sure
what i was going to do
and the kids love it next time i'll
bring one she'll tell you
thank you very much thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee
yes represent woodcock i think i heard
you correct after i think i heard you
correctly i'll be sure he said your
children were already being homeschooled
prior to the program that's what i said
i'm not sure i could continue
homeschooling them okay thank you
any other questions
thank you very much
any other
parents
yeah i know probably a lot of parents
out there but
that need to get home okay you put your
hand down
good afternoon my name is ali taylor my
family and i live in manchester we are
property taxpayers in manchester and we
are in manchester school district
we found it very interesting that both
of the assistant principals of the
public schools that our children have
attended have had their own children in
private school
that's that that tells a lot
thank you for your time and hearing my
thoughts today regarding hb 1683
it's my strong belief in the live free
or die state of new hampshire that the
educational choices for children belong
to their parents
who better knows a child and his unique
needs better than mom or dad
as the mom of four boys ages 11 to 23
our family has taken different
educational approaches along the way
our boys have attended public school
private school and even been
homeschooled early on but it hasn't
always been easy providing
a unique education that each of our
children needed because our youngest
child hudson was born in 2010 with a
surprise diagnosis of down syndrome as
well as autism
diagnosed with autism a few years later
so our lives drastically changed today
hudson is non-verbal and incontinent at
age 11 with several other medical
diagnosis so i'm a full-time caregiver
these days and while i initially
homeschooled my older boys my caregiving
responsibilities do not allow me to
continue that
after initially trying the public
schools and then doing some research we
realized that private school was the
right choice for our older boys
unable to afford school tuition on one
income with me at home with hudson we
applied for private scholarships and i
started a web-based company in 2014
working nights for many years to earn
tuition money for our kids it was
exhausting working nights and caring for
my son hudson during the day
at that time our second youngest son
charlie was still enrolled in our local
public school and things were not going
well
a very creative child he was bored and
desperately needed a gifted and talented
program that was not available in our
district
we then moved him to a private school
but it was a very tricky financial
decision for our family
so we you can imagine how ecstatic we
were last august when the new hampshire
legislature unanimously embraced the efa
bill it changed our lives charlie is now
a high school sophomore he attends
private school in concord his classes
are challenging and many opportunities
have opened up for him last year he
entered the concord rotary club speech
contest and won first place as a
freshman in high school he plays guitar
on the worship team at his school he
participates in ski club he takes guitar
piano in percussion lessons he has a
lead role in the school play
makes straight a's in advanced classes
and works at market basket on weekends
this is a kid who is thriving despite
the pandemic because the efa has given
us educational choice
i've always told my kids the sky's the
limit they can do anything they want to
do and that they'll be happiest when
they're utilizing their god-given gifts
we see an incredible difference in this
child because he can now fully utilize
those gifts i'm so glad we made the
decision to put our kids in private
school it has not always been easy but
with one child finishing up his
doctorate program right now another
finishing up his undergrad degree it was
the right choice for our family we have
no regrets
all new hampshire families should be
able to choose the right educational
path for their children it shouldn't
have to be a struggle like it was for
ours please support new hampshire
families and educational choice for
every child by voting no on hb 1683
thank you thank you very much
and thank you for all the sacrifices
you've done for the kids it's
my pleasure
any questions any questions
thank you thank you
any other
folks that got to get out of here we all
got to get out of here i've got the car
seats and the kids got to be picked up
in manchester at five oh that's a good
reason
i have the same problem the car seat's
always in the wrong car
yep you have to shift it i always
underestimate how long this is going to
take i'm brittany leclear ping i'm here
with moms for liberty new hampshire
hillsborough county chapter
greetings again my name is brittany
leclearping i reside in hillsborough 18
in west manchester and i'm here
officially as a representative for moms
for liberty hillsborough county chapter
there's about 45 of us women and a few
men
to speak in opposition to hb 1683 which
seeks to remove education freedom
accounts in our great state
moms for liberty hillsboro new hampshire
is a dedicated
to the survival of america by unifying
educating and empowering parents to
defend their parental rights at all
levels of government i'm not gonna i'm
gonna skip past some of my speech
because we all know this stuff
um efas were ruled out in a pivotal time
for families in our state when coveted
restrictions in many school districts
had blue collar families attempting to
find ways to remote school their
children while performing their
essential in-person jobs
my family personally chose to homeschool
my son in kindergarten because i had to
do just that i had to be in person
last year
in line with our mission we joined the
fight to protect the 548 children in
hillsborough county that are part of the
approximately 1600 children that have
been able to utilize a portion of their
study state education funding to meet
their unique educational needs and we
hope that with your opposition to this
bill families in our community may have
that may need these accounts in the
future will have the ability thank you
for your time thank you so much any
questions from the committee
not seeing any hands thank you thank you
have we gone through all the families
kids that are
here the back
okay first time here
um
thank you for hearing my testimony today
my name is melissa lewis and i have four
daughters that have been in new
hampshire school system whether
attending public school or homeschooling
from 2012 through today
today i'm going to highlight the journey
of my eldest daughter evie who thanks to
the children's scholarship of new
hampshire and the educational freedom
accounts
is able to attend ninth grade at high
mowing school a waldorf boarding and day
school in wilton new hampshire
evie the eldest of four has always been
an intuitive empathetic young child an
artist from the start i quickly saw that
she learned the most in by interacting
with the world around her she
communicated easily with adults and
children in our community from the
library children's director the town rec
program instructors or a homeschool
co-op led by parents
trained as an early childhood educator
myself i could tell that by age 6 evie
was not picking up on things like
reading and math where she should be
at the time our local
school district in goffstown would not
test her for a delay unless we enrolled
her in public school
we did that the following year when evie
was given an iep for an undiagnosed
learning disability what i suspect was
and is still today dyslexia and
dysgraphia
evie would go through the next few years
struggling with anxiety and depression
all while making continuing to make
strong connections with teachers and
tutors
many whom to this day still say she was
their most outgoing and favorite student
her ties and interest in forming
community connections remained by sixth
grade evie was vice president of our
student council
acting in the manchester community
theater and helping teach children's
acro at our local dance studio
however i stayed true to the fact to her
iep team that the day when the day came
when i felt my daughter's sense of self
had been lost
i would pull her from the school that
day came when after severe current
concerns with mental health for well
over two years
daily tears and frustration over the
lack of help from teachers and what she
was supposed to be receiving
academically from the school i felt my
daughter spark had long been lost to a
system where she was getting forgotten
her gifts pushed aside and not valued
from the staff that was overworked and
didn't have time to provide whatever he
needed to learn in a healthy way
after talking with the csf director kate
baker we realized that we may just be
able to make himoing school evie's dream
school a reality for evie for high
school if we qualified for the new
educational freedom account evie wrote a
scholarship essay for the school
attended a virtual interview and was
over the moon when she was told by the
teachers that they knew she would offer
a lot
evie has worked hard since september she
has long days and homework that involves
essays reading math french but also
painting hand work an independent study
of ballet
her days are filled with science foreign
language treks outdoors daily community
cleanup and her favorite circus arts
yet she comes home eager to go back the
next day
expecting to hear of her academic
struggles from her teachers at the first
student teacher conferences in october i
instead was met with these words from
her teachers
evie is in touch with nature she cares
for those students around her she is
bubbly but focused evie values the
school and its mission i see her
becoming an emerging leader of the
school and her class
evie is kind and caring she is dedicated
and while she may struggle with some of
the content she's the first to offer to
participate or demonstrate in class
evie is going to succeed not because of
grades but because she has a desire to
learn and she is passionate about her
education
i wholeheartedly believe that my
daughter is in this school that is the
best fit for her that without the
educational freedom account and the
funds provided evie would not be able to
attend the school where she is valued
her gifts are celebrated and not
discouraged the teachers can see how she
learns best and take this into
consideration for assessing her work and
the curriculum throughout the year
evie has a new take on life and her
future and it is because she was given
this chance
thank you for this opportunity to speak
and to support children and students in
new hampshire like evie that want to
learn but need the freedom of choice to
find the right educational path for them
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee not seeing
any thank you
is todd out there taught from new london
you have to tell me how to say your last
name you're todd
uh my name is
todd burcillary um good afternoon
community members um thank you for the
opportunity to speak to you today in
opposition of hp 1683
i am a licensed new hampshire teacher
i'm also the assistant director and one
of the middle school teachers at newport
montessori school
it's a non-profit non-public school with
108 students
our school enrolls uh pre-kindergartners
through eighth grade
we currently have 12 families using efa
monies to supplement their tuition
payments to our school
and our school's highest tuition rate is
eight thousand six hundred dollars a
year
non-public school has always been an
option for affluent families and with
the help of scholarship funds like our
school's in-house tuition assistant
program which we do a lot of fundraising
for
and the children's scholarship fund
low-income families are able to meet
tuition payments
the fas have leveled the playing field
for middle-income families who sometimes
make just a bit too much money to
qualify for need-based scholarships
um but are yet far from affluent income
levels
i have here a portion of a testimony
from a family member of one of our
students he's a five-year-old his name
is carter b
um both of his parents are incarcerated
and his 71 year old grandfather is his
legal guardian um this has actually been
emailed to all of you but i'm just going
to read one paragraph an excerpt from it
so again this is from a family member of
carter b
we implore you to please vote against
eliminating the education reform freedom
accounts
please keep the education freedom
accounts program for carter and his
grandpa and for all the other new
hampshire families that have relied on
these accounts this year to allow them
the ability to choose a school that fits
their child's educational needs better
than some of our public schools are
currently able to do
keeping this program will not only help
the children who need a method of
education more conductive to their
specific needs but will also take the
pressure off public schools trying to
accommodate large class sizes full of a
wide variety of learning styles and
needs
public schools will be able to focus
more on mainstream education and improve
areas of education they are already good
at while private schools home schools
etc can focus on meeting individual
students more specific educational needs
keeping this program is not only an
investment today in all new hampshire
children in public and alternative
educational environments but also will
be an investment in new hampshire's
future when today's children become
tomorrow's valuable members of our
state's adult citizenship
so
thank you very much for giving me the
time today um we urge you to vote no on
1683 and i can take any questions thank
you todd are there any questions
not seeing any thank you very much
uh
seth cody's
good afternoon my name is seth coats and
thank you all for all that you do
to make our
state of new hampshire such a great
place to live um and thanks for allowing
me to speak this afternoon
i have a similar story to a lot that
you've heard today
and i implore you
to find a solution that allows the heart
of the faa program to continue
my children
i've attended public schools in our
local area
we've also tried homeschooling and this
year they attend a small private school
and the efa
account has been what has tipped the
scale to allow us to try that out to
find the best
possible education for our children
i love the public schools in our area i
think the teachers are great i have no
doubt that they also provide a
constitutionally adequate
program and like many of the parents
that you've heard today i seek out the
best possible education for my children
um
and i'm i was happy to find the efa
program and the use of our tax dollars
as a state
to that end
and to give the parent the choice to
make that happen
um
so i would offer um
maybe a middle of the road encouragement
to you that if you choose to vote no
um or if you choose to vote yes and
repeal the fa program find a different
better solution and quickly at least for
my sake because i have a high schooler
coming this next fall and i'm thoroughly
trying to figure out what to do with her
that will find the best possible
education when we'll send her the public
school if we need to and it will be
constitutionally adequate
um but as a parent and i'm sure that
many of you can resonate with this
i'm not just searching for what's
adequate i'm searching for what's best
and so if if we don't have a quick and
expedient solution that's better than
the current program then i would implore
you to keep the current program until
you do
for so many of the other people that
you've heard today and for my kids as
well thank you
thank you very much uh looking at
jacquard are you in support or in
opposition to the bill or neutral
i'm in support of keeping the current
program
so i'm in opposition of repealing the
boat though okay so do you want me to
change to them because you put yes if i
wrote it wrong sorry about that okay
thank you you're welcome are there any
questions from the committee
not seeing thank you very much
appreciate it
james wood
good afternoon i'm james wood from
merrimack new hampshire and i support
parents and whatever they want to do
with their children
as a taxpayer my wife and i both have no
children
we've lived in the state for over 20
years we
i understand the need to send children
to the best education possible
i spent 22 years in the military travel
around the world it's all lots of
different peoples all different places
and something's fundamentally wrong in
our country when you start seeing us
drop down around the world when you
start looking at the educational levels
of the kids coming from our high schools
i saw it in the military
i saw people coming without
any
real fundamental values i don't know
what it cost i don't know where it comes
from whether it's in home or something
in school but they're just something
missing
i support kids because i understood what
it's like because i suffered from
dyslexia for more than
six years when i was growing up and
teachers would
couldn't understand and my mother was
the only thing that i had to move
forward because they were saying
we don't know what to do with them
we don't know what to do with them and i
went from year to year but still pushed
through the educational system until i
got to fifth grade and uh teachers one
teacher said
this kid can't write his name
i'd write letters backwards i could add
or subtract because i was adding numbers
because i thought a three was an eight
or i saw things upside down and
backwards i know what it's like to be
one of those kids that gets pushed
through the system and then that teacher
said to my mom you need to get him some
help
because things were going downhill
relatively quick
so my mother my father worked at ford
plant making 95 a week and there was
seven of us in the house so you tell me
how my mom and dad were going to support
sending me to special education my
mother did all she could to take care of
five kids and a guy that worked three
jobs trying to make ends meet
so i know what these parents are going
through i know what it's like to be that
kid sitting in that classroom being
pushed through because
we were in an expedited educational
system we need to get you through we
have a lot of kids in this class we
don't have time to spend a lot of time
with you and i understood that too i
understand that now because i can see
that
but i tell you right now these
educational savings accounts are
important because you can see the
families that are helping there's no
better return of investment on our tax
money than putting into these kids we
can spend money on highways we can pop
fix potholes but once these kids get
through those grades they never gain the
fundamental knowledge again that you
miss by the early formative years the
formative years are the most important
building blocks to build their education
so i stress everyone to think about when
you're looking at money as money is a
sole
driving factor for everything we need to
find the money bank borrow steal
whatever we have to do we need to find
money and if there's a structural
problem in the program between the house
and the senate or the people in these we
need to come together as a group and
realize the things we're trying to do is
what's best for the kids and best for
everybody in the state of new hampshire
because like they were saying we will
benefit from these children far longer
because they're going to be taking care
of us but we can't take care of
ourselves so if we don't equip them with
all the tools that they need to we're in
trouble as a society and you can see
that now by how many homeless people
there are who can't find jobs because
they have no hope because a lot of them
don't have any reason to have hope
so i'm for structurally doing whatever
we need to do to keep these kids
in whatever they need to do whatever we
have to do
thank you are there any questions from
the committee
thank you very much for your service
louise spencer
hi mr chairman thank you for taking my
testimony thank you members of the
committee
my name is louise spencer i live in
concord i'm co-founder of a group called
kent street coalition it's an
all-volunteer grassroots advocacy
group
and i
i'm very sympathetic to much of the
testimony that we heard today
i have a daughter with dyslexia
who had
a great deal of challenges both
in the public schools and in a private
school
i think
that
there are
there can be challenges in finding the
right match for for each child to the
right education
where i take issue is
the fact that
we have not adequately funded
the public schools and many of the
problems that we hear
being raised are ones that i would hope
[Music]
could be
addressed if schools had the adequate
resources that they need
in order to
give each child the
sort of education that can address
specific challenges and problems
i
i do
think that there is truth in the idea
that
we need to look at
customer and i have to say that as a
taxpayer and customer
i find it quite appalling that a program
would have been estimated at costing us
200 000
or less
and that it's run up
to 8 million and counting
with a 6 000
cost overrun
now it could be
that
the state decides that that's how we
should be spending our money
the problem i have here is that we never
decided that and that was never reviewed
this program never went through finance
committee
it never was really considered what the
true costs of this program were going to
be
it was never looked at what might be
appropriate alternatives to this program
and so
i
you know it may be that it represents a
certain
interest in the program
but
as taxpayers
and i would think every granite stater
would want
the
legislature to do its due diligence
and reviewing a program and the two the
true costs that a program will have
in the context of the money that we have
available to fund education public
education
overall as a state and i really take
issue with the fact that that was never
done with this program
so i also i just want to point out that
there are many people who are
paying attention to this bill
and lots of reasons that many of them
could not be here today
some of that has to do with covid and
whether people
are feeling comfortable being in a
smaller closed environment
others have to do with people working
teachers for example who are in the
classroom
students who are in the classroom
others who can't travel due to
disabilities or lack of transportation
so
i would like to point out a few things
one is that if you go on to the um
onto the record
where the public testimonies can be
submitted
we find that
people as of just a few moments ago
signed in
in support of this bill
if you take into account the additional
ones that signed in on the blue sheets
that adds
that comes to
917 people
supporting this bill
if you then look at those opposed signed
in
204 opposed
plus on the sheets 30 so that's 230
people
opposed to this bill
there were 33
testimonies submitted online
27 in support
and
six opposed
we heard today
16 testimonies in support again thank
you much of it very powerful
and we heard before
in support did i say 16 we heard today
um
opposed to the bill and then
four
um in support of the bill
so that brings it to 31 total
testimonies in support and 22 opposed
so i think it's important that we
recognize that there are many many
granite staters
who for a variety of reasons
are opposed to this bill i appreciate
the testimony of the last gentleman
about you know can we come together and
try to find solutions to meet the needs
of all of our children
across the state i think that's
really important
but
as it stands right now
with this legislature
choosing not to
put money
that would fund an adequate education
for every child attending public school
i think we need to err on the side of
repealing this bill
which is currently
taking money away from the public
schools that is much needed so
thank you very much appreciate it the
opportunity to testify thank you for
your testimony are there any questions
not
not seeing you thank you very much thank
you
do we have some folks here kirsch
is it doug
oh yeah there are two of you
i want to do is a team relay here um
walter
you're walter
you want to go up and sit with her
[Laughter]
welcome
so
i'm dorcas kirsch and
i guess as i put down representing my
god my lord and savior jesus christ but
i guess he was
represented a little bit
you know when you take god out of the
equation i don't know what people expect
i'm just going to read this because i
said i'd be quick um this is
zechariah zechariah 8
these are the things that ye shall do
speak ye every man the truth to his
neighbor
execute the judgment of truth and peace
in your gates
and let none of you imagine evil in your
hearts against his neighbor and love no
false oath
for all these things are things that i
hate saith the lord
we're created beings we're i don't know
what you know i don't know what the
schools
teach because
i think
the reason i have sanity is i didn't pay
attention in school
i didn't understand it it didn't make
sense i didn't pay attention
and that's my saving grace and and
nothing too
it's good to learn
but when we first came over
from another country
we learned from the bible
that's not religion jesus christ is not
religion he's a relationship
and
you know it said in the end times
i'll use
the bad will get better and the good
will get gooder and that's not very good
grammar but this is what's going on this
madness
going on um in in this world and
if we put
god first
our neighbor is ourself we wouldn't be
here
i thank you
if there's any questions i'll answer
thank you very much
walter
i assume you're related
i didn't really come prepared to
speak today but after listening to um
young girls from the prenda program and
other homeschoolers i
felt that i
had to kind of weigh in a little bit
here
you know and um
a couple of testimonies ago this woman
talked about
public school system needed more money
you know it seems like it's always about
money money money money just get much
money as we can right now
i think roughly 20 000 per student is
being spent through the public school
system
these alternatives
systems are looking for a little bit of
money you know if just the money
would follow the students that would
take care of all the money needs
you know um public schools
from what i've heard today are not doing
a real bang-up job
i mean there's going to be amazing kids
could be coming out of these uh
homeschooling and
alternative schooling that
i you know i oppose this this nonsense
bill to take
money of choice and freedom away from
from you know parents
and also these numbers that this one
person came up with
writings and whatnot
whatever i mean that means nothing
you've seen what's happening here today
this is people are against this people
want to have choice you know to
to school and educate their children as
they see fit
thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
not seeing any hands thank you
uh next one we have it i'm
not quite sure i'm pronouncing alan
osborne
is it eow
yes there it is
pronounced a win aoen okay thank you
everyone all right
um
hello thank you for allowing me to speak
today my name is eowyn osborne i'm 15
years old i'm a homeschooler from auburn
new hampshire
and i oppose this build
several several years ago i was
diagnosed with aspergers and
it's really impacted my life a lot
however i am one of
the luckier people who was diagnosed
with it i've had
more opportunities than
the average child would i'm lucky enough
to have been homeschooled from the start
i've never had to go to public school
i know that
other children like me who are
dealing with similar brain differences
to myself
they've really struggled and haven't
really done well in public school you've
seen
the testimonies from the previous
people here today you had
that other
11 year old
boy who
was who got expelled from his school
because he couldn't cope with it
as someone who's a neurotypical person
could and
as you know someone with the same brain
difference as him it's really important
to me that other children
get to have the opportunity to have the
education that benefits them and doesn't
exclude them because of their brain
differences
i know for a fact that i wouldn't have
survived public school i wouldn't have
learned anything and i probably would
have gotten thrown out because i
couldn't have coped with it
i know several other friends of mine
three of my best friends in fact have
been through the public school system
all three of them they were bullied and
some of them now struggle with
mental health problems because of like
the lousy job that public school did for
them
so
i beg of you please do not pass this
bill by doing so you would be do mean
hundreds of kids like me
to the oppressive education system that
is public school
thank you thank you for your testimony
and thank you for coming this afternoon
we really appreciate it
are there any comments from the
questions from the committee
now thank you so much
have a good evening
marie fontaine
hi thanks for having me today i'm going
to make this fast since it's way later
than i expected my name is mari
i live in manchester um i have a 10 year
old son that loves to learn like many
families the past two years have been
extremely difficult for our son and his
education we had to make big changes on
how we supported him in and out of
school
when the pandemic happened he was in
he was in a private school
but everything went remote and i was
building decks with my husband for our
construction company
so it was like a really hard situation i
had to bring my son to the job site um
the clients were getting upset
it was really difficult i had to stop
working um
so having education freedom accounts was
something that offered support for
families like ours that were struggling
to provide the best opportunities
public school system was not working at
the time they're also remote and
a lot of what i was seeing happen in the
public schools don't align with our
values and
i was really dismayed at seeing some of
the low test scores large class sizes so
once i stopped working
we really really took a lot of time to
like find the best opportunities we
could for our son
so that he could still have a normal
life during everything that was
happening
so we can't
he's he's doing so great like i can't
imagine like going back
and you know putting him in a situation
he's thriving right now so
um i oppose bill 1683 and i thank you
for your time thank you for coming any
questions from the committee
thank you
taylor garrison
alexandra
wing
welcome hi thank you um thanks for your
time my name is alexandra schrozzotti
wing
and i um
i have five children
three of whom are using the efa right
now and i couldn't be happier with their
progress my son in particular
it's nothing short of a miracle how far
he's come and we were late going into
the school year i had been homeschooling
um and i did that because of the public
school was not working especially for my
son
so it definitely changed our income i've
had to cut back so i i really think the
efa is going to be a win-win overall for
taxpayers i really believe that because
as soon as my last child god willing
gets into
on the school that we have the children
and now i will be able to return to work
in a more full-time capacity
um but i just i didn't want to lose my
children you know i didn't want to lose
my son
in a school that wasn't working for him
at the time and now he is attending a
private school thanks to the efa and it
just supplements what we're able to
bring to the table and
make it so that he is able to attend um
and again we just couldn't be happier
and i just wanted to bring out that um
and i have shared this before with some
of the members here um
that as a teen i actually went to live
with my grandmother and aunt for several
years
away from my parents because they
couldn't afford to put me in a private
school and i was being bullied in
the public school
of their residence and so i was able to
attend another public school but i had
to be away from my family my immediate
family for a number of years
and that did benefit me you know but i
did miss my parents of course it wasn't
ideal so i just thank you for these efas
they've empowered me to be the mother
that
i've wanted to be i and
they've just it's just changed our
family the the positive ripple effect is
just
it's awesome my husband has been able to
attend nursing school we've had more
money so we're not going in the red with
him in school and we expect him to
uh be a nurse at the end of the year
um so you'll see that the bigger picture
is it's really helping families overall
not just with the education of the
children but financially
um so i plead with you please keep these
efas alive
uh they're making a big difference for
these families thank you so much
thank you for coming this afternoon are
there any questions from the committee
thank you again thank you
uh michael thornton
michael thornton
milford new hampshire
speaking for our family
chair
please strike the word at the bottom of
the card without prejudice
and don't let this be a condemnation
of the state of education
in new hampshire
thank you for the reading test
yeah thank you our family had a problem
uh with our younger daughter
she was painfully is
publicly painfully
shy because of this she was teased and
bullied
we
were not in a fluid family we still are
not
we saved and got her
some
much needed
counseling
the counselor
prepared
an independent
iep
complete plan
submitted it
to the school system
and
to our horror we found out
that the
school
excuse me the school psychologist used
to work for that
counselor
and
because he did not like her
our daughter
and her qualified plan were dismissed
he directed her
student her teachers
and her fellow students to pull her out
of her shell by calling on her
every opportunity
she stopped going to school
we asked for a meeting
at the meeting we were told there's no
way we're not going to do it
we're not going to let her have her plan
the uniform officer the uniformed
officer sitting in the room
came to us
afterward and
offered some friendly advice
your daughter will be
16 in a couple of days
withdraw her
and we won't have to come arrest you
at that time
was too sick
with agent orange induced the lymphoma
the first of several different cancers
to
fight
we had no money for
professional lawyers who would be able
to
rebut what was being done
instead we did our best
we taught her to teach herself
when
her
fellow classmates graduated she
was discouraged so she went down and
tested
with the ged
when she got her results
she felt a little redeemed she did not
get her ged
after
being forced out in the ninth grade
she found out that her own teaching
of herself had resulted in this
she missed by three points
in one
the mathematics
on the rest
she maxed
the test
today
she still struggles with shyness
she's an excellent person
a wonderful citizen
the system doesn't work for every child
it can't
there needs to be
some
mechanism
because the law says
what the law says
and the results we give the children
should reflect that
we can
do better this is a first step
welcome any questions
thank you very much michael michael are
you in support of this bill to repeal or
are you in opposition to the bill you've
written down here that you i asked to
you to strike that word at the end
it is obvious
that our family
would have
benefited greatly
by the current state of affairs
and we would welcome it remaining
okay thank you please then correct that
thank you very much
the next person is uh kelly santos
kelly you'd down uh
ten minutes said you know can you cut it
a little short please
no my back can't handle 10 more minutes
so
thank you so much for having um
spent your afternoon listening to all
this testimony um
it's so so important
um
i brought my children with me but in a
different format because no way would
they sit this one so um
you've seen these pages before some of
you um
and
since the last time i spoke in front of
the education committee i've actually
had a conversation with my youngest
son's kindergarten teacher where they're
suggesting occupational therapy for him
we suffer from a
congenital
disorder it's a connective tissue
disorder where your
you know ligaments and tendons don't
quite work
and what that leads to is
low muscle tone so we have to work twice
as hard to get half as far
so when that comes to writing your
body isn't properly aligned you're not
able to sit up very well
and that happens to my oldest as well so
they need additional support that is not
the only support they need
my oldest has been diagnosed with
specific i can't see everybody sorry um
two specific learning disabilities one
i'm reading one in written
expression he also has adhd sensory
processing disorder so he brings to
school a whole host of
items we were in the public school
and
i was the first to be there at the end
of the first day of school with my
camera so i could get them coming off
the bus with their big smiles
and i'm grieving
the loss of my oldest
not
being part of the fifth grade farewell
at his school with his cub scout buddies
i
wanted
them to go to public school the way
my husband and i did and have the same
life experiences that we did i met my
husband in high school
i met him when i was 15 years old
and i didn't marry him until i was 30
that's a whole nother story so
we did remote learning for fourth grade
due to the pandemic
we are not interested in homeschooling
this is not an option for us
my son
has been a priority in my life of course
but then he was in public school in
first grade i'm volunteering at the
school
each monday his teacher
explained that she's gonna call a
meeting because he's having trouble with
his writing
she can't read anything that he writes
is what she said
so i come to a room that looks pretty
much like this big group of people
talking about my son psychologist i
didn't know who they were
and
i trusted them
my trust was misplaced
and
they
i thought they were doing what was best
for my son and the more i learned the
more i understood they were not
following the child find mandate they
were not offering vape
which is the constitutional
um
right to a fair
free i'm sorry free and appropriate
public education so let's talk about you
are not allowed
to ask the public school system for the
best education this is the first rule of
iep process
the only thing you can ask for is a free
and appropriate education
the
psychologist refused to test him when i
brought her five thousand dollar
neuropsych evaluation that we paid for
we were told
we do not accept his learning
disabilities
because he is able to pass
which
according to the
um ida ea law
that doesn't matter if he can pass
that's not a true statement i was also
told by the
director of special education only the
parents can refer him to special
education
also not true his first grade teacher
referred him to special education but
now he was in fourth grade
no iep a 504
that wasn't benefiting him and he had um
asked me
if he could speak to somebody because he
was so sad
so public school did not work for him it
failed him
it did not provide him and then
if we were to get an iep then it would
become my responsibility to ensure that
that was being followed i would now need
to become the school's checks and
balances i would need to make sure that
they were delivering it on that iep that
i was keeping every email every
paperwork every phone call
enduring these meetings with a
psychologist that told me he was not
meeting my expectations
so really
i don't want to hold you up so
i came here today to talk numbers
actually and
math is not my strong suit so
please forgive me we're gonna just try
to do a quick math um
let's talk about who's taking the money
away from the public school for a minute
the efa is for low-income parents i
don't know if that's clear
so
a family of four like us
the limit is seventy eight thousand six
hundred dollars okay
so i am sending my son to a private
school
in which he
is given orton gillingham along with all
the other students in his class he is
not singled out
i had asked the school for this after
the neuropsych evaluation they denied
him
so he walks in the door he gets his
needs met at the private school the cost
of the private school for two children
i need my classes
is twenty thousand five hundred and
sixteen dollars and eighty one cents
what we receive for two children from
the efa was nine thousand two hundred
dollars
i have
written out and
i can provide to
the committee
a budget for a family of four
based on tuition
so after
we paid for the registration materials
and tuition the required t-shirt the
computer and the outdoor gear required
we then had a budget of 57 681 dollars
for the year
using not
only my specific
monthly budget or yearly budget i went
and looked at averages so i have a
website here where i found most of our
information but just based on fifteen
hundred dollars a month
that would equal eighteen thousand
dollars a year
um property taxes fifty five hundred we
do pay property taxes we actually have a
tenant unit
so we're paying for that as well
we pay health insurance private health
insurance
we pay for current insurance because the
yellow bus doesn't come to our house
anymore
we pay for fuel for that car maintenance
on that car we pay for ot
services because the school did not
provide that we pay for pt services they
do not provide that speech services
which they have that ability but denied
him
we pay for propane electric phone
internet for his homework
um food
lots of it
life insurance two hundred dollars a
month uh water bill
so our families year-round balance comes
to negative one thousand four hundred
forty dollars
the hudson school system typically their
yen year-end surplus is over seven
hundred thousand dollars i also have a
copy of their history
historical fund balance and year-end
transfers which i can provide to the
committee as well
now
in this budget it does not include
medical and dental expenses that are not
covered by insurance you have a
you know genetic disorder you need a few
extra
mris
you need a few extra cat scans you need
a few extra things
this does not include emergencies it
does not include clothing it does not
include savings it does not include
birthdays and christmas
this does not include that five thousand
dollar neuropsyc evaluation
it does not include lawyer fees if i did
decide to fight the school it does not
include pets it does not include
streaming services
[Music]
so
in hudson this school district that
we're in it's roughly around sixteen
hundred dollars to educate
a student so i have two students around
thirty two hundred dollars
again we received that ninety two
hundred dollars
to help with the cost of private schools
that's roughly seven hundred and sixty
seven dollars per month
the public school would still have 23
800 for these two children that no
longer exist
they don't need
to educate them anymore we laughed
if i looked at wyndham woods which is a
private school that's actually a lot
closer to where we live
their per student tuition is forty one
thousand dollars per year
if we looked at a school like learning
skills academy which would help with the
learning disabilities that's fifty three
thousand eight hundred and fourteen
and sixty cents per student that's over
a hundred and six thousand dollars to
educate two students
now pitcher minimum wage
household seven dollars and twenty five
pence in new hampshire
for one person that's fifteen thousand
dollars to bring it home
a couple that's thirty thousand one
hundred sixty dollars
the school again cost twenty thousand
dollars for these two children
compare that to your food bill the seven
percent increase
in january in inflation
compare that to the number of streaming
services you might be using currently
the median or the average cost of living
in hillsborough county which i live in
is 83
667 dollars and 14 cents
so
we can't ask for the best
education i pay my property taxes and i
pay for
private school education i pay twice
i am a taxpayer
i would like to see low-income families
receive funds for when the school system
fails
i support teachers
i think you can have it both ways
you can support the efa
you can oppose this bill
and you can support teachers all at the
same time it's not one or way or the
other it really isn't
there
are
over
1600 students
that
ran to this program
parents who need this to survive
we are low-income people trying to take
money
from our taxes
to go to the school to help us survive
in order to
make
the 78 thousand six hundred dollars a
family would need to make
37.79 an hour
that's not too bad right
or that's two people at 18.90
an hour but you take 20 000 off the top
that doesn't leave much
we'd like to just buy some clothes
we i don't necessarily want my funds to
go pay for someone else's education
my property taxes pay for that public
education
that i trusted and didn't work for us
and told me that they don't accept
his disabilities
so
why not
work the other way right can we just
have ninety two hundred dollars
follow him from our property taxes to
help make ends meet
i think that's all the math i can handle
so thank you so much for your time
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
not seeing thank you very much
and this is the last
no no no we is lorraine
lindenberg here
she left okay
uh then richard irving
uh thank you uh mr chair
and uh committee members
um
i may not know much about this um
h bill
h bill um 1683 but uh i know this
i'm one of the people who are
opposed to this uh bill
uh
just for our for our students at school
and um
i would ask that
you uh turn down this uh this bill and
to protect the efa
for all students of new hampshire
that is all i'm going to say to you all
thank you
thank you very much any questions any
questions
no no questions
um i don't have any more pink cards up
here is there anybody out there that did
not
did you look well come on up if you have
something you'd like to present to us
then you might look under the table see
if you can submit a card
no not it okay
hello my name is rick duba i'm head of
school in my 18th year at laconia
christian academy
and prior to taking this position i
taught for 14 years at plymouth regional
high school and part of the reason i'm
asking you to stay just this little
extra bit is because i was a government
and law teacher
in plymouth and i dragged my kids to
these hearings
year after year after year made them
testify and never actually did it myself
and i've dragged my students down from
lca and done the same thing and now i'll
get to go home and say
i did too so i will my remarks might be
disjointed because i'm going to try to
really
get done here and i want to share one
email with you so the father of four
children
three of whom spent their entire school
career at lca
my fourth child is currently a senior at
newfound regional high school so i think
my perspective might be unique my kids
have been served
very well by both schools
the three that went to lca it was the
right place for those kids
the one that's graduating
from newfound this year it's the right
place for that one
we're fortunate as a family and that my
wife and i both work to afford private
education
and we could make the choice we had the
resources to say you three go here
and uh and you go here
that's not true for a lot of families a
lot of families don't have the resources
to actually make an educational choice
for the kids
and i think the efas and the education
tax credits that that's a game changer
for these families that wish they could
perhaps do something different for the
kid that it makes a difference for and
are unable to do so
so i followed the debate
and the media
in the senate hearings a couple weeks
ago
and
it seems
as i hear people talk there seems to be
some confusion or maybe misinformation
i'm not sure what it is but
it doesn't appear to me that money is
being taken it's all what the money that
is as the adequacy aid
that goes with my kid has already been
allocated for my kid
it's just changing the place right now
my son is at newfound is getting the
state adequacy aid because he's at
newfound
the three well the three that went to
lca did not get any adequacy aid and
neither did the district they were in
so some of the questions about well were
you in private school before the efas or
not don't seem to matter because if they
were not they matter
if you ask them they matter for sure
but
if a child withdrew from a public school
prior to the efas the public school had
already lost that adequacy aid and my
understanding it's in the new hampshire
charitable or the new hampshire
education trust fund
it's still that child's
adequacy aid all the parents are asking
is that it follow them to the school of
their choice
and that makes sense to me
and and it's a portion of the aid that
the public schools are getting
right because the balance of that you've
got someone was talking about you know
18 000 kids and and 280 of them
are brand new into private schools and
that leaves about 1500 kids
that those public schools were not
receiving that adequacy aid last year
either
it was in the trust fund
and now we're taking those funds and
saying yes mom and dad if you think this
is the best choice
you can take that money with you and you
now can make the same decision for your
kids that my wife and i were able to
make for ours because we had the
resources to do that
in the lakes region it cost between 15
and 22 thousand dollars to educate a
student in a public school
and even without the average of four
thousand dollars in adequacy aid there's
eleven to eighteen thousand dollars in
resources that are left with that school
without a child to educate
um that seems to be in my opinion for
families who are trying to choose what's
best for their kid that seems to be an
appropriate split
uh i'm gonna con i continue to play
property taxes
and the town of bristol and we'll do so
for as long i'm not gonna leave the
state new hampshire i love it up here so
bristol will have my property taxes
forever
um and and i won't have kids in that
school and i have no problem with that i
think that's a fair thing to ask of me
i benefit from living here i benefit
from the living in that town and i and i
want to support that school
but i i do think it's fair to ask to
allow parents to have an option it's not
a lot
it's a small portion of what it costs to
educate a child that they're able to
take with them
so as i consider the positive impact of
the efas have had on students enrolled
in my school
and honestly
i know some of you may not like to hear
this but the relatively limited impact
on the public schools i wonder if this
debate hasn't become more about
the freedom to choose and it is about
money
when you look at i mean i just got an
email from one of my teachers uh i won't
tell you the district but they're about
to they're putting a bond out to spend
22 million dollars on a stem building
and we're talking about 1.8 million
dollars
this year
that didn't get stolen from anyone i saw
the signs at the senate hearing stopped
the steal the money's not being stolen
the money is being allocated differently
than it was being allocated before
unless i misunderstand something and i i
will stand corrected if i do
it's really not on us against them
private against public i've done both i
love both
it's really about choice and giving
parents an opportunity that some parents
don't have without the help that the
efas provide
so i want to encourage you to
to support put your support behind
parents and kids
not relatively well-funded public
institutions
um and if i could just share a real
quick um hopefully it comes up you know
this is do i have to identify the person
okay or the town okay then i can read it
i'll skip some stuff
this is a parent who is in our school
because of the efas
and is moving out of state and we we do
an exit survey with all our families and
this is what she said
see how i felt the survey we've been
overwhelmingly happy with the two years
the boys have been at lca
we employ two special edu certified
state-certified special education
teachers
heather's one of them so heather has
done so well with gabe and it's been
nothing short of america to watch him
grow academically socially as well as in
his faith
when he transitioned from his previous
school his spirit was broken he hated
school learning and emotionally was in a
tough spot
almost from the moment he started not
once did he flinch when it came time to
go to school
he has found his quirky humor and love
for learning again
the kid can't keep a secret and has
found trust and compassion in heather
and tells her everything
blake has turned into pre-teen overnight
he's grown strong a strong faith
foundation and devotion to god a kid who
two years ago struggled to write a
sentence and wouldn't be caught reading
anything but graphic novels has been
struck by lca's humanities class
he has found engagement in the subjects
to sustain his fleeting attention
they both love their time at lca and i
can only hope to find a schooling that
will meet all my kids needs after our
move
so if you have any questions related to
our school's experience with the efa i'm
happy to address them
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
don't see any thank you very much thank
you guys for sticking around so long
you're more than welcome have a good
drive
safe drive
this concludes our our hearing today and
i appreciate all the members of the
public that hung around here and hung in
we do appreciate it and thank you for
your participation thank you all
this hearing is closed
yes mr chairman could i just mention
these
um for the members um when i was just
coming back in i was giving
these cards that are filled out by kids
for each member if i could just pass
them out to everybody
as a reminder again
you